you
sorry
that is no longer allowed and
when called upon you should just jump
right into whatever question you have
and try to make sure you're not giving
lectures or
or
your own personal opinion especially
during the hearing process
and
the
meetings will go by much faster if we uh
try to adhere to that
okay so we're going to hear first hb
and
representative piemonte you're going to
introduce the bill
thank you mr i'm sorry
thank you for the reminder please stand
and join me in the pledge
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic we should stand one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all thank you
continue mr uh representative pimante
please thank you mr chair
um the bill i'm
talking about today i'm introducing
housefield 1026 i'm the main sponsor on
that
it's relative to the budget information
provided to a budget committee
and i'm going to read you the analysis
it's very easy very simple bill
bill provides that a municipal budget
committee may require that the governing
body
provide options in full line item detail
in active spreadsheet form
um some of you uh know uh from past with
me on this bill
i had house 14 house bill 1460
and
that went down in flames in the senate
because they tabled it
we did come to an agreement
the chair at the time was
chair carson
and between him i and uh
cordell johnson
we came up with a solution to my bill
because it was a little confusing
and it was a simple
uh bill and that's
a simple solution and that is
what you have
in front of you today
okay so
in committee
that bill
was itl
uh with the help of uh representative
mambuket
um like i say
chair carson and cordell johnson we came
up with one sentence
and that is what the analysis basically
says and if you look on the back
that
budget committee may require a governing
body to provide its budget
recommendations in full line of my item
detail and active spreadsheet form to
the members of the budget committee
and that allows instant decision
so someone at the budget committee comes
in with a motion well i'd like to say
maybe we'll
add two thousand dollars to this bill
to this line
and if they had what the line
covers say it was maintenance and repair
uh for vehicles
uh it would also show
um say tires you know
tune-ups or whatever maintenance they
may need to the bill
governing vehicles or tires for that
matter
so
they can put that figure in their
computer on their
desktop right at the meeting help school
board committees
come to a
a very solid decision whether it would
be good or bad
we did on in the house session
on that house bill 1460 we
amended that and we overturned the itl
i believe it was 283 to 8.
so
it was a a partisan bill and both sides
agreed to it
and unfortunately it was tabled in the
senate uh first time around i changed it
a little bit and they did make some
recommendations
to do that but they only went down a
couple of lines
uh in our first session and i thought
that i felt that this part here was
necessary for the people in the in
committee to actually do their job and
and it would be more kind of beneficial
and they would learn more about their
budget processes
and that's pretty much it and i'll take
uh some questions
yes uh questions from the committee as
uh representative rum
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
i'm curious um
is there anything that prevents a
governing body from doing this already
in a lot of cases not a lot i should say
a lot
i've seen
many cases that
they would have to take a vote
in order to to do this
and
a budget committee
in most places will go over each
individual lines but some don't some
come in and they say well this is our
budget
um
go through it you know and stack a paper
and
there's no uh no real
uh
digging into the budget itself
and they take a vote and if the vote is
not in favor of doing this it
goes back to uh their standard way of
developing their program
so it will help in that respect
do you know of any governing bodies that
already do this that can be used as a
best case practice sandown does it
actually okay um i had one individual he
was on there a couple years ago he used
to take his computer all the time and he
went to the to the office and he said i
need to download the budget to my
computer and he gave him a
thumb drive they put it on the thumb
drive and they they gave it to him he
worked it he worked that and that was
part of the reason why i started this
process two sessions ago
so um but like i say
some
some budget some governing bodies are
very amenable to uh this procedure and
they'll do that
others don't want to be bothered and
you know you know it all goes downhill
if you have uh
a high budget
you know sometimes we've heard testimony
on different things pertaining to the
budget so far
so
it's just one way of giving an
opportunity to not only the budget
committee to to learn more about it but
also project that to the people
listening and and and coming to the
meetings so okay thank you
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
so i understand what the intent of this
um bill is but i'm a little bit
concerned with the language
because
line three
the wording is may require to provide
so
that means what that's saying to me is
that the budget committee
they might or might not ask
this information from the
governing body
and additionally
is there anything that
compels or
forces
the governing body in response to to
actually provide the information i don't
see
a
shall
provide coming from the governing body
so i well i understand the intent
do you share do do you see what i'm
saying and i understand i can have an
amendment uh made to change made a shell
i just wanted to go easy on everybody
first you know
okay
yes representative clay
microphone i can't hear you
my apologies i just wanted to know what
the definition in this of governing body
and active spreadsheet
okay governing body is any any school
board any budget committee school board
committee budget committee um
and
active spreadsheet means
the one they're using now to present the
budget
follow-up sir yes thank you um but it
doesn't have to be the live spreadsheet
in other words you you it doesn't have
to be the live spreadsheet in other
words you said you would give them a
copy with a thumb drive so it's not
something that has to be
they can't edit what exists on on the um
okay i'm sorry i know i'm not being
clear so for instance if i make a change
to it just because i want to
diddle here to to see how i could change
the budget for a better it's not going
to change it on the the city the
municipal system correct that is correct
the the town the town city or um
governing the uh
pearson the people that generate the
budget will have a master copy that will
not change
and those will
be perfect perfect thank you very much
thank you representative for taking my
question um
so
that line number three the budget
committee may require a governing body
to provide its budget recommendations in
full line item detail and active
spreadsheet format so
when you say the budget committee
may require so all this takes
is a majority vote of the budget
committee
to require this to happen is that
correct
yes but representative power asked me to
change that made a
and if they ask for it they they will
get it and under those conditions
but it is
i'm sorry follow-up yes it is enabling
the budget committee doesn't have to do
this
at this point with that may in there
that is correct and and i probably
shouldn't uh change that i agree with
that because
if somebody does request a copy of it
they should be and they're on those
committees they should be able to see
the full budget
okay thank you
yes
oh sorry thank you mr chair
um
i'm following up on representative cle's
question about
the spreadsheet format because in the on
line
four it says full line item
detail in active spreadsheet format
so an active spreadsheet is it not
editable
yes of course it is and that will be
edited by the budget committee only or
budget committee member only
and
that would not affect the original
budget at all they could make those
decisions
from
the results of
a person questioning
um i would like to increase or decrease
this particular line
and this is the results that i have this
is what would happen
if i did that
okay so you can at your meeting at your
budget committee meeting you could say
well this is a good idea or a bad idea
uh you know and it gives them more
insight based basically in operating
that budget
follow-up mr chairman yes go ahead um do
you have any concern about the edited
piece of
the
budget committee has made their search
and found that this is a line item that
can be changed
do you have any concerns that
that can then be
like a screenshot and
post it on on social media as this is
what it should be
and and and then there's a
misinterpretation of what is actually
the budget no i i believe the budget
committee members are completely
responsible for their actions okay
and those will be the only ones that
will see this
it isn't posted to the public it isn't
posted on um any
facebook page or anything like that a
budget committee individual has that on
his computer
so he can do his job more effectively
in the budget process
thank you
yes representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
there's a big difference between uh the
word may and shall
shall is more
deter you know um represent your
question yeah so would you believe that
this would be too stringent
changing the word made to show
not at all it only applies to the budget
committee people and
it gives them the opportunity if they
want to do it they don't have to do it i
know on my uh
budget committee board for sandown we
had one person
request this
and any questions
were diverted by the chair
uh to the uh person can you look up on
the computer and say what that would
affect how that would affect this budget
that's plain and simple a quick
follow-up mr chair yes go ahead yeah
how would this impact right to no law
has nothing to do with the right to know
law budget committees are all public
okay any other questions for the
representative before i go to the public
yes
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i'm noticing in the
analysis that it states that the bill
provides that a municipal budget
committee
and
the language of the bill itself it only
references a budget committee so my
question is
based on the language of the bill and
not the analysis this bill covers
school district budget committees
because some municipalities the the
their school district is not under
municipal budget correct and that it's a
school does cover the school budgets by
requiring a government party to provide
like any further questions i think mr
mcguire
thank you
thank you representative
appreciate it thank you
okay for those of you in the audience
who have questions about
house bill 1026
please come up to the microphone
we're very clean
here yes
good morning chairman dolmen and
committee members my name is catherine
heck from the new hampshire municipal
association and originally we did not
intend on speaking on this bill as it
was written
as the amendment um
[Music]
has compelled me though to want to just
make some comments as to changing the
may to shall
it would be best practice that a
municipal budget committee which would
cover school districts they're all under
municipal budget law or towns
to be able to have access to a line item
detail when they are preparing their
budgets
when you change may to shell it will now
be a requirement it wouldn't be a
request any longer that each individual
committee could make it would have to be
required that this information be passed
in this way in active spreadsheet format
the concerns that i have is in best
practice and in the way most of our
municipal governments and i can't speak
to all schools but several schools there
is of course access to this information
and typically there is someone
especially when we're getting into four
and four and 500 page documents of line
items someone within the
office staff that kind of manages these
versions because when you start to
manipulate one line on page 280 that
could get missed in the in the final
budget so in many cases there's an
individual that attends all these
meetings that make sure that all of
these changes are made and recorded and
it certainly doesn't preclude any
committee member budget committee member
from having access to this information
but in the effort to make sure that
someone's not
at home
changing the spreadsheet and then that
change isn't properly discussed at a
meeting and then transposed into the
final budget those are the concerns that
we would have
so we do prefer the language of may so
it stays a local option and again in
practice this should already be
occurring so that the budget committee
can do its work
and i can take any questions that you
might have are there any questions for
the nhma yes representative clean
thank you mr heck
just just a quick one
having this document um in in a public
forum in electronic version does that
subject it to right to know by the
public to get a copy of this active
spreadsheet as well
i i would imagine that it would once a
majority of the committee would have
something it would become a public
record in electronic format i'm not
talking printed in electronic format
um
i don't know that that would be shared
in excel format with the public but
certainly in pdf format which they can
already request of course at any time
i just want to know about the electronic
thank you
u.s representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um is there anything in this bill that
prevents
the act of
i guess
i just need some clarification active
spreadsheet means um
editable so my question was
um
the wording of this bill
is it possible to
provide an uneditable i mean
certainly the
the purpose of the bill is to provide
the information
but if there's concern about things
being
changed
then
the solution would be to have it not be
editable
and
well typically um whether it's a hard
copy or pdf format that is what would be
provided to a committee and again some
committees do have access to an editable
spreadsheet and usually there's one
individual in charge of making sure that
that version
is done with fidelity and is then
reported as such moving forward through
this budget process so then it gets to
the time of the deliberative session or
the town meeting it is the accurate and
correct document too many people
accessing one document could lead to
just honest mistakes
any other
yes
representative
anja putin
thank you mr chair thank you uh for
taking my question
um you kind of answered part of it so
the budget isn't it true that the
budget is a working
document and
it is to be
[Music]
edited or modified
in consensus as a team because it's an
important numbers game that we're
playing so
this would allow
individuals like you said you know and
wouldn't that create more of a
bookkeeping
nightmare
potentially
representative
any other questions yes representative
thank you mr chair and thank you miss
heck for taking my question do you see
any
issue
um whether this be shall or may
aside do you see any issue between
having an advisory budget committee and
a budget committee that
is going to make final decisions about
the budget if if there's a request for
an active spreadsheet do you see any
issue there just on that one piece
my understanding with that this would be
required for the
official budget committees but again
even advisory committees should have
access to the line item detail that they
need to be even advisory in nature
so
the active spreadsheet format
is just a concern due to the multiple
versions that can start to be created
and then not properly transposed over
time because it's usually a six-month
process to do the budget so that would
be the concern that we have with the
active spreadsheet
but someone i think
well i'm
clear that a law was passed last year to
ensure that the public can have access
to the full line item detail now as well
so certainly um it's important that
everyone have the access that they need
to make proper
decisions and deliberate the budget
accurately and properly and i think that
is already occurring in most situations
if there's exceptions to that um
certainly the may versus the show should
alleviate that in some communities if
that's not the case
thank you any other questions
yes
[Music]
thank you
thank you very much
any other any other people wishing to
testify on this bill that are here
if you are
looking to testify
on this or a future bill make sure you
fill out one of these pink cards which
is over there by the clock
so we have a record of who's testifying
and who's not
yes
thank you
this closes the hearing on hb 1026
we'll start the next hearing in three
minutes
good job
um
uh
yeah next next tuesday
yes
okay
i'll make sure thank you
now
with their money
all right let's begin uh testimony on
house bill 1068
is there someone here to introduce the
bill
a representative or
okay
thank you representative majori
thank you mr chair thank you honorable
members of municipal and county
government for the record my name is jim
majorie representing
rockingham district 22 the town of
northampton
and i'm here to
introduce house bill 1068 the tiny bills
home
and make the request immediately that we
go to itl
on this bill after consultation with
many
industry experts about this bill
in spite of the fact or
recognizing the fact that
i have been invested in this since it
first came to municipality county
government
a number of years ago
there is
legislation there are updates
there is progress being made across the
country
that will address many of the issues
that are not addressed in this bill
right now to make it a much better bill
if we try to pass this bill
as it is right now
this will not be effective it will not
solve any problems in fact it may cause
more problems because it doesn't resolve
the issue of tiny homes on wheels
and that is the real issue
where we're trying to
find the codes find the standards find
the regulations that will make this an
effective piece of legislation
so with that said mr chair
i ask i respectfully ask that the
committee maybe even consider executive
session now on this bill to go to itl i
do also want to say that there have been
uh multiple attempts to reach out to the
prime sponsor on this representative
dave testerman
um we haven't heard back so i i
uh there there have been many attempts
to do that and i just want to make that
clear with that i will certainly take
any questions thank you representative
is there any objection
if we took this to executive session
right now
yes
mr chairman um may i ask a question of
the sponsor yes oh thank you
um thank you representative a question
some of the current concerns you have
about this bill can they be addressed
through amendment
thank you representative for the
question um
they could not because it would take a a
re it would require a rewrite of almost
everything that is in this bill
um it would not be something that we
could merely amend
um possibly i shouldn't say that it
possibly could be amended however
based on the advice that i have been
giving again from india industry experts
we might be able to just cut and pay
something
coming out of colorado right now that
will fix this it would just take a few
months better to do that and get it
right
then pass something now that is going to
have to be that's going to hemorrhage
that we're going to have to rework
better to take some time to do it right
once then half right twice does that
make any sense yes thank you
yes well thank you mr chair i'm not
opposed to going into executive session
thank you
representative thank you chairman and
representative maggiore am i correct in
understanding that the
international building code council is
actually working on this right now
and that new hampshire is looking at
building code updates that have to do
with tiny houses
thank you representative for the
question you are correct and to build
upon that right now tiny homes
a tiny home
could be built in the state of new
hampshire on a foundation appendix q was
adopted which sets the standards for a
tiny home we're really trying to get to
that piece about the on wheels you're
absolutely correct
we're halfway there we just need a
little more time to get all the way
there representative manjuputi
thank you mr chair um
thank you representative for taking my
question you answered part of my
question to
the previous
question
what other bills that you alluded to
other bills that are enabling tiny homes
what other that are currently law or
currently modified
that
can facilitate
a tiny home
thank you representative i understand
correctly
do you mean what what uh existing
legislation or standards exist
so again appendix q
will sets the definitions for what a
tiny home is a tiny home is a very
specific
structure
we can talk about a small home that's
different a tiny home is a specific
structure which has already set forth in
appendix q which those standards were
adopted
the end of last year as i recall so
again a tiny home
can be built on a piece of property as
long as your community allows that
see
someone have a question oh i'm sorry
representative tripp
thank you mr chair
and thank you
i i know nobody can see me i must be the
invisible man
uh
uh you mentioned uh appendix q
is that the uh
from some uh specification
thank you representative for taking the
question i apologize the speaker is
directly in the way so i'll stand over
i'll sit over here
i will get you the information i will
make sure the entire committee has
appendix q so you can review it and
where it comes from
thank you yep
okay
seeing no further questions from the
committee
i'll open it to the public if you want
to
you want to ask any questions please
come on up
oh my god i think i made this
there we go can you hear me great
uh thank you for uh taking public
comment on this issue today
um i'm a little curious to the last
excuse me
get your name yes sure thing i i put in
a card there my name is stephen daves i
live in manchester new hampshire got it
i had recently purchased some land in
manchester
i had contacted the zoning department
about building a tiny home and they had
told me if it's under 320 square foot it
is not legal
to build
so i don't know if that's
what appendix q references that you were
talking about but it seems contrary to
my personal experience
um
i did have some written comments but i
just wanted to address that first
because that was a little puzzling to me
looks like uh there's a representative
yes representative
uh
mr daves um i believe you will
i know the answer to this question
um
there's no way to formulate it as a
question so i'll pass
okay uh any other questions
yeah i just want to say that new
hampshire is facing the worst housing
shortage that we've had in our recorded
history as far as i can see
in january i checked the mls and there
were less than a thousand houses for
sale in the entire state
this problem has
essentially been created by restrictive
local ordinances that forbid
building and living in smaller homes
and lot utilization rules
according to the new hampshire coalition
to end homelessness there were 4
451 people
who experienced homelessness in 2021
and
1577 of those were families that
experienced homelessness
you couldn't even buy every home and
give them to the homeless people there's
not enough homes as it stands
allowing tiny home communities as listed
in the bill offers a legal and voluntary
solution
for philanthropists to create real
solutions right now to house the
homeless that are outside as we speak
please take a moment and imagine
sleeping outdoors
in this winter
i don't know if anyone here has thought
about that and what that's like
most of us have warm homes to go to
if you oppose this bill you're stopping
an actual solution to help 1005
families from freezing to death in the
cold
um so with that i'd be happy to take any
questions that any reps have
yes uh representative gallagher
yeah um could i just get um the spelling
of your name for note taking purposes
like is it a v or ph
yeah i did fill out a card and submitted
it it's ph
uh and last name dave's d-d-a-v-e-s
like i said it is on the car okay thanks
okay uh
seeing no further questions actually
there's one over here
yes representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
you said you have you purchased a piece
of land was it part of uh
you know tiny home community building or
is it a regular plot of land that you
buy
so it's a regular plot of land the most
common plot of land available in
manchester is r1a
it is the standard piece of land that is
actually the specific type of land that
this bill references
um
so that's why i felt that it was
relevant
any further questions for this witness
thank you mr jan thank you for taking my
question
um
has
the
homelessness
increased dramatically
since
two years in the last year or two
because
you stated that
this would help the housing shortage in
new hampshire and cordell johnson from
the new hampshire municipal association
said this is not a solution to the
housing shortage in new hampshire
okay well currently this would according
to the bill this would allow four tiny
homes to be put on a lot of land as i
read it i'm not a land use lawyer but
that seems to be the plain language in
the law
i believe last year just from my reading
from the new hampshire coalition to end
homelessness there were 35 encampments
that
required the police to go in and remove
the homeless people that had set up
encampments
so does that mean
that if 35 pieces of land were set up to
create homeless
tiny home communities that it would be
an availability i'm not sure i don't
have all the answers but i don't think
that preventing a solution that could
create more houses is a very
um
let's say heartfelt position for a
legislator to say when they themselves
have warm homes to go to at night
thank you
mr natch grace you had some comments you
wanted to give
thank you mr chair i don't really have
anything to add i'm happy to answer any
questions the community may have
i support the sponsor's recommendation
of itl
anybody have any questions for the nhma
seeing none thank you mr graves
next we have testimony from mary smith
are you here mary
hello
hey
go right ahead the floor is us
uh thank you
um
as
part of the uh portion of my testimony
that is actually written out
this bill takes tiny houses out of the
statewide legal gray area and makes them
explicitly lawful
while requiring them to meet life safety
codes and allow municipalities
some limited zoning control over them
it prevents municipalities from banning
tiny homes in single-family zones and it
allows tiny homes on existing
residential lots wherever detached
accessory dwelling units are allowed by
zoning
i guess this bill is a lame duck now
that the
prime sponsor isn't here and the
co-sponsor
is suggesting itl that's a real shame
because
aside from the comments from
the new hampshire municipal association
any additional housing that we can help
allow or create in this state is going
to mean
that there is less homelessness
and lower
rent and lower prices for everyone else
in the state
so i'm not exactly sure
[Music]
what his analysis includes it would be
interesting if
the municipal association was here
to make that case
um
but unfortunately
it uh
doesn't seem to
coincide with common sense that any
opportunity we have to make cheaper more
affordable housing in the state means
there will be fewer homeless in our
state so
any other questions
for ms smith
okay thank you very much
yes
i passed in a pink slip
i passed in a pink slip mr chairman
mr chairman and members of the
municipality county associate
committee i don't know where i am this
morning um i wanted to talk a little bit
about what i think is part of the
confusion that's happening this morning
um right now
under international building code the
ibc
there is an addendum which was adopted i
think at the end of last year
which is called appendix q
appendix q lays out the requirements for
a tiny house it talks about
cooking facilities sanitary facilities
adequate ventilation all of those things
and those refer to tiny houses that sit
on the ground so right now
you can build a tiny house in new
hampshire unless
the municipality in which you are trying
to build it
has a minimum square footage requirement
many jurisdictions have a minimum square
footage requirement of between three and
six hundred square feet some of them are
higher than that
so
if your jurisdiction
for example peterborough new hampshire
where i serve on the planning board um
right now we have an amendment going
forward in our code that removes the
minimum square footage allowance we used
to have a minimum square footage of 400
square feet for a studio 600 square feet
for a one bedroom
i recommend it to the planning board
that we amend that and remove the
minimum because that's controlled by the
international building code the
international building code makes clear
how
big the build the
uh a safe dwelling shall be and that's
for tiny houses that information is an
appendix q for anything that's not
considered tiny it's in the regular
international building code actually if
it's a single standalone building it's
in the
international residential code to be
precise so when people are having
trouble building a tiny house
at this point in new hampshire if it's a
tiny house
not on wheels
then what they are likely bumping up
against is their local zoning code and
the minimum square foot requirement that
is in that code
i just want to make that clear that
that's
it works across purposes to what the
state has done
with their building code and with that i
will take any questions thank you
representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i'd like to
understand can a tiny home on wheels
can is that permitted in a trailer park
in new hampshire
i don't know the answer to that question
that's
i i don't know representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
how does that apply to
micro or mini
condos or
structure on a complex
same thing
if your local code says that the minimum
square footage for a dwelling unit is
400 square feet it doesn't matter where
whether it's a single standalone cottage
or part of a 400 unit apartment
complex it has to be at least 400 square
feet
thank you representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so i understand that
with regard to the appendix q and the
international building codes
in terms of
i guess safety
that they
put forward minimum
square footage requirements as you've
explained so my question is is with
regard to a tiny home
so long as
the tiny home meets that building code
is there anything
that prohibits
a certain number of people from
domiciling or living in that space could
you have five people or you know four
people living in a tiny home
that would be up to the local health
officer in terms of how much there are
minimum square footages but that's
administered in a different place the
ibc has to do with the construction of
how it's used after it's constructed
falls into a difference under a
different
uh
supervision
seeing no further questions
thank you representative
okay the the uh
the pre-hearing
count on this
particular bill
1068 was nine four and nine against
you have a
another pink card coming in
oh
robert tardif are you here in the room
would you like to speak on this bill
you have two minutes mr charter
welcome
thank you i can be less than two minutes
if you'd like
uh thank you my name is rob tarda i'm
the administrator of the subsurface
systems bureau in the department of
environmental services
um we regulate on-site wastewater septic
systems
we also do subdivision of land
uh our only concerns really are about
wastewater and wastewater disposal
there's a line in the bill that says
alternatively there can be essentially
holding tanks in these
tiny homes whether it be for water
supply or wastewater
currently state law and our rules in the
env wq1000
prohibit holding tanks
well
45a 32
says nobody shall construct a building
that doesn't have an approved wastewater
system from the department
our rules
say that we don't allow holding tanks
except for in three
separate scenarios one is if you have a
failed system and there is no other
means for
a compliant on-site wastewater system
if you're about the second is if you're
about to be connected to a municipal
sewer within one year
and a third is for infrequent commercial
use
so
to
have holding tanks in a tiny home
contradict state law and state rule
so we
we're not opposed to the bill
we would support the bill with an
amendment to remove that statement about
alternatively
uh
self-contained i believe is the language
in the bill self-contained water and
wastewater
then the other comment we have in our
letter of testimony is regarding tiny
home parks
and we would like to see some language
added to that part of the bill
to basically
go along with our language regarding
mobile home parks
with the minimum lot size per per unit
that's your timer
i mean that was
pretty succinct i think on what the
department's position is i'd be happy to
take some questions any questions for
mr mr tarter from des
yes representative ron yeah thank you mr
chairman and thank you mr tarta for
taking my question
would
assuming a tiny home might house one or
two people
and suppose the state changed their
rules to allow holding tanks
how large a holding tank would one need
to
service the waste coming from that tiny
home from one or two occupants
currently our minimum holding tank size
is 2 000 gallons
which is a pretty significant size
volume a pretty large tank
so
if if this bill oh yes follow up thank
you mr chair so if this bill
you know maybe not this particular bill
but one that addresses the whole chassis
and wheel issue better if it were to
move forward would the
des be
amenable to discussions to allow a
holding tank for tiny homes if it was
large enough to service
one or two people in that tiny home for
a year or two before it would need to be
pumped out
uh i would say never say never kind of
okay answer uh what one of the main
concerns about holding tax and i'll try
to be brief again
is the expense that it that people incur
when it comes to actually having these
holding tanks pumped
and having the wastewater disposed
what we find happens is either holes
mysteriously get punched in these
holding tanks or
the material is removed and disposed in
other maybe
illegal methods
so those are those are the main reasons
why we try to discourage the use of
holding tanks
so it's it's not a matter of you know
if the holding tank is working you know
and it's
structurally sound and watertight it's
not really an environmental issue it's
more of the reality of the costs and
what happens to as a result of the cost
to disposal of the of the waste
just one more follow-up one more thank
you mr chair
those issues you described about holding
tanks would they not be true of also
septic tanks
uh not necessarily because with a septic
tank the effluent is leaving the tank
uh so when you get a tank pumped you can
get a tank pumped
you know every uh can depending on use
but uh every two three years
because the effluent's being disposed of
in a wastewater in a leech field
right and that wastewater is being
treated by the soil and
okay and that kind of thing thank you
you see no further questions for mr
tardiff thank you very much for your
testimony thank you very much for for
your time
at this point in time
i've been encouraged by those around me
to
take this
particular bill to the next step
which will be
executive session
so during executive session we we change
a little bit how we operate
there will be no input from the public
and
the committee members
will discuss the bill
uh among themselves
and uh and then we will take a vote
on the bill
so and close the bill uh close hb
1068 the hearing of it but
specifically and we're now opening
1068 for executive
uh review
mr
mr chair uh
we should have pleased the committee i
would move itl for house bill
1068 and if there is a second i'd be
happy to speak to my motion a second
motion's been made and seconded is there
any further discussion on the bill yes
representative wrong
i just want to state that
my support of the itl doesn't reflect
on my position on tiny homes i think
tiny homes are a great thing not just do
they address the housing issue the
housing needs of people that are lower
income but it provides a way for people
that just want to live a more simply a
simple life with less consumption to be
able to have their their housing reflect
that
thank you
any other yes representative
thank you mr chair um
i see uh why the prime sponsor is our
co-sponsor is asking for an itl we had
this last term too
but there is a place for the tiny homes
and i'm encouraged with the fact that
there is appendix q
that can give
some somewhat you know not 300 square
foot but at least a 400 square foot
which can
provide that um
smaller than you know smaller tiny home
opportunity or mini condos so
i'm hoping that we can offer those
opportunities for folks that need in our
state representative
thank you
thank you mr chair uh i while i
just fully endorse the idea of the tiny
home
um
i think as the co-sponsor said it this
isn't ready for
prime time and one of my concerns is
that
is the wheels problem because
[Music]
the last couple of years we passed some
legislation about taxation of
of year-round camp campers in
campgrounds
that are now being taxed for
structures that are affixed to them
and doing this on wheels brings to me
brings up to me the same question how
would it be taxed
okay
yes representative
gallagher
so um i'd just like to echo the previous
speaker's
comments um and would just like to raise
a point about procedure um since this is
the
second year of
a two-year legislative term
well in previous years
if we had concerns about or in the
previous half of this term if we had
concerns about a bill we might have
voted to retain it or refer to interim
study or something but
since we're in the second year of the
term that means we won't have time to do
either of those
so
um
yeah if
if we
if this had been a year earlier i would
avoid to retain our interim study but
since we're running out of time um the
only way to postpone it at this point is
would be itl
representative
thank you uh
full disclosure i just told uh
representative maggiore this my oldest
child lived in a 240 square foot tiny
house built inside of a 1995 school bus
for four years in vermont
but what i want to say is i hope that i
made clear in my testimony that the
issue now
for tiny homes not on wheels is
primarily local zoning ordinance
representative maggiore just told me
that in
northampton the minimum square footage
for for a house or a dwelling unit is
725 square feet
that is unconscious unconsciousable
people need to attack this is the thing
that can be done at the local level go
in talk to your planning board ask them
to lift the minimum you don't need a
minimum square foot
all of those health and safety issues
are dealt with by the international
building code and appendix q
just get rid of that minimum and then
people can build tiny houses
any further comments uh questions
okay seeing none uh at this point we're
going to take a vote so
um
would you uh
let me review the emotion has been made
to itl this bill
and it's been seconded
so now
we're going to take a vote
we're going to ask the
committee clerk to take a roll call vote
and then we'll disposition the bill
okay uh it'll on hb 1068
representative monty yes
click votes yes representative tripp yes
representative guthrie yeah
representative los alas yes
uh representative mcbride representative
melvin yes
representative yeah uh representative
power
yes
representative tray 11 representative
gilman
yes
representative mijori
representative davis uh representative
megaputi yes
representative van
yes
uh representative clee
representative gallagher
yes
and representative ryan yes
and chairman dolan yes
motion passes 15-0
okay so with without objection i'll
place this bill in the consent calendar
going forward
and that closes the
activity on
house bill 1068
okay we're going to move on to house
bill
do we have
an introduction to the bill
thank you
representative rose the floor is yours
thank you uh
mr chairman and good morning to all my
honorable colleagues for the record
i'm representative michael vose
i represent rockingham district 9 the
town of epping
i serve in this house as chair of the
house science technology and energy
committee
and i also serve on the
planning board in my town of epping and
i'm here this morning to talk to you
about
affordable housing
i have submitted written testimony
about a week ago i hope all of you have
had a chance to take a look at it
the reason i filed this bill is because
new hampshire has a persistent problem
with having more jobs than we have
people who can
accept and take those jobs and work
those jobs
now part of that might be demographic
but part of it might be because
people can't find places to live
if you can't find a place to live you
can't take a job
near
unless you can find a place to live near
where that job is located
i've lived in epping for 14 years
since i've moved there i've watched
literally hundreds
of single-family homes constructed
all of them
in the three
four and five hundred thousand dollar
range
homes that you would probably not
consider
affordable
and our town facebook page
is frequently populated with messages
from people saying
in search of or in need of
an apartment a two bedroom apartment for
twelve or thirteen hundred dollars
there are very few apartments in epping
and in fact in rockingham county
the average rental for a two bedroom
park apartment is 1652
which is the most expensive
average rental in the entire state of
new hampshire
rockingham county is the most expensive
place in the state to live
both for single-family homes and for
affordable homes
so what's really the definition of
affordable housing
it's housing that you can afford to move
into
if you make
of the average median income
in the area where you live
so in rockingham county the average
median income
is
significantly high
compared to other parts of the state and
that's what drives up the cost of
apartment dwelling to over sixteen
hundred dollars a month
and that pushes it out of the affordable
range
the other thing that distinguishes
affordable housing from other kinds of
housing is it typically
is
multi-family dwelling units
it's not single-family dwelling units
it's multi-family apartment buildings
or
houses that have been
converted to apartments
in dover if you ride through dover
you'll see
many of these great big huge houses that
were built 150 years ago
when people had big families but now
many if not most of those buildings have
been converted to apartment buildings
they contain
two three four five apartments
and those units are more affordable
for a person to live in than buying a
single family home in fact in dover
single-family homes are
the median price now is over five
hundred thousand dollars for a single
family home in dover
now in my
written testimony i provided a link
to a study that was done by saint
anselm's university recently
to try to uncover
the causes of
unaffordable housing in new hampshire
and if you read that study or took a
quick look at that study one of the
things one of the things that reveals is
that
heavy duty land used regulation
is one of the causes of our lack of
affordable housing in this state we have
driven up
through land use regulations
the cost of housing all across the state
but especially in the most populated
counties like rockingham and
hillsborough
so i have filed this bill in an attempt
to chip away at some of the
regulation
that is inhibiting the development of
affordable housing
now the bill i submitted
initially or the bill as introduced
i will concede is somewhat vague
and
possibly even toothless
what it does is it
amends the
workforce housing general provisions for
planning and zoning
declaration of purpose to say that
you can't prohibit workforce housing
in any defined zone well that's kind of
vague
i admit so i have prepared an amendment
that
addresses this issue
it um
clarifies exactly what i mean
and would like to accomplish and i'm
going to pass out
uh this amendment so you can all take a
look at it and i would like to discuss
it discuss it if that's okay with the
chairman yes we can discuss it but we're
not going to take a vote on it until we
go to executive session understood
understood
so
thank you to representative power for
passing out the copies of the amendment
and also
thank you to representative power
who made a couple of suggestions uh to
me as i was
thinking about preparing this amendment
and her suggestions were incredibly
helpful
so what i've done in the amendment is
i've spelled out
well what exactly are we talking about
when we're talking about
affordable housing
so the language now says
that it would be
you would be prohibited
uh
on the building of
or you would be prevented from
putting into your land use zoning
requirements prohibitions on the
building of multi-family dwelling units
in residential or non-residential zones
that spells it out
spells out what is an affordable unit
and where it could
or could not go and by
using the language residential or
non-residential that basically means you
can go anywhere
where it's reasonable to put it
and then to give the
the bill a little teeth as it were
i've also added a
uh
a similar phrase
to the
innovative land use control
section of statute
to provide an incentive for people to
actually
consider
doing this
so this amendment i think significantly
strengthens the bill
makes it
more understandable
as well as gives it some teeth
to make it implementable
so this bill hb 1238 is basically a
modest expansion of rsa 672
it chips away but a little bit of the
heavy duty regulation to which we
subject
land use here in new hampshire
and it may be one small
step
toward helping us provide more
affordable energy of affordable housing
rather in our state
with that i think i'll i'll conclude my
testimony and i'd be happy to answer any
questions
representative votes do you have
already assigned the the amendment to
anyone in particular to complete that
we're going to probably
execute this bill
i'd say the middle of next week
uh i was hoping that representative
power would take that on but i can't
speak for her
yes um thank you mr chair
so
this is a process question
and
due to the fact that representative vose
has
submitted this amendment
i guess prior or during the hearing
does he need another co-sponsor
no no
okay
okay uh questions from the committee yes
representative vann
thank you chairman and thank you
representative vos for taking my
question um i
uh am curious about this amendment to a
section 3e
where you say not limited to
provided that such units meet all other
applicable standards
the issue i am asking about is
lots of and i'm sure epping is the same
way a great deal of your residential
area is zoned single-family only so are
you assuming that that's a standard
because typically i don't think we would
consider that a standard
thank you for the question
what i was referring to
by applicable standards are essentially
building codes
zoning ordinances that affect parking
lot size
that type of thing not anything having
to do with
what's applicable to the zone
in total but applicable to building
units
okay so
can you tell me how much of eppings
residential area is zoned single family
only
i couldn't give you an exact percentage
but i'd say it's close to 70 percent
one more follow-up so i'm not sure can
you explain to me how this is going to
help
if 70 is single family only and this
does not address that issue
uh
what's your anticipation here
well i think it does address the issue
because it gives an incentive
to
a
builder if he so desires to build an
apartment unit in a residential zone
and
he could also build an apartment
building in a non-residential zone
it's a property rights issue if someone
owns property
and
they decide they want to sell it to
someone who wants to build an apartment
building
they should have the right to do that
okay representative matchapootie
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
um
my question is you have added in your
amendment the inclusionary zoning
and which
some communities have
adopted
and it only applies to
of a new development that they can um
ask for a multi-family
still does not address like my colleague
just asked about
zoning in terms of single-family homes
and the developer can own
somebody owning a land to put up
the local ordnance local zoning
has to work with
the developer just by owning a piece of
land
you still have to abide by what's
currently in existence
this does not
give much change to that
how do you explain that
well as i said in my
thank you for the question
representative as i said in my uh
original testimony this is a a bill that
chips away at land use regulation it's
it's not a huge change
but i'm hopeful that it will
prod
local communities as they craft
future
land use regulations
to consider the possibility
that affordable housing needs to be
accommodated in a better way than we do
today
i'm not entirely certain
exactly what you were asking uh if you
could clarify a little bit maybe i can
give you a better answer
thank you
my question is
this will only enhance a large developer
or support a
landowner
in terms of developing i just have a
single family home with a modest
air you know it doesn't help
somebody if i'm willing to do expand on
my single family lot
it doesn't give me a whole lot of um
to do that
currently
thank you for the clarification yes uh
it is an incentive it's not a not a
mandate certainly
it's just an incentive to a developer
to be able to to consider
putting an affordable housing unit on a
piece of of property
now
existing regulations that are in effect
would still apply so for example
if you live in a single family home and
there's a empty lot next door to you and
somebody buys it and wants to put up a
multi-family home you're in a butter and
so
you can still make objections
to
the planning board or other local
planning organization
when that site plan is originally
offered
and if there are a sufficient number of
a butter objections
then the
planning board or other organization
would have to make a decision about
whether to go forward with that or not
that would still be the case
even though we've provided in this in
this legislation an incentive
for developers to consider
a multi-flam multi-family dwelling unit
in a residential
or even other zone
industrial commercial for example
we had a case in epping
where we have a a zone that's
industrial commercial and someone came
in and proposed a 315 unit apartment
building
and
there is a federal law that says if 20
percent of such a
a
development is workforce housing then
it's allowed in a commercial industrial
zone
so
this would
this bill would reinforce that federal
legislation
okay if there are no further questions
i'm going to go to the public
thank you representative
and first we'll have
mr pollock
yes
welcome
thank you good morning i'm ari pollock
i'm with the law firm of gallagher
callahan and gartrell
excuse me here in concord i've been a
land use lawyer for about 25 years
still hard to hear myself say that
but i'm also a lobbyist for the new
hampshire home builders and we're here
today to support the bill
frankly we support any well-intentioned
effort to develop additional housing and
in particular workforce housing
our members build housing it's no
surprise we want to build more but we
also rely upon and require
a workforce and a labor force and it's
becoming an increasing struggle to find
people who are able to work for our
members who have those skills who have
the ability to to live near where they
work and afford housing where they work
and so we're not only building for
customers we're building for ourselves
we're building for our workforce
and we're building for the state
we support therefore the diversity of
housing stock not everyone wants not
everyone can afford a single-family home
and workforce housing and multi-family
housing
serve some of those needs
this bill helps it may be a small step
as the sponsor explained and frankly i
view this from a legal perspective of
putting another thumb on the scale when
a case involving workforce housing or
multi-family housing or inclusionary
zoning
reaches the courthouse and a judge has
to decide whether or not a community has
acted fairly reviewed things fairly
whether they're rejecting a proposal
because of the merits of the proposal or
because of the population served by the
proposal
i think those are critical
distinctions to be made when housing
projects come through
the process
and so we're just looking at the
amendment to the bill this morning like
the rest of you but it all appears to be
a well-intentioned effort to open up
more opportunity for housing in new
hampshire
it's amending a statute that's already
on the books a statement of purpose
that's already on the books
and a statement of purpose that's
already been tested in court on multiple
occasions and frankly can use all the
support that it can get so we're here to
briefly explain our support uh for the
concept behind the bill and to thank the
sponsor for putting it forward
questions
yes
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question um
how would you characterize this is like
i asked the priya the prime sponsor
does this only support landowners in the
developers or
is there a counter that can also
facilitate small
independent
single-family homeowners that can
create multi-dwelling units on the
currently existing
it's a difficult question to answer
based on the language i see in the bill
as introduced and in the amendment i
think certainly the intention is to
provide support for both of those
scenarios
and i know
the inclusionary zoning portion for
example in 674-21
that's enabling language that the state
is providing to municipalities to enact
those types of ordinances it could only
help in those circumstances so i think
it would be both
follow up yes
thank you mr chair um
so
is my understanding correct
that it's enabling currently focused on
multiple you know the large developer
but not
independent except for the inclusionary
zone that we see in
our
amendment most ordinances define
multifamily as three units or more so it
does not need to be a particularly large
development project to be classified as
multi-family i think people hear the
phrase multi-family and they think large
rental apartments in a large complex
with multiple buildings that that is
that is rarely the case in the more
rural parts of the state so i think it
could very easily benefit either a
private landowner or a private developer
not a corporate entity
one last follow-up mister
one more okay thank you so how would
this address the crisis or the need for
missing middle
housing in our state
i think a number of these projects are
disadvantaged at the local level because
of the notion that they're bringing in
folks from outside of the community who
who may not be
of the higher income levels
i think this fills that middle by
providing some more support for those
projects if and when they reach the
courthouse and the reasons for the
treatment at the local level are
explored whether you want to talk about
the housing appeals board the superior
court there are forums where these the
rationale of the local boards is
examined and this type of language is
very helpful in figuring out whether or
not those bodies have done their job
yes
gilman
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
do you have any concerns about the
about including non-residential zones
and the mixture of perhaps
light industrial or industrial
businesses with uh with dwelling units i
would have concerned in terms of mixture
of uses if the language behind it wasn't
also provided which is meeting
applicable other other applicable
standards i think that modifies the
concern
yes
representative
yes sir uh thank you for taking my
question i'm over here there you are
i represent uh
the town of litchfield which has
the overwhelming majority of the town is
single-family housing but we do have
over 55 housing which is
a development where
i assume that the requirement is that
you're
you're over 55 and you don't have young
children
and and that's fine for those people
but
in this case
why couldn't we have housing
similar to over 55 communities
that are
for instance under 40.
right so the over 55
category over 62 category those are
essentially legally discriminatory
practices it's a it's a specialized
recognized um subset of elderly and
there is no prohibition against having
children in those developments it's just
less likely because of the age group of
the owners uh and so
you know having something that says uh
you know for under 40
that that would be discriminatory in a
way that has not been recognized as
legal it's well beyond my pay grade to
to decide whether we should or shouldn't
have it but there's the distinction
any further questions for
mr
i think there's one here
to my right representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
uh
with regards to the other applicable
standards
uh
could you give me some examples of uh
what these other applicable standards
would be
yes that was a good question asked
previously of the sponsor and as i
understood his answer it was things that
i would consider to be in the category
of dimensional requirements do you meet
setbacks do you have proper parking
loading can you achieve the proper
loading for whether it's an on-site
septic system or does the sewer capacity
uh achieve the project's needs um things
of a of a more technical nature
than what i would call of a use nature
thank you welcome
any uh questions from the public from mr
paul
seeing none thank you for your testimony
my pleasure thank you for having me
next we're going to hear from
nhma
thank you mr chair and h grace for the
new hampshire municipal association i
actually get to support this bill
we
nhma does have a policy that recognizes
the need for diverse and affordable
housing in new hampshire and we support
legislation that allows municipalities
to
require the inclusion of affordable and
diverse housing
opportunities as part of new housing
developments i think as was described in
previous testimony this provides further
incentive for municipalities to look at
what they're doing look at their zoning
codes and provide more opportunities for
affordable housing and that's why we
support it i'm happy to answer any
questions that committee members may
have yes representative
thank you mr chair thank you mr greece
for taking my question same question i
asked the previous
speaker
how would you characterize
this
bill
with other bills that are in our
committee to help with increasing the
densities
that would help
individual homeowners increase the
density in their property
i'm not i'm not sure exactly how it help
individual homeowners i would say as far
as
asking municipalities to look at
increasing density opportunities in
their zoning
this certainly
bolsters what the legislature already
has an effect
to say this is something that they want
municipalities to look at
especially with that missing middle
um as mr pollock indicated uh the
multi-family is often defined as as
three units or or more so it's possible
that could help uh help that type of
opportunity arise
yes
yes go ahead
mr grays
i thought that nhma opposed all
statewide zoning ordinances does this
not require places to allow multi-family
in places that they don't now can you
explain to me uh in hma's change of
heart we we do oppose all state-wide
zoning mandates but we we also uh
because an innovative land use control
is a local option not a mandate it would
be something adopted at the local level
and therefore we would be able to
support it
in in conjunction with our policy on
housing opportunities
so this only applies to communities that
have adopted
uh
innovative land use policies
correct under the statute correct so it
would have to it's a it's a local option
okay great thanks
okay uh any
final questions for the nhma
thank you
thanks
i'm going to close the hearing on
i'm sorry i do have one more speaker
so i'm not going to close the hearing
mary smith
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee
um
this bill strengthens the state's
workforce housing law by preventing
local governments from prohibiting
workforce housing development in any
district that meets other applicable
standards
presumably including life safety codes
it is unclear how stringently this law
would be interpreted and its literal
interpretation and this is talking about
not the amendment haven't had time to
review the amendment
and its literal interpretation
the new law could represent a massive
statewide deregulation of housing
in which every single district
must allow affordable housing to be
built over the state's entire territory
but the law could be interpreted
narrowly
simply making the existing requirement
that every municipality must provide at
least one pathway to building workforce
housing more explicit
without explicit preemption of lot sizes
setbacks floor area ratios parking
minimums minimum house sizes and so on
municipalities could probably find a way
to evade this
as they already are doing
so
uh in any event it does end up
being a local control sort of local
option
um
thing
uh
again not considering
uh what
changes the amendment uh would have on
this bill so i just encourage the
committee
to
consider
uh doing something today to improve the
state of
new hampshire affordable housing
so please
do not vote to itl this bill
if you want to do something today
anything today to
improve uh housing costs and access to
affordable housing in this state
thank you thank you
okay this uh this bill received support
of 16 people
and
those opposing with zero
so
fewer information
we're going to close the hearing now on
house bill 1238
and open a hearing
on house bill 1119.
good morning mr chairman my name is
representative david muse
i am here
in place of the sponsor of this bill
representative nicole klein knight
and thank you for giving me an
opportunity to uh to present this bill
to you i know this is something you
folks have seen before i hope the
approach that we're taking this time is
something that can meet with your
approval
what the bill would essentially do is to
allow new hampshire cities and towns to
regulate the distribution of single-use
plastic bags
to their customers
as they see fit
and that's basically it
this is not a plastic bags ban this is
not a tax on plastic bags this
essentially says
that if your community and this is an
issue
for the people in your town or the
people in your city
you have the ability under new hampshire
law to pass regulations that would
impact
the distribution of single-use plastic
bags
the bill as it's written would amend the
municipal ordinance statute that's rsa
31 colon 39
to include a new provision
related to single-use plastic bags
and again what it would do is it would
give municipalities the option of doing
this uh it is not a mandate uh it is not
a requirement
um
one of the
one of the big issues with uh with
single-use plastic bags and a lot of
plastic
plastic materials that are put out into
our environment these days
is that
they are many times billed as being
recycled recyclable
but the simple truth is is that they are
really designed to be disposable and the
vast majority of people
simply dispose of them
and this is why they wind up in our
landfills they wind up on the side of
the road they wind up as litter
they wind up along beaches in places
like portsmouth where i and seabrook
so this is a this is an issue uh that in
a maybe in a small way
we can begin doing something uh to
uh to help the environment a bit
the other thing i think that sometimes
flies under the radar a little bit with
plastic bags is they are made from
fossil fuels
so one of the things that continually
churning out an endless supply of
plastic bags and plastic materials does
is it actually makes
the climate problem that we have just a
little bit worse
so
this is a proposal that a lot of people
have been behind
uh for many years i know there have been
several attempts to get various uh
versions of this
through the legislature
this would simply give communities
like mine the ability
to regulate single-use plastic bags
without having to worry uh
any longer about whether or not that's
something that is permissible under
state law
and i can take any questions any
all questions yes representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
my question is
in the seacoast and the
communities that attract a lot of
tourists
and
during summer and the population
fluctuates
how would this help
those small communities to deal with
plastic waste
benefit
it helps them by having less of plastic
waste to deal with i think that's really
the the intent of the bill
so part of what this bill could do
depending on how different
municipalities implement it
is it could begin to
constrict the supply or the amount of
this material that actually goes out
into
uh into the world
from stores from businesses and places
like that
there are many different options that
communities have for doing this and
one of the things that you can do is you
can just google municipal plastic bag
bans
and what it'll do is it'll take you to
pages where you can see
state laws that are that have either
banned them or restricted them in some
way you can see municipalities um it's
dozens of states at this point and and
it's hundreds of municipalities so this
is something that is happening
across the country and it would be
uh it would be a good thing if our
communities had the option to do this
and
my community in portsmouth we have kind
of come up against this several times
we have a very active high school
environmental club
that over the years has uh
has proposed this to our city council
portsmouth is actually the the only
state
in new hampshire or the only city in new
hampshire right now
that actually
has any kind of
regulations or restrictions on
on styrofoam
and on a
plastic uh single-use plastic
disposables
and uh
those particular regulations have been
written with the knowledge that the
state uh you know that this is not
something
uh that
there isn't blanket permission to do
this across the board
however
our council
was confident that new hampshire's
municipal waste laws uh do allow for
some of the things that have been done
so for instance
portsmouth's ordinance is not a total
ban
one of the things that portsmouth
ordinance does
is it restricts uh the distribution of
us things like styrofoam containers and
single-use disposables on city property
there are um
exceptions to that
um
there is also
another ordinance that restricts the
distribution of styrofoam containers
and so one of the things that just sort
of happened in our experience
is that a lot of this this a lot of this
coincided with the cobit period
and so a lot of restaurants and
businesses that normally use these
materials were really kind of taking a
second look at this you know they wanted
something that was environmentally sound
they wanted something that was cost
effective
and where a lot of a lot of them have
landed as they've landed on paper
products
and they've also landed on
on things that are
recyclable so one of the problems with
both plastic bags
and with styrofoam is neither one of
them is recyclable
and a big problem with plastic bags in
particular is that if people put them in
their recycle bins and you see that a
lot if you have newspapers and a lot of
people will look for something to put
the newspapers in
those those plastic bags can actually
follow up recycling equipment and that
can actually add costs for
municipalities and it can there can be
extra costs
to sort through
material that has a lot of plastic bags
in it and things like that
so for a lot of reasons
it makes sense
to
let communities chart their own path
when it comes to this depending on
things like the extent of their
recycling programs depending on things
like
are they in a tourist area where you're
going to have you know beaches and
recreation and where you know having
this this litter would be an issue um
uh
you know
in portsmouth we have hundreds and
hundreds of restaurants we have a lot of
we have a lot of supermarkets we
generate
a lot of disposable material and this is
a way of just sort of helping us start
to get a handle on the amount of waste
that we generate
and the amount of waste that we put into
our environment
before we go to the follow-ups we have a
whole slew of people who want to speak
on this so i'll come back to you for a
follow-up later
um
mr
bruce burke
are you here
come on up
and am i done you're all done okay thank
you did oh i'm sorry before before you
leave
uh representative mcdonald had a
question for you
yes sir
thank you for taking my question
representative
i know some of the communities in
massachusetts have
adopted similar policies that you want
to adopt in the state of new hampshire
there have been many failures in those
communities confusion to the public
you know do i get a plastic bag don't
get a plastic bag
and i'm trying to figure out how you're
going to determine that we don't have
those same failures in new hampshire
i'm sorry we don't have what in new
hampshire the same failures that
massachusetts has had in some of the
communities where some communities adopt
a policy of yes we take plastic bags
others no we don't
well part of
i think part of
part of the reason for this bill and and
one of the things that we went through
in portsmouth is this wasn't just
something that was proposed one night
and everybody agreed to it
this is something that's been debated
over a period of many years in
portsmouth so i think
at least three or four years that i'm
aware of
it was proposed in several forums shot
down in several forums and finally it
was passed
but it was passed with a lot of local
debate and it was passed with a lot of
local input
and one of the things that was part of
our debate were
local issues
you know i'll give you an example um in
doing things like banning styrofoam from
city locations to put food in
um there were people who were very
concerned about
folks who may have bought supplies
of of styrofoam containers and who had a
lot of them on hand
they're not cheap
so there's an exception and there was an
exception in the local in the local
ordinance that allows people
who who did buy stocks to use those to
use those stocks up
um there were other exceptions for
non-profit groups who who rent out city
facilities and things like that
so i think one of the things that we
found is that at a local level
we can be very much in tune
with with local concerns and i'm not
saying that
you know we're doing it perfectly i
think we're sort of going along and sort
of seeing how things work and people are
probably fully expecting to have to
tweak it at some point way down the road
but having the flexibility to do that
and not having to deal with you know
a one-size-fits-all mandate imposed from
the state
which is something that that could come
at some point
i think would tend to work better for a
lot of communities in new hampshire just
because of the independence that you
refer to
thank you for your explanation uh
regulating is a very broad word
and couldn't if this was approved
couldn't a
community say okay we're going to keep
plastic bags we're going to make
everyone pay 10 cents a bag if they want
to use one
well you could i mean you know
essentially the bill is yours now so you
can do whatever you want to it but the
reason for keeping it broad uh was to
really just give municipalities uh the
maximum amount of flexibility uh to
enact regulations that
really meet the needs of their citizens
meet the needs of their situation
not everyone is going to want to charge
for them
there are also debates about where the
money goes
does it go to our community recycling
program does it go back to
the
the the restaurant owners and merchants
and you know where does that 10 cents go
so
one of the things i think sometimes is
that
we
you know we we try to solve all the
stage problems up here at the state
house um when there are people who are
perfectly capable of solving problems
for their communities in those
communities
and
what we're really just trying to do here
is to let them do
what people in local communities elected
them to do
thank you representative thank you
representative
just to be fair
thank you thank you mr chair thank you
uh representative for taking a follow-up
um single-use plastics
would also
um
enhance or
wouldn't that
help with more recycling better
recycling and a locally produced
reusable
i mean recycled product from the
single-use plastic versus mixed-use
recycling stream which can
uh the single-use plastic can
pollute or
i don't want to use the word corrupt but
it kind of could reject the whole bug
i'm not sure i'm not sure i understood
you okay let me
phrase the question it's in so many
broad sections
um single-use plastic this providing
this opportunity to separate and
single-use plastic will also wouldn't it
also help with
doing a recycle recyclable product for
example in vermont they do the
chairs
uh plastic chairs the adirondack chairs
using the single-use plastic
similarly but if it is mixed in with a
multi-stream or mixed stream
it can reject the whole stream because
of the single use yes and and one one of
the things that that this that you know
one of the impacts that legislation like
this could have is it could allow
communities to actually kind of clean up
their recycling streams a little bit
um so a lot of disposables uh that
aren't recyclable wind up in in in
recycling streams and that costs
municipalities extra money
um and i think as we all know recycling
programs these days are not uh are not
inexpensive there's a there's a
significant cost to having one of those
and a lot of our communities we but we
still we still uh we still do want them
so if you have fewer fewer disposables
following up your your recyclables and
then when
when restaurants and and when business
owners do provide single-use plastics
they provide them in a form that that is
recyclable um you know that that's
something that
again can
can help significantly representative
thank you for taking my question um
what do you
think will it will be
an alternative
let's say a grocery store
if they prohibited single-use plastic
and paper bags
what would they use
i think i think there are grocery stores
now that provide uh that provide paper
bags so um
trader joe's i think is one grocery
store in portsmouth they no longer
they no longer give out plastic bags at
all um all of the bags that they uh
that they give out when customers come
into the store and buy things are paper
um
and
a lot of people are also bringing in
their own uh
permanent bags yep like you've got right
there
i have four of them out in my car right
now i use them every time i go grocery
shopping although sometimes i do forget
i think everybody forgets
but the um
but the issue you know
one of the things i do want to say is is
i think that some of the grocery stores
we have in new hampshire like market
basket are to be commended
because they have made it
a lot easier for people to bring their
used bags back into the the supermarket
so they can be properly disposed of and
hopefully recycled
um
but but again that's only a very very
small percentage of of the bags that
actually
leave a store like that like that so
only a very very small percentage
actually come back and get recycled
follow-up
yes thank you for taking uh my follow-up
but the proposed bill
has language that says they can regulate
the distribution of single-use plastic
or
and
paper bags
so a grocery store
would not be able to offer
plastic or paper so they would have to
offer something like this or something
else
well there's actually no requirement in
the law as is written for a grocery
store to do anything unless a
municipality tells them that they have
to do something differently
but the reason for paper bags is that
paper bags are a lot of times are put
out there as an alternative so for
instance there are some communities that
say
uh we don't want you to uh to distribute
plastic bags anymore instead
we would like you to offer paper bags
and and charge people ten cents a bag or
five cents a bag or or whatever uh
whatever that the community thinks is uh
is fair
uh the idea is to really
is to really change behavior um
the the plastic bags as they now stand
they're just
amazingly convenient for a lot of people
we've grown used to something that 20
years ago we didn't necessarily have
um
and uh and and i think a lot of people
do appreciate the convenience um
but
the convenience comes at a cost you know
to our recycling programs to our
landfills and to the natural beauty of
our state
so this is
sort of why we're
we're we're doing this and and i and i
would stress that
you know we're not trying to design
you know the regulations here in this
committee right now unless the committee
decides that's where they want to go
you know this really is about just
basically said telling municipalities
that if you want to do this
you you can
yes representative gallagher
so
to kind of um
rephrase the previous question in a
different way would you
support an amendment that would change
plastic bags and paper bags to say
plastic bags or paper bags to change the
and to ore
or does it have to be
and i think that i think your your
suggestion is probably a little more
precise
um
again the i think the only reason paper
is in there
is in situations where a community might
want to
um
to have paper bags be your preferred
alternative to plastic it's
basically there could be somebody who
comes out and says wait a minute the
legislature never gave you authority to
regulate paper bags
so part of part of it is try is just
trying to get around that issue and the
other thing is
um plastic bags are the only
single-use disposable uh that are
covered under this legislation
so it it's it's very narrow
representative did you have a question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
i'm sorry i'm behind the speaker but uh
it's interesting that you uh you read
the
bill to say
single-use plastic bags and paper bags
but you flavored bags are not considered
single-use
i'm sorry
oh sorry paper bags are not considered
single use
they are considered single use the the
issue is paper bags are
are not
quite as destructive and long lasting in
the environment as plastic bags
so um
i think the ideal solution would be uh
for people to bring in their own bags
and and that that's actually something
in our
in our municipal ordinance in portsmouth
that is encouraged you know people are
encouraged to bring their own containers
um to bring
you know their own bags and things like
that it's a it's sort of a slow steady
uh
a slow steady change that'll take people
a while to get used to you know no two
ways about it
um
but um
a small change that hopefully will help
hello please follow up
all right
i typically use my paper bags to take my
trash to the dump but uh there are
uh would you consider a uh hefty trash
bag to be a single-use plastic bag
i think in the bill we're talking about
bills we're talking about bags that are
provided to customers
so i um
i'm
[Music]
i think for the most part what we're
talking about are the bags that we get
at walmart and target and market basket
and things of that nature
one more follower that was a great
answer but not to what i ask okay i ask
would you consider the hefty trash bags
to be a single-use
plastic bag
i would say generally yes i know
things like leaf bags and work bags um
like when you're taking like waste out
of your house and things like that
they're more durable
so some people might use them more than
once but i think in general uh i think
it's a similar issue
to uh the bags that are given away in
stores they're used once and then
they're disposed of thank you
thank you mr mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question uh
i would like to follow up on
representative tripp's question
um because of the word single use and
you cited uh market basket
because they have a thicker ply
um that what that's what makes them
reusable
um so i'm wondering if you want to to
get to your point about
the
grocery store or you know
places that have the single what we
really understand is or
the notion of single use would we change
would you consider changing that phrase
to
one fly or two ply
or all ply
um
yes i mean if if it's something that
that you folks think would make would
make the bill better and more
understandable um
yes
thank you
yes representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
i'm curious to to know has any of these
sponsors of this bill have they
considered the concerns related to
reusable bags and
the sanitation with respect to that and
the spreading of germs
and you know perhaps
if we might be in a pandemic
well i think what i think one issue at a
time
but but um you know when it when it
comes to that i think one of the things
that we went through early on in covid
was we did have an executive order that
that did ban
um
those types of reusable bags from
grocery stores because there was a
concern about transmission i mean
anytime you're dealing with things like
you know meats and things like that
there there is always a danger
of bacteria
building up you know in reusable bags
but i think it's kind of up to us as
consumers
to
keep them clean
kind of like anything anything else it's
kind of like you wouldn't use you know
your cooler summer after summer after
summer without cleaning it
and the same thing for plastic bags at
least you know give him a spray of lysol
every once in a while
yes
thank you chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
i'm wondering if
this whole issue about
our is a hefty bag a single use bag
might be addressed by
saying in
your amendment or in your proposed
change regulating the distribution of
single-use plastic bags and paper bags
at point of sale
yes
yes would you accept such an amendment
yes i'm not i'm not the prime sponsor
but
i would be an enthusiastic co-sponsor
with that
thank you
and
now we're going to go to
bruce burke
come on up thank you and you're welcome
to use the
clorox there to sanitize the
work area i'm good
thank you
good morning my name is bruce burke and
i am from the town of pittsfield
and uh
i want to thank you for all the time you
spend on behalf of our state
uh i want to speak a little bit about
this bill and maybe just some general
facts for a moment
um
you know astonishingly plastics have
only been a major part of our culture
since 1950.
uh we older folks
some of us in this room remember
a world that didn't really use a lot of
plastic as a matter of fact we lived in
a world where they delivered milk to our
doors right that world existed plastics
is a recent phenomenon and i don't want
to bury you with facts
but in 1950
uh we produce something like 2 million
tons of plastic a year and in 2015 that
number increased 220 times
right
plastics have not always been with us
and they are i think
um
you've heard before i think they're an
emerging crisis that we're not really
haven't really grappled with yet
having said that plastics are an
important part of our economy and what i
think this bill is trying to
address is single-use plastics which are
estimated to be
40 percent of the plastics that we use
i think giving towns the option to
eliminate plastic bags and paper bags is
a step in the right
direction to my sense the two major
arguments against this one is about
individual freedom i as a person should
be able to decide what i want to do when
i go to buy groceries
i would suggest however that there's
something called a social compact where
we as a society try to do the best for
all of us even imagine sacrificing the
ability to choose between plastic paper
or
a reusable bag
you could also make the argument that
people who are well informed will make
the right decision i don't spend my time
doing this but if you spend 10 minutes
outside of hannaford's in concord where
i shop 60 70 percent of the people are
coming out with plastic bags
i think they've heard of the crisis but
it's just not an awareness for them
the second argument is economics
right
families are stretched
and they can't afford any additional
expenses because what we're saying to
them is you're going to have to go out
and buy reusable bags probably that's
what you're going to have to do
i can accept the first part of this
argument that families are stretched but
not the second part
i went online to find how much plastic
bags reusable bags cost
some were less than a dollar
i would suggest to you that any family
would be willing to spend five ten
fifteen dollars
pizza with pepperoni
right
to ensure the health of their kids
in the future
i would also say and it's been brought
up before that
reducing this
will help our waste stream
it'll reduce demand for new landfill
which is a major issue in new hampshire
at the moment
and as i said uh even reduce if you
followed it plastics in our lakes
sideways last week the governor said in
his one of his talks that we have the
largest surplus we've had in the history
of the state
he said conservatively we have a two to
three hundred million dollar surplus
that's conservative he said
imagine and this bill doesn't ask it but
just imagine for a moment if the state
went out and bought a reusable bag at a
dollar a bag for every citizen in this
state
it'd be one and a half million dollars
be 0.5
of his suggested surplus
what i'm trying to say is
that i think this is a minor step an
important step to create awareness and
to help our landfill and our future
health and thank you for your time and
i'll take your questions
i've been in trouble before i recognize
that
you know those of us who used to get
milk delivered to our houses before
plastic bags didn't have to deal with
these phones that's all i'm trying to
say
okay
thank you for your testimony i'm going
to move on thank you because a lot of
people have requested to speak
uh christina
dubin is that right
all right good morning uh
cheryl dolan uh vice chair piedmont and
members of the committee my name is
christina dubin i am a volunteer
secretary and campaigns coordinator for
the new hampshire chapter of the
surfrider foundation
and our chapter has worked to address
single-use plastic and packaging
pollution in seacoast communities for
well over a decade
um before i begin your microphone
it is on do i make it lower yeah no just
maybe speak in it
okay sorry about that
um so i'm here to ask for support of
hb1119 but before i um begin on that i
just wanted to address the question
about paper bags
from my understanding
having paper bags as well as plastic
allows for perhaps adding a fee
mechanism so not just to outright get
rid of them but it would allow
municipalities to add
something like that so not to get rid of
them entirely but perhaps to do
something to incentivize
behavioral change
so
hb 1119 would basically just clarify
current ambiguity regarding the inherent
authority
um
that municipal municipalities have to
regulate waste from single-use paper and
plastic bags
and this is really important um it's an
important clarification of existing
ambiguity in uh 149-m
and it is basically stalled local
efforts
for municipalities to follow in the
footsteps of portsmouth to pass local
laws to meet waste mitigation needs
which ultimately help to achieve the
state's source reduction goals
what hb 1119 does not do is ask this
committee or the state to make a
decision about whether or not single-use
backs should be mitigated in any way nor
request any
administration of solid waste
regulations at the municipal level it
just
simply clarifies that ambiguity in
149-m
um from municipalities that you know for
well over a decade have expressed this
desire
uh to have local laws aimed at plastic
pollution mitigation
is that okay to go on no that that's
your time is up
that was three minutes that was two
minutes that was two minutes okay
can you wrap up in a sentence or two um
yes
uh
so let me just see if i um
i guess i'll just know i just want to
give one example of the kind of the
ambiguity that's perpetuated um in the
past our chapters uh testified in
support of senator martha fuller clark's
sb 410 in 2016
and the committee uh public and
municipal affairs committee at the time
argued
that it would be redundant stating that
there's already inherent authority in
our state solid waste regulations so
thank you for your testimony
next we'll hear from
simon thompson from concord
mr thompson
feel free to sanitize the work area
there all right
thank you good morning my name is simon
thompson
uh
i'm with sheen finney capital group and
i'm here on behalf of one of our clients
the
new england convenience store
and energy marketers association that's
a mouthful
we go by nexima and we represent
convenience stores
not only in new hampshire but all
throughout new england
in here in new hampshire we have about
850 stores
um
roughly employing close to 14 000 people
i'm not going to read this testimony i
have had it submitted to you folks
online i think the one point i'm going
to make is we have experienced
how bad this approach has worked in the
state of massachusetts
where
many of our members own several stores
throughout different municipalities and
localities and we've just seen that this
is very difficult to deal with in
managed shell i'll leave it at that
answer any questions that folks may have
but i appreciate your time
okay thank you for your testimony
appreciate it
next we're going to hear from
curtis barry
new hampshire retail association
welcome thank you and good morning mr
chair members of the committee i am
curtis barry here on behalf of the new
hampshire retail association the new
hampshire retail association represents
several hundred retailers in new
hampshire both the national major chains
and many hundred small independent
businesses
i'm here to oppose
this legislation my testimony is is very
brief into the point
the retail association is
very wary of
a trend that this bill may start which
is environmental regulation on a town by
town basis there are 234 municipalities
in the state
this bill could set up a
a scheme where you're pitting one town
against another in this and then
potentially other environmental
regulations
you folks are 400 strong in a small
state with very small communities we
think you're you have the ability to
decide environmental regulations on a
statewide basis which is more
appropriate
one last point i think i'd like to make
there are more
reasons why
this bill
should not pass it would be ineffective
for example one town banning
plastic bags does not mean plastic bags
don't enter the waste stream in their
community if i lived in portsmouth i
could shop in newington where they might
not ban the distribution of the
single-use bags
bring them back into town
if i were visiting hampton beach i could
shop here in concord bring my
lunch in a plastic bag in hampton beach
uh responsible disposal is the solution
i think you'll probably hear more about
that later this morning or during this
hearing i'm happy to answer questions to
the best of my ability
thank you for your testimony thank you
next we're going to hear from
kevin daigle
welcome kevin you've got two minutes two
minutes okay i'll try my best good
morning mr chairman members of the
committee try not to talk so fast here
my name is kevin daigle i'm the
president of the new hampshire grocers
association
for those of you not familiar with us
and this doesn't count in the two
minutes yet right
we are the organization that represents
both chain and independent grocery
stores supermarkets convenience stores
and their suppliers
before i begin a couple of the first
presenters doing their testimony had
talked about environmental awareness
i just want to get back to the bill
itself
is allowing towns to regulate the use of
paper and plastic bags
so if passed this bill would have many
unintended consequences as you're aware
new hampshire is a dillon rule state
meaning that the state retains all
powers which are not specifically
granted to municipalities it has been
wise to maintain dillon's rule as
opposed to home rule and for good reason
new hampshire is a state of 234 cities
and towns located in a very compact
geographic area
grocers do their best to attract
customers from not only their own
community but from surrounding
communities as well as well
now imagine if this bill was passed if
suddenly a particular community
instituted a ban or mandated a fee these
communities in grocers within those
communities could see a migration of
consumers to other towns
now through no fault of their own other
than being in the wrong community
businesses would lose commerce to
businesses and other towns by allowing
towns to create their own rules both
retailers and customers would be faced
with differing regulations from town to
town
grocers like many other businesses
oppose a patchwork quilt of local
ordinances the immense complexity of
operating in an environment of varying
local laws
increases customer confusion and through
high costs of compliance unnecessarily
increase the cost for all the parties
in addition to the confusion and
complexities this creates for businesses
this bill sets a bad precedent it
provides an opportunity of past for
other issues to come forward seeking
home rule for their cause thus creating
an even greater web of regulations that
businesses and citizens just now need to
navigate
for these reasons we ask you to find the
bill inexpedient to legislate i thank
you for your time and be happy to answer
any questions
thank you you made it within two seconds
can i next here
we can if you want
representative
thank you chairman and thank you uh for
the groceries association so would you
support a statewide ban on with the
groceries association support a
statewide ban on plastic bags we would
have to look at what those details
look like and entailed
thank you
okay thank you for your testimony we're
now going to hear from zachary taylor
feel free to use the clorox to sanitize
your area
thank you chairman
good morning chairman vice chairman
members of the committee my name is
zachary taylor i'm the director of the
american recyclable plastic bag alliance
we represent the u.s manufacturers and
recyclers of plastic bags we oppose this
bill for multiple reasons most notably
the complicated patchwork of local
ordinances that opens the door to
we've heard from businesses in the
community about why that's a bad idea
but i want to focus on a few other
things that were raised this morning
notably the concerns about plastic bags
and the environment data from the
environmental protection agency
finds that plastic bags and sacks
combined all plastic bags and sacks
account for 0.3 percent of municipal
solid waste plastic carryout bags
targeted by this bill account for a
fraction of that
litter surveys from across the country
consistently find that during litter
clamps plastic bags account for less
than one percent of litter and data from
the ocean conservancy finds that beach
cleanup items plastic bags account for a
similar amount what that means to say is
that while
efforts to ban plastic bags to address
environmental concerns and advanced
sustainability they will miss the mark
because these products do not contribute
meaningfully to these real issues
however they do open the door to
unintended consequences alternative bags
are more expensive for businesses to
procure
particularly paper bags there's a
national shortage of paper bags right
now that is going to hurt small
businesses distinctly who will lose the
ability to access economies of scale in
purchasing their carryout bags
furthermore
bag fees also
hit vulnerable families more severely
research from the university of ottawa
on toronto's bag fee found that lower
socioeconomic families are more likely
to be hit by these policies but most
importantly i want to underscore we're
the first to say that if you don't need
a bag don't take one we care deeply
about sustainability that's why we
promote recycling in the store take back
program that provides a pathway for
plastic bags and films to be returned to
the store and transformed into new
products like bags railroad ties
composite lumber decking and other
similar applications we believe that
increasing recycled content promoting
recycling and promoting consumer
education around these issues is a
better approach than bans that force
consumers to use alternative bags that
are both more expensive for them but
also have greater environmental impacts
every life cycle assessment has found
that comparing carryout bags the plastic
carryout bag when disposed of properly
is the one with the fewest environmental
impacts thank you very much i'm happy to
take any questions
thank you
any questions yes representative
majipudi
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question um
don't you
in your facts or in your research have
you come across the fact that single-use
plastic bags
can
cause uh drainage obstruction or
flooding you know in the
drains because the easy with which they
if it's not properly disposed
um
can block the natural rain and flood
uh drains
getting caught
you for the question representative i
think you know it's important to know
that plastic bags do not belong in the
environment we're the first to say that
plastic bags should either be reused at
home they overwhelmingly are
research from recycled quebec the
recycling authority in quebec found that
about 77 of plastic bags get reused for
household chores like picking up after
pets uh or lining waste paper bins in
the bathroom so the idea that their
single use is sort of a misnomer um also
it's important to recycle them and as an
industry we want to see more recycling
we were able to put out a release last
week that our members
have met their recycled content goals
for their products so now that on
average every plastic retail bag
manufactured by our members in the
united states contains on average a
minimum of 10 recycled content we want
to see those numbers continue to
increase in future years and to help
that we've also partnered with a company
called stena on a new film drop-off
recycling directory that's going to help
consumers find where to take these
products back to the store so they don't
have to throw them out they can actually
recycle them in the store take back
program yeah i have a question for you
is are biodegradable plastic bags uh an
option
uh so it depends on sorry thank you for
the question mr chairman it depends what
you mean by biodegradable so there's
multiple kinds of plastics most uh
plastics are compostable and most of
those compostable plastics require
industrial composting
what the life cycle assessments find is
that the traditional plastic carryout
bag as long as it's disposed of properly
is the one with the least environmental
impacts and that's the one that a lot of
consumers reuse and a lot of consumers
recycle
i'm sorry
a lot of consumers reuse and recycle the
the traditional plastic carryout bag
well thank you for your testimony um
next i want to hear from mary smith
i'm sorry i have a question oh yes
representative tripp
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question uh
during your presentation you identified
uh
several items that
these bags can be uh
recycled into basically products could
you uh
give us those products again and not so
fast
yeah absolutely thank you for the
question representative
so plastic bags when the return to the
store are purchased by other companies
to be turned into a variety of other
materials including new bags
railroad ties composite lumber composite
decking furniture i think that was
raised earlier playground equipment and
similar applications there's continued
research going on about other ways to
reuse
these materials recycle them and avoid
the use of virgin materials there's new
research coming out about using them as
binder for asphalt and paving as well
thank you you're very welcome
thank you for your testimony we're going
to hear now from mary smith
thank you mr chair and
the rest of the committee
it is not the purpose of the government
to micromanage every aspect of the
interaction between producers and
consumers
producers should be allowed to provide a
low-cost way for consumers to carry
their items to their cars and into their
homes
to allow for towns to regulate how
businesses interact
with the public in this way interferes
unnecessarily with the market which
increases costs that businesses have to
pay
and inevitably the businesses won't pay
them the consumers will pay them
states such as california have tried
similar bills which leads to more
financial burdens being placed on
businesses especially small businesses
this burdensome regulation has no place
in new hampshire and impedes the whole
live free or die spirit that makes the
state so great
um
any questions
for
mary smith
seeing none thank you for your testimony
uh have i called on
kevin daigle yet
you've had a chance to speak okay
and last we have uh some testimony from
representative rosemary rum
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you to the committee um i want to make
clear
especially after the comments of the
previous speakers this isn't a ban on
plastic bags all this is is enabling
legislations to let our towns and cities
who have the cost and the responsibility
of managing solid waste to make this
decision
a similar bill that was a statewide ban
came before the legislature about three
or four years ago i voted against that
i don't believe in a statewide ban on
this but i do believe that we should
enable our towns and cities to make the
decisions that are best for them
i seriously doubt that if this bill
passes that my town of merrimack will
will enable will use it
but i don't want to pre-support pre to
presuppose that what's good for
merrimack is also good for
littleton or colebrook or hampton or
portsmouth this is simply letting our
towns and and cities who have the
responsibility for solid waste
management
the ability to control it thank you
i'd be happy to take any questions thank
you representative are there any
questions
seeing none thank you thank you
thank you all uh
for enduring that that time those time
speeches i'm sorry but we just had to
limit
some of the output
for this uh particular bill
we had
118 118 in support and 11 opposed
that's mine
okay
thank you that that ends the hearing on
house bill 11
19.
the committee is going to take a break
now
for lunch or early lunch and i ask you
all to be back here at five minutes of
12 and we'll begin our next hearing
on uh
12 68.
what five minutes
five minutes
we still have 1268 to do
yeah you want you want to plow on and uh
and do the next hearing or do you want
to take a break
what's that
you want to keep going
all right
okay
okay we're going to open the
hearing on house bill 1268
which is limiting the authority for city
council bylaws and ordinances
i'm sorry yes
there have been
members of the public that have left
i'm just concerned that maybe they were
here in 1268
before we get started should we uh
make sure that
diane's going to pull the corridor out
there
okay
thanks one of them
okay it looks like we are going to move
forward with
house bill 1268.
do i have anyone that would like to
introduce the bill
please come on up
welcome
thank you very much um
chairman and members of the municipal
and county committee
i realized that
you folks probably want to get to lunch
so i'll be as concise as i possibly can
um
there's a number of handouts that are
going around so
i'll be
very uh concise
uh this the issue this bill seeks to
address is the overly broad broad
language in rsa47 colon 17
it has come to everyone's attention that
the cities of keene portsmouth berlin
lebanon and durham have passed town wide
mask ordinances all with different rules
and many with no quantitative
exploration information this has
resulted in some confusion
the language which we'll discuss later i
have an example for you
the language in this rsa can also be
better defined to reflect our existing
dhhs guidance regarding communicable
communicable diseases to reference
guidance from the new hampshire public
health nuisance task force
and to avoid conflicts with dylan's rule
we can improve the consistency
with this bill that i have the amendment
that i'm that's being handed out right
now
um in the language in this rsa all items
listed in the section of this rsa 47
chapter 47 and in particular 47 colon 17
refer to local issues and nuisances
references to communicable diseases
viruses contagions
vaccines personal health etc have been
omitted because the state
was
meant to take the lead on these issues
pertaining to communicable diseases
as a
way of reference
that
i have found
on the dhh website
uh under the health officers section
a powerpoint by philip alex
alexa kos
mph chief of environmental health and
emergency response
who addressed
the city of manchester about the rules
and
it says quote new hampshire dhhs has the
responsibility to lead these efforts
this was in the communicable disease
section of his presentation that can be
found on the website
uh dhhs should lead the the efforts with
regard to communicable disease because
viruses such as covet 19 no no no
borders
and because dhhs has the epidemiologist
in other staff
who are better prepared than anyone else
in the state to handle such problems
on a statewide level
and furthermore because a town wide town
by town approach will only lead to a
patchwork of confusing bylaws
please see
if you may
the
city of portsmouth's directive it says
public health directive on the top
and this is uh taken from the city of
portsmouth website
where
it is unclear whether this is a law a
by-law if it's been codified
that has not been clear to me i've
reached out to this department
to get clarification but as you see if
you flip it to the back
it is signed by a city employee
it's a health officer
who is employed not elected
by the people
and it is a
mask mandate as i understand i tried to
look this up on the uh there's some news
articles about it it's my understanding
because the city of portsmouth is still
in the hearing process of this statute
or this bill this bylaw for this
for the city so
um i hope this is maybe the last time i
ever see a directive
or a bylaw that's
posing as a law
signed by a city employee
at the bottom
they have referenced
the statute in 40
147 colon 1.
now that is meant to
um
yeah the health officers may make
regulations but
it's supposed to be
approved by the selectmen
to my knowledge that they are still on
the hearings
stage
so um
what this is exactly i don't know but it
is confusion i would say uh okay
also please see the map that i've passed
out
the the
state of new hampshire that i've taken
off of our covert 19 interactive
dashboard
i've gone through and and highlighted
and outlined the cities that have mask
mandates just to show you that
uh there's nothing jumping out here that
says that mask mandates works at work
and this isn't a
a testimony about
whether masks work or not
i realize that's a whole other issue but
i just wanted to make sure that there
wasn't any thing jumping out saying uh
these cities have some sort of
overwhelming advantage
in the fight against um
transmission
okay so um
also okay so they may make any other
bylaws
in the uh bill itself
or in the rsa
uh the the the language that we're
addressing
is on line 16. they may make any other
bylaws and regulations
um for which may seem for the well-being
of the city
but they don't really mean any
uh because of dylan's
rule
um
this isn't really it's it's uh ancient
language from
the year of 19 1846. the language is
quaint and attorneys will warn you about
enforcing it due to constitutionality
issues
so if you read chapter 47 someday and i
hope you do it's it's full of all kinds
of quaint language
um including
uh giving cities
leeway to make to regulate all kinds of
quote all kinds of immoral and obscene
conduct it's very broad
but just to read a little bit about
dylan's rule is a municipal corporation
can exercise only the powers explicitly
granted to them
those or those necessarily or fairly
implied
or incident to the powers expressly
granted those essential to the declared
objects and purposes of that corporation
not simply convenient but indispensable
dylan's rule states that if there is a
reasonable doubt whether a power has
been conferred to a local government
then the power has not been conferred
i would argue that
there is a reasonable doubt um
so
what i have done and i hope uh
you like this is um
i have clarified this
if you look in your
public health nuisance guidance document
on page four this is a great
sort of study
that was conducted in 2014
by the
you can see the list of all the
different um
health officers public health officials
of the state and it really it really
gives a lot of great i emailed it to all
the committee members because it's 22
pages
and i have only printed out nine in the
interest of
saving trees
but if you see on it sort of goes into
defining what a public health nuisance
is
because it is difficult it's confusing
on page four
it says at the top
first paragraph the task force was
interested in developing model language
that could be used by cities and towns
interested in developing stronger
public health ordinances
so they did this study and then at the
bottom where it says overview of public
health nuisance
they sort of just
define it
since i've noticed some people have
are not sure whether a communicable
disease is a nuisance
in general a nuisance is defined as a
condition activity or situation such as
a loud
noise or a foul odor that interferes
with the use and enjoyment of property
especially in non-transitory condition
or persistent activity that either
injures the physical condition of the
adjacent land
or
interferes with the enjoyment of
easements and that is consistent with
what we have
heard
in our last
testimony of the health officer bill
that it is related to local issues
so
i have uh i think you all have the
amendment
um and i think
that i actually
passed out all of
the amendments to everybody but i didn't
keep one
does anyone have
um
so what i've done is taken that
um thank you very much
i've taken i've taken that um
definition and incorporated it
incorporated it into
um
line 16 here
and it just now says they may make any
other bylaws and regulations
and i crossed out which may seem for the
well-being of the city because it is
of course all the regulations are going
going to seem for the well-being of city
just for the sake of flow
they may make any other regulations and
bylaws for the abatement of nuisances
that interfere with the use and
enjoyment of property to emphasize
that it pertains to
the use of property
which by all measures
is consistent with everything else that
i've
seen on the dhh website about
nuisances and about the role of public
health
regulation within the city so
i think these changes are the
responsible thing to do i'm asking you
to support the amendment last year we
had a similar bill which eliminated the
regulation ability
for cities to pass any bylaws at all
so i think this is a good compromise it
allows the ability of cities to make
their own regulations pertaining to
local issues
as they would like
but it also clarifies and better defines
the purview of public health
within city government and it's
consistent with the existing
dhhs guidance on
regulating
and
regulating public health especially
communicable diseases thank you very
much i think that's it's a question for
you
as i understand
what you've done here
it does it seems like you're not
objecting to the mask ordinance you're
objecting to the
to the fact that the community doesn't
have the authority to implement a mass
coordinates is that right
uh thank you chairman dolan um
that is
pretty much true um i'm objecting to the
idea of not just the mask ordinance is
sort of incidental to the larger picture
um of
you know
narrowly defining what cities and towns
may do in keeping with dylan's law
where you know we're getting into the
sort of slippery slope of
by
um interpreting
this line of any they may make any other
bylaws well we know that we can't allow
you know they they shouldn't be making
regulations about personal health
or telling us what to eat or drink for
instance
i think everyone would agree that maybe
we shouldn't allow lockdowns or
stay at stay-at-home orders um
so
those are this
so it's just sort of the responsible
thing to do to to define it
look at this map that you've
provided to us have you had a chance to
sit with and discuss
those those communities that you've
highlighted sit with their legal
team to see
how they feel the legality of this is
um i have reached out to portsmouth i
didn't get a call back
i haven't
reached out to that to all of not all of
the cities say for instance manchester
and concord don't have town-wide
city-wide mass ordinances
i have reached out to
hanover and i just got dumped into the
voicemail i think maybe they're
just uh here that it's about mask
ordinances or something and then they
just
okay uh
other questions from the committee yes
representative
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question um the map that
you show here um
the
i see that the data is 210 22 are you
aware that um what you show here is that
at the beginning of nashua's mass
mandate we were in significant
high
surging and we are getting better so i
your your comment would you not say that
your comment that um
mask is not showing this is not
necessarily accurate
thank you for your question
representative
um i
did not uh i put the date on there so
that you know that it was
that was the date and it's it's the rate
that's being
the rate per thousand is is what i'm
what i the parent the uh
parameters that we're using
so
it was a random date um and that is
it could be getting better follow-up sir
yes
thank you very much um
the
kind of put this into a proper question
um
if if this did show that it was getting
better would you
feel comfortable with changing your
statement
thank you for the question changing
changing my amendment no changing your
statement
that that this map showed that they're
not working
so the i'm just not sure if i understand
the question if we looked at the map
today
no
i had commented prior that
when the math mandate was put in in
january or actually december
the numbers were per 100 000 were quite
significantly higher than they are on
210. i have those numbers um
would you not say that your statement
was not quite as accurate as you would
hope
thank you for the question i
uh
i no no i would not agree with that
because
i'm i'm simply showing you a snapshot
and saying that there wasn't anything
that jumped out as overwhelmingly
showing that the cities with mass
mandates not not the state as as overall
and don't forget
uh some of them are in various degrees
they've
had mass mandates last winter they took
them away they put them back i think
that was
hanover that did that i'm not sure about
the other ones and i haven't done a
a great study of whether or not they uh
show promise and it it's quite
complicated the science and the data
that's that's all
um
and i'm not an expert for sure i'm going
to claim to be represented
thank you mr chu thank you for taking my
question my question is simple in terms
of
your built uh 1268
is trying to take away the local control
flip it around and say state has more
control over the local ordinance is that
true
thank you for your question
representative um
well what i
said was that we have dylan's rule in
the state
which
preempts any state city rule um
we all automatically the way we're set
up
have the control the legislature has the
control to make the laws
and
this ordinance is is really just i
consider it housekeeping to better
define
i'm not taking away anything
because
they already have all the abilities that
they need to regulate all the public
nuisances
that they so choose if you read the
entire chapter of 47
it covers just about everything
including
making
plain cards illegal and and regulating
candle makers all the way back to 1846
plus in in other sections of the rsa
there's all kinds of regulations this
this only would define what kind of
regulations
they can pass
and that is that's all it's just a
better definition thank you remember
yes
thank you for taking my question
i
looked at the
the directive from the
city of portsmouth
and
i see that there is a paragraph
it says a face covering is not required
for a person
with a medical or developmental
condition
and you're not required to produce
documentation
now i am a person
who has
what's termed a cleft palate
okay
it makes it harder for me to breathe
so i am not
covered by any sort of mask mandate
the problem for me to go into
a city that has a mask mandate
is that i personally
have to
[Music]
tolerate
the scorn
and the bad
looks
that i get
from that
would your bill
prohibit
the
me getting that scorn
going into a a municipality that
requires a mask mandate
thank you for your question
representative los
alas um
so this this bill would prohibit cities
from making mass mandates yes
or any mandate uh
pertaining to communicable diseases
which would be the purview of dhhs
so
technically
possibly the governor or
at the state level we could pass mass
mandates
so i can't say for certain that um
that would never happen
but it would would allow it to happen at
a state level
rather than a city by city level thank
you representative
thank you and my question will be quick
you you mentioned something that kind of
triggered when you said the governor um
the governor has actually come out and
said that whatever the municipalities
felt was necessary for the health of
their
could could in fact do mass mandates and
so on he has not prohibited he said that
he would not do it statewide um so would
this prohibit him from saying that
or any other future governor i apologize
thank you representative um he did
he did say that uh the governor i
believe
that i don't know whether that was after
or before he as you recall
did pass a sort of mask mandate for the
state at for in a limited way
at one time
so i imagine that he could do that again
um
i am not uh
i'm not quite sure
yeah he could i don't see why he
couldn't do it again
follow up sir
yes
um
he he did it after he
stopped hit the the statewide mandate
and and then basically allowed the
states to do it my question to you is
would this prohibit him from
without regulation stating oh any
municipality as he has done presently
any municipality
can invoke um
a something of a mandate of a mass
mandate or something like that for the
health of their citizens
if the if i understand the question
thank you representative
would this prohibit the governor from
saying that a city can do this
um i believe
this would put the onus on
the state
or the legislature
uh to to deal with it at a state level
and it would
i don't see how uh
unless there's there's something more to
the
to the to the regulation but it would it
would stop that from yes just one quick
follow-up and i apologize sir just for
clarification
okay and and i apologize to you too i i
don't mean to to keep keep asking you
this um oh my god it just went out of my
head um
the um the
you said that it would not
so if this were to happen in
october november when the
legislation is not in
in session they would have to call an
emergency
meeting in order to be able to pass
something like that
is that your intention
um thank you for the question
representative um is it my intention
that
the state go and and call for an
emergency legislative session no
i i don't think uh that would be
probably
something that they would do
um so no they would not do that but um
you know to on on a side note
uh a governor can can say that they they
wish that people would wear mass or to
to maybe publish something
some more guidance
uh they could certainly publish guidance
thank you so much
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative taking my question and i
apologize if you addressed this already
i i might have been shuffling paper at
the time so my question is specific to
your amendment and i'm just trying to
understand for the abatement of
nuisances that interfere with the use
or enjoyment of property my question is
about the word property is that personal
property and
municipal property is that all the
property of the town i just want to be
clear on what on how you define the word
property there thank you
um i believe thank you for your question
representative
um when i when a word is not defined in
an ordinance i my understanding is that
the common
uh use
of the term
applies
so um for the use and enjoyment of
property
it certainly uh
pertains to private property because
when you're discussing nuisances
and um health officers and regulations
they're often dealing with uh private
property and dispute disputes between
par you know landowners
um
yeah i don't see why it wouldn't apply
to public property
any further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
i appreciate it thank you very much
next we'll hear from mr graves
thank you mr chairman h grace for the
new hampshire municipal association we
oppose the bill as written as well as
the amendment
the
the amendment does address a number of
our concerns with the bill is written
as i
it's very similar to a bill previously
heard by this committee relating to the
authority of local health officers for
towns um and uses terms like
presenting a clear and present danger as
well as uh limiting the time period for
an ordinance for a certain period of
time
as i explained in that prior hearing we
think that's inappropriate i believe
it's the sponsor's intent that the
amendment would replace the entire bill
or at least the problematic language
and therefore i would like to address my
comments towards that
first i'd like to note that under
rsa4717 roman
14 there's already a provision that
allows cities to abate and remove
nuisances so
uh this to to the extent that this
language uh proposed today the abatement
of nuisances that interfere with the use
or enjoyment of property would be added
that would be duplicative of what
currently exists and may in fact
restrict it to a specific property
rather than
however nuisances
are interpreted
and the way nuisance nuisance
is interpreted at the moment
is it really has to be
clearly defined and so
if i can use the city of nashua as an
example
they have a very
robust process in order to enact some
sort of local regulation
um so if it's something that a health
officer would propose
they would you know have to
write up the the wording and find a
reason for it it would they'd have to
find a sponsor on the city council
the city council would debate that
before putting it into action
and so
you have all these sorts of local checks
obviously there would be opportunity for
the public to address the city council
and express their opinion on the matter
flush out any issues that might arise
that might not be foreseen by uh
the
local officials working on this
um
and so we are concerned that this would
take away local authority
i did
just put out a question to our members
about
you know what
what
specifically does this
provision in the law has it been used
for in the past
there are a couple of cases on it um and
really the cases are
well the law's changed slightly since
since the first case which is dover news
inc versus city of dover 117 nh 1066
from 1977 which saw the city of dover
regulate the display of adult books and
magazines at a newsstand
the laws changed slightly there is now a
provision that
under 4717 roman 13 that allows that
type of regulation specifically
and this provision was also mentioned in
the case state versus lilly
i don't have the new hampshire citation
but the
regional citation is
204 a
3d 198 2019 which saw the city of
laconia
regulate uh topless female sunbathers um
and that has
and there's now a provision in the law
that specifically addresses that as well
i'm not sure if that was in in place as
well
beforehand um but in any case um
really this provisional law
by and large has been used as supplement
supplementary authority
4717 covers a huge
range of things that cities are allowed
to to deal with
they really are
things that you would that just kind of
the average citizen would think of
calling their local officials about so
it's not something they would logically
think about calling a state official
about it's something they would call the
city about and assume the city has the
power to regulate you know
trees on roads snow plowing etc all of
that's covered under 47 17.
the one area where it may be the case
that this provision stands alone
is something like dealing with uh
in in the health context is some
something like dealing with mosquitoes
so for example concord and manchester
have similar provisions
i learned this morning dealing with
mosquitoes and
standing water so obviously if you have
standing water mosquitoes can breed
there
so they have ordinances in place to try
to limit the amount of standing water
around the city
and in particular to some places like
junkyards which see a lot of things like
tires that collected standing water
and in this in the region between
concord and manchester they're dealing
with
um kind of a
seasonal outbreak of the james count
jamestown canyon virus and some other
viruses spread by mosquitoes
obviously limiting the number of
mosquitoes available limits the
probability of that spreading
salem
using its its provisions as a a
a council
um has a uh
a provision that requires testing of
private wells when new homes are
constructed to ensure that they provide
safe water to the inhabitants there's
currently no state provision on that
so that would cover things and i'm not
sure exactly how how much that covers
but that could cover something like
testing to see the level of pfas or the
level of lead or arsenic
etc and having that disclosed to new
homeowners who would then presumably be
able to negotiate with the builder and
ensure that the water is safe to drink
um certainly happy to answer any
questions the committee may have
we're going to take a break in just a
few minutes could i ask you to hold for
us to leave absolutely before you leave
absolutely any questions for the nhma
yes
jim
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
grace for taking my question
um
if
house bill
1272 as amended were to pass
giving health officers the uh right for
uh to deal with nuisances and house bill
1268 as amended were to pass giving the
city council
the same authority to obey for nuisances
god bless you would we have a conflict
or would we have confusion
about whose authority
or who has the authority
health officer or city council
thank you thank you for the question um
you would certainly have a duplication
of who has that authority um
it it gets a little complex and how
these relate um but again if i go back
to my example of the city of nashua
typically the health officer themselves
aren't making regulations in a city
context typically they're doing it
through
the city council's process
so
i'm not
that concerned about the any sort of
conflicting language between those two
um i would add however we we also object
to the amendment on 1272.
any other comments yes representative
thank you mr chair thank you mr grace
for taking my question my question is um
how does this flip the state versus
local control and how would it
jeopardize
local control
well representative i think you had it
exactly right earlier when you asked the
sponsor that this does take away local
control
you know local authorities are granted
a limited yet broad grant of power in
certain areas simply because we can't
anticipate the issues that are going to
come up um
the the two case examples i i came up
with probably not something that the
legislature thought about ahead of time
until it was an issue
and this just gives
municipalities the option to deal with
that and of course the check is that the
next session the legislature comes in
and decides whether that was dealt with
appropriately thank you um
and
is it not true that we are the pandemic
this is the first time we have had a
pandemic at least since i've lived in
here for a few decades
and so
you know to change something
that not knowing if you're going to have
another pandemic or not
wouldn't that mute the
local control
i thank you for the question so i i
guess to paraphrase what
the governor's comments were as far as i
understand them at his several thursday
afternoon briefings that i watched where
he addressed the issue
um
he believed it was appropriate to deal
with this at the local level with regard
to the masking because local conditions
are different so some place like
you know hanover obviously it's the
center of dartmouth hitchcock large
hospital
you know you don't want doctors getting
sick during a health out during a health
crisis you need them to care for the
populace
more broadly but you might not have that
same kind of concern you know outside
that immediate area so a few towns away
it might not be appropriate it might not
be something that that is and i think
that towns have used
their authority very judiciously and had
public quite a lot of public comment i
can tell you because i've heard about it
um and made decisions based on what the
people of their municipality want
any additional questions to hma
thank you very much thank you
next
we're going to hear from christina dubin
did i pronounce your name correctly you
did you been right yes
all right good morning again chair and
committee members uh just to reintroduce
myself my name is christina dubin i am
volunteer secretary and campaigns
coordinator for the surfrider foundation
new hampshire chapter and i also have
the privilege of living in portsmouth
so our chapter is opposed to hb 1268. um
the goal of this bill is identical to
multiple bills before it including hb
439 which failed last session
and it seeks of course to limit the
scope
of city councils
it takes aim at strengthening rsa 4717
but does so in an unreasonable and
overbearing manner by adding a time
period of 10 days and increasing the
limitation of the scope of authority to
quote locations that present a clear and
present danger to the city unquote the
state of course would be sought after to
resolve many issues that required an
extended time period beyond those 10
days
and it would create a need to arbitrate
every instance of what constitutes that
that
clear and present danger
we have 234 municipalities and 25
unincorporated places that vary in their
demographics economics culture and
geography
and so it's necessary for local
governments to maintain their current
authorities to make timely decisions in
response to unique situations which
arise in their communities
it's of course already provided by
statute that local policy must not
directly contradict the state
constitution or laws
and so attempting to require explicit
authority for all municipal matters is
really creating an undue burden
for all every level of government and
also on the liberties of new hampshire
people
there's plenty of examples where
municipalities are in for afforded
inherent authority to carry out
ordinances under their respective rsas
and i'll just give you a few examples to
add to the ones already given
workforce housing ordinances under rsa
674-58
also within zoning and planning
inherent authority is given in land use
boards
and the last example i'll offer is of
course within 149-m which we just heard
about with bill hb 1119
in that regard municipalities have
existing authority to regulate solid
waste and therefore inherent authority
to classify specific items within the
state's definition
and clarity there is needed because
there is a demonstrated need to resolve
ambiguity
but by modifying our state law in a
sweeping manner as hb 1268 would do
again just causes unnecessary and
burdensome oversight
um
really onto every single letter of local
law where that is just not needed it
would bog down the state local
governments and citizens with the
minutia of municipalities and it
ultimately just demonstrates a lack of
confidence in local government
i'll just end by saying it would also
cost the state more money which uh we
really don't have to spend so i just
urge the committee as it has done in the
past to vote this bill itl
thank you
thank you any questions
at this point
see none thank you so much thank you i
know it's lunch time so i appreciate it
okay uh
so at this point we're gonna come
i'm sorry
just uh we're not taking the
department of uh health and human
services isn't taking a position on this
particular bill we want to talk about
the bill and and some of the concerns
that we had um the most recent version
of the bill which i got last night that
um basically removes
anything which seems uh for the
well-being of the city and then adds in
the abatement of nuisances that
interfere with the use of the enjoyment
of the property
at this time the esu understands the
sponsor wants to make the law consistent
between towns and cities and so it's
added this reference to specific
nuisances
the only concern is the bill eliminates
a phrase
which seems for the well-being of the
city and replaces it with the abatement
of nuisances at a specific property um
and they had the discussion a little
while ago about a property it can be
private property it could be the self it
can be public property might even be
shared media
like air water things of that sort
and i think the change really is that it
shows kind of originally the well-being
of the city is about the people and i
think the change makes it kind of more
about the location the nuisance of a
particular property so i just want you
to be aware that that's a change um
and you may be more interested in
protecting the health officers are about
the population that they control not
control that they protect
and manage it
dhhs doesn't see a significant impact on
public health from this change or
restriction to creating a health code
as i say we're not sure exactly what it
would create but we're not seeing a
significant problem at this time
you know we want to give health officers
and support them in being able to do
their job sometimes as broad authority
we don't know what the next hazard or
nuisance is going to be
and we want to mature health officers
who are on the ground and really see
what's happening in their own cities
understand know their neighbors have the
ability to do that so i'm happy to take
any questions you have specific about
these changes or about
the law could you state your name for
the record yes matthew k helene from new
hampshire uh department of health and
human services
you don't have a car
i have a question
go ahead
um
i just couldn't you don't have position
or you're opposing or supporting we're
not taking a position was providing
information today
okay seeing no further
questions
thank you for taking my question can you
repeat what you said about the i'm sorry
here i'm hiding behind your chair thank
you um
can you repeat uh what you said about
the um this is covering particular
property or particular buildings and
places
and you mentioned something about not
air or
water supply or something like that can
you explain can you repeat what you said
yeah yeah let me try to describe the
difference between um the original law
um as it currently is which may seem
for the well-being in the city right so
when i think of the city i think the
population of the city and all of its
environments things of that sort
that's being changed to abatement of
nuisances that interfere with the use or
enjoyment of the property and as we
discussed somebody mentioned they
thought that property really was talking
about either private property the self
property public property and it may
include media right it could property
could be viewed as air water waste
things of that sort the way we look at
it because things can move between those
right pests can move and infections can
move odors and other things can move
between those so i was just trying to
get a broad picture of all the different
types of property i feel like
most things are property and could be
managed
there are things that aren't necessarily
nuisances
nature grace mentioned the issue of
arbor viral disease and the need to
remove standing water right stagnant
water well there's no risk there yet
right there's no nuisance there yet
there's just
a media which could grow those eggs of
the mosquitoes and spread them so is
that a nuisance or not i don't know
would a health officer be able to
would be they be able to control that
based on the definition of it not being
a nuisance those are some of the
concerns that dhhs has thank you
okay uh
seeing no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you very much
it just was a point of interest a little
discussion earlier about
pandemics
the
previous pandemic we had most
most previous
was the was the 1918 endemic
where about one third of the world's
population died
and uh there was something before that
there was something called the black
death
i'm not all that familiar
yeah
okay so so we're gonna take uh
a break and ask you all the committee
members back here at one o'clock
thank you
thanks
you're little
you gonna move the chairs
does it help
you
um
hey in just about a minute i'm going to
start up
if you don't mind i'm going to sit here
because it's one more get up and sit
down i don't have to do on these old
knees you want to introduce the first
bill
okay
okay let's get started
welcome to the municipal and county
uh committee meeting
we are
at a had a full morning of uh
work sessions and we're going to finish
up with all work sessions this afternoon
and we're going to start with hb
so let me invite
representative rizzulo
to begin the testimony
12.89 i'm sorry
you scared me for a minute
but then again at my age you can be in
places and nuts know where you are so
the floor is yours
thank you mr chair
mr chair
my name is andy rinzulo i represent
hudson and pelham hillsborough district
i also chair the resources recreation
and development committee
i'm introducing house bill 1289
it
an act relative to the applications for
abatements and authority to abate prior
years taxes for certain homeowners
actually
really what the bill is if you read the
analysis the bill provides for a good
cause for tax abatement under rsa 76
16.
shall
shall include allowed recreational
use of ohrvs on class 5 and class 6
roads
i kind of wish that that analysis had
been in the title it had a lot more
people to
show up to testify but then maybe
you know you don't need a you need a
bigger room
i wish
uh well
the purpose of this bill
is to provide some equitable relief for
those who have lost a significant part
of the use enjoyment of their home
due to actions of government local
and state
the issue is two conflicting
activities a high impact noisy
recreational activity
and a quiet residential activity
let's step back a few decades
some of us can recall when vehicular
recreation in the wild areas was very
limited
many
maybe some
dirt bikes or dune buggies but they
weren't prolific and limited to private
property
then along came the atvs and with them
the pressure to use them on trails in
this
in the summer like snowmobiles are used
in the winter
we
it used to be that the ohrv
which is the off-highway recreational
vehicle
uh was used on trails either in on state
land or on private land with permission
then we opened jericho state park
which was dedicated to ohrv use
and the people came
the sport became more popular
very popular the types of vehicles grew
including four seat dune buggies
types
for the whole family
and when then the great idea
connect all the trails so you can have
1 000 miles of trails ride the wild
but you had to connect all these trails
how about letting them
on a few of public roads
but it was only a few public roles at
first
but then as some
as someone
could see the economic potential
of letting all the riders there coming
in to spend their money in command and
spend their money in town
other roads were open to ohrv traffic by
local officials
class 5 and class 6 roads
and we're not talking about small
numbers
so now we have a high impact
recreational use
impacting on low in on a low impact
residential use
consider this
when did public roads become
recreational areas
they're not they're for transportation
only
there are those behind me who can speak
from personal experience on the impacts
of this clash
as a freshman
this was my first committee
municipal and county
if i learned nothing else i learned that
a person's home
really is their castle
and as legislators that
that should be where we stand
looking back the legislature messed up
the piecemeal expansion of ohrv use
never involved to my knowledge the one
committee
one committee
proficient in the knowledge in the in
of the use of land
things like zoning
powers of local government and
government officials conflicting land
use and yes abatements
that means this committee
i think
municipal and county needs to be part of
this solution
i recall this scene in the movie die
hard where bruce willis character
in order to gain attention of the police
car sent to investigate what was going
on
in the in the tower
he eventually ends up throwing a body of
the terrorists onto the hood of the
police car
and all of the machine guns of the
terrorists open up
and bruce willis says in the famous line
welcome to the party pal
well welcome to the party
i think you we really do need municipal
and county's
uh expertise in this matter and i speak
as a chair of resources thank you
thank you representative
let's have
wayne moynihan well i'm sorry you want
to have questions for the representative
yes representative ron
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative renzola it's such a
pleasure to have you come to municipal
and county government
i have a question
homes that are on rail trails is would
those be included in this
in this bill
uh
only to the fact that
uh they've if they have been opened
by the selectmen
to but if they're if they're not class
five or class six roads they would not
be
uh
by part of this bill now uh is
uh is
the uh does
uh the
uh committee uh know that you know what
class five and class six roads are i can
talk to that if there's a anyone needs
to know
or doesn't know yeah um would you please
describe that thank you okay
representative well there there is a
statute on rhodes base basically the
class five roads are
town
the general town road road the paved
road
uh the town maintains it class six roads
are not maintained by the town
uh they're they
they used to be called dirt roads and
but
uh they are roads that is not maintained
by the town but there are to people who
do live on them
uh and uh
they
in order to to fix those roads
they they need a permission of the town
okay follow up mr chair yes okay thank
you
um so what about homes that are on maybe
a state road
and maybe the town has allowed or the
state has allowed ohrvs to travel on
that road to get to
uh you know to kind of as a connector to
another ohrv trail
um certainly those homeowners i would
think would be subjected to the same
noise and dirt and particulate matter
generated from ohrvs
why are they not included in this bill
uh i
actually they should they've people have
asked me to include it for uh
to amend it yeah and i would not be uh
adverse to that i i chose class five and
class six
uh to start because that's the that to
me is the low hanging fruit okay thank
you
representative guthrie
i think thank you mr chan thank you for
your your uh testimony i have in the uh
act that says
authority to obey prior year taxes and
i'm not that familiar is why why that's
even in the act is it just the way it's
written up by uh
those who write up our our laws or what
you got it that's that's that is the way
it came from the uh
that's the way they wrote it so there's
nothing in here that uh allows
abatement back for back years
uh not to my knowledge that's not that's
not the put it this way that is not my
intent right thank you representative
maggiore
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
the town of northampton that i represent
is is right now trying to figure out a
noise ordinance uh that's going to the
ballot and and of course that raises
questions about what's noise to me
what's noise to you
i'm just curious
how
do you envision any kind of uh a process
by which i'm going to be aggrieved
is it noise
is it volume
or is that clearly left up to the board
of selectmen
well as
the the noble noise the noise ordinances
are
uh very difficult to enforce i think
what you uh what you're going to
really for
abatement purposes
it has to be the effect on the
on the the homeowner
uh
there's a there's obviously a big
difference between
one
oh hrv going by
and
100 or 200 and that's one of some of the
issues that have
uh driven this
but i think the way the way it is
written it is a
uh it is a uh
you know a good is a cause of uh
you know it is a something that is now
uh
something that would be
of an abate available for abatement now
as opposed to it just being blown off
any other questions yes representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
on the similar uh
line
noise and also emission has you know
have you considered emission pollution
in terms of
the number eight
which
are we uh and the impact on the
residential area see the
the amount of dust and the amount of uh
pollution
uh and the the actual impact of these
vehicles
are pretty well known
and the uh
so
they're
just stuff they're being available
in an area
and
[Music]
they're being
the trails being used
uh actually
are it's pretty easy to determine what
they will what they can and and can't do
uh
as far as the environment
we're
we're taught with like the folks behind
uh maybe we'll be able to speak better
to that as to what the impacts actually
how they how it affects
people who actually live there
yes representative sellers
thank you representative for taking my
question
i live on route 3a
in litchfield
which i have to live fairly close to the
road
there are no
atvs that go in front of my house
what i do have
is a lot of motorcycles go up and down
route 3a
because it's a very scenic road
and
the
it's not a toll road or anything like
that
now the motorcycles really produce a lot
of noise a lot of noise
i also
am a writer
of a side-by-side atv
it's one of the most pleasurable things
that i have
left
in in the world i have hand controls on
it so i don't need to use my legs
now
we have a place in coast county where i
ride this
now
there's a lot of atvs up there because
we live right on the trail
but the noise that is produced by the
atv
is much less
than the noise produced by
motorcycles particularly harley-davidson
motorcycles
now my question of you
is for assessors and selectmen
who are
trying to quantify
some sort of abatement
how would they how would they go about
doing that
i think the very fact that
a
high impact
area a high impact
recreational use
and that's what
these these vehicles in especially in
mass
consist of
i mean
they
by the very fact and what they what is
known to produce
will was is should be sufficient
now in your case you're on a trail
you're not on a class six road or a
class five road
it's much different there's much
difference especially if you're on a
class six road which in
in effect is a very
fragile road
and
most of the homes uh on it are fairly
close to it
so it's they are
the
a bunch of this is
situational but
i think by the
fact that you have this
ability this
area that your area where your home is
has been determined to allow these
which they're this
heavy impact use
it should be sufficient
to warrant an abatement
uh i know you you live on route 3a
that's that is a probably a class
probably a class two or three because it
says a secondary yeah it's a secondary
state road that's made for heavy heavy
vehicles
uh that's made for a higher traffic
that
that that is not covered by by this of
course
okay representative guthrie
did you i'm sorry mr chairman i didn't
hear you uh thank you again for being
here and
i can imagine you you almost feel like
you're sitting in front of a bunch of
selectmen
but you are i happen to be
it would seem to me
would you believe not what you believe
it's not a fact that when they value
homes
that they take a lot of things into
consideration and the value of those
homes in the area that you're talking
about would be impacted by the situation
you talk you're talking about they have
saleable
value would be impacted
i would suggest to you that
uh wouldn't you
think this would be better uh taken care
of in
assessing the value of the house
as assessed instead of trying to go into
the back door with an abatement
i don't quite understand in the uh
i'm sorry uh maybe i better put it
clearer isn't it better to leave the
value of the house that's impacted by
this condition
determine what the
uh
tax will be instead of going into the
back door and after the fact putting a
an abatement on that same property who
has been valued and taken into
consideration the plus and minuses of
the neighborhood well
most of the time aren't the evaluations
of
of properties
made
kind of in mass by the by the assessing
by the assessing authority
and
if they don't dig into the uh
that much into the
uh the sighting of of the of the houses
usually they'll just go by
comparative values things of that nature
so i i don't think they that
on our uh just just using the assessment
alone
is uh would be sufficient for to to make
restitution all right thank you thank
you any other questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you representative
thank you
we will now go to wayne monahan
welcome mr monahan
please feel free to use
the disinfectant if you so desire
is that mike turned on
there you go thank you very much mr
chairman and members of the committee
um
it is with um gratitude towards
representative renzullo representative
gould and representative gottling
for their introduction and sponsorship
of house bill 1289 that i've traveled
down here today to express support for
this proposed amendment to the new
hampshire taxation statutes
as you folks are aware passage of this
bill will create an opportunity
for a fair and just property tax
abatement for affected properties when
the government
allows town roads or highways
to be used as trails by off-highway
recreational vehicles
the proposed amendment makes such an
allowance
to be good cause
for a property tax abatement under rsa
7616.
already
allows
for consideration of back taxes that's
already in the statute
gives that option to selectmen
this bill would not affect that wording
of rsa 7616. all this bill does is add a
under the good causes allowed
the fact that the selectmen and the
state have designated
town roads as open ohrvs
when town roads become ohrv trails
they become a detrimental nuisance in
the vicinity of residential
neighborhoods
and
other properties in the town
i recognize that motorcycles are noisy
as well but motorcycles are subject to a
noise ordinance believe it or not there
is a limit to how loud a motorcycle can
legally be in the state of new hampshire
law enforcement doesn't enforce it
because they have to buy
sound
measuring devices and it's expensive for
towns to acquire those things and so a
law officer may hear one go by that is
offensive but it doesn't have the tools
or the means or the time to deal with it
i have served as a state representative
in recent
years past and it's good to be back
among you and grateful for your
volunteering service here
but while i served up until 2020 i
received a great many phone calls and
letters from constituents
throughout my district which was coast
district two
as well as from residents of
the city of berlin and cars and all over
cars county
these calls and letters emanated from
the stress caused by
on highway use of off-highway
recreational vehicles
the use of the roads puts the trails in
close proximity to people's homesteads
those who contacted me too often related
distressful stories and described
objectionable levels of noise dirt fumes
dust
disrespect
road damage and trespass
all coming about
by the ohrvis using the town's public
ways
that is not to say that everyone who
rides an ohiv is an evil person
but there is no enforcement
of these vehicles
except the occasional opportunity for a
fish and game officer to drive up from
the south
to serve a weekend in coast
and occasionally the coast county
sheriff will independently fund
some effort to regulate these devices
you'll appreciate that while traveling
on town roads
in proximity to residential properties
these our rvs do not have and are not
required to have the safety equipment
mandated by the dmv
rules of the road for vehicles that
travel on public roads
these vehicles are not equipped with
substantial noise mufflers and are not
required to by state regulation they
come
as produced in the factory without
mufflers
and they will complain if you seek to
impose a muffler because if you put a
muffler on one of these engines
supposedly they can't carry as many
people these me these machines have
become huge they carry four people at a
minimum they're much louder than your
old
tricycle
atv you might recall or the little ohrbs
you see young people that used to use
and look like so much fun i'm sure the
big ones are fun also but they're not
the same machines that existed in the
early start of this sport
ohrv has generated a noise level that is
between 90 and 100 decibels
examples of this noise levels are
jackhammers rock concerts monster truck
shows car races and helicopters or jets
taking off and landing
it is a medical fact
that hearing loss is possible from
sufficient exposure to noise levels of
100 decibels
ironically a local city that prohibits
jake breaking for large trucks
because they want to keep the noise down
allow unmuffled ohrvs on the city
streets
furthermore hrv trails are open from
dawn to dusk
the season opens in may
and generally closes around october 31st
these are the best six months of the
year in new hampshire for enjoyment of
one's yard and property
people report having to yell at each
other to carry on a conversation on a
front porch
windows on the roadside of the their
houses cannot be open during the summer
months due to noise and dust
the affected citizens use
use and enjoyment of their property
is substantially diminished under these
conditions
when the selectmen and bureau of trails
declare these roads to be
trails
please consider that it's the current
taxation policy of new hampshire that
the value of a property with a pleasant
view
can be taxed at a higher value than a
similar property without such a view
as a result the tax liability on such a
property is higher due to that special
positive circumstance sometimes called
the view tax
doesn't it follow that a special
negative circumstance should allow a
lower tax liability
properties impacted by having the
adjacent roadways become ohiv trails are
burdened by an unwelcome nuisance
rather than benefiting from something
like a valuable view
given the noise dirt dust fumes and
other detriments generated by proximity
to such trails on town roads
it is simply fair and just to recognize
the burden and loss of value
as house bill 1289 proposes
such an effective property should be
eligible for an abatement
for good cause
and then allowed to be taxed at a lower
amount due to special circumstances
if the other requirements of the law are
met
by way of anecdote i have spoken with at
least one citizen in the north country
who's been informed
that his taxes are higher than others in
his area
because of the value added
for the truly pleasant view from his
home
however now
all summer long he suffers daily waves
of ohrvs
documented at over 780 document ohrvs in
a day
divide that by eight hours and that's
more than 80 oh hrvs an hour
some days they're in the hundreds
traveling on the pond side road where he
lives
the circumstance this circumstance was
created because the town selectmen in
the new hampshire bureau of trails have
made that road into an ohrv trail
the property owner was informed that
while he
pays extra for the view he may get no
abatement for the noise dirt dust and
disruption caused
by the road becoming a trail
so because of the impact on the quiet
enjoyment and value of these citizens
property
caused by the public policy that permits
these roads to become trails it has only
failed to afford the property owner on
such roads the opportunity to petition
for a tax abatement
with good cause
i hope you'll give this
idea
a positive hearing and send it to the
floor of the house for a positive vote
it will
be well received by the people who
suffer from these circumstances thank
you very much
yes sir
so you're seeking
the ability to apply for an abatement
which will lower the taxes for the
property owner
what
what benefit does the
that property owner that's dealing with
the noise
and the dust and so forth yet
other than financial
unless the legislatures
douse
selectmen
and
the bureau trails that they can't make
class five and six roads into trails the
property would get no other relief the
other than a bit of compensation
for the harm they suffer as a result of
having this nuisance created by
government
for whatever reasons the government may
seem and you believe that that
benefit of the abatement will
make the make these
affected citizens happy
i believe it will make them happier sir
it won't make them happy
yes representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you uh
honorable my hand for being here thank
you um
i was up in that area and i observed a
lot of the ohrv activity in front of
homes and and on on city streets
and i was appalled by what people have
to tolerate
but my question is uh have they not had
access to any abatement before this is
this
i believe i understand your question i
believe and the answer is
i i believe under 76 16 any citizen can
file an abatement petition with a
selectmen the issue and the and the
benefit that this statute as i
understand it will offer is that it
gives
a presumption
that the petition is got good cause
so the citizen
may still have to persuade the selectmen
of how much the damage is the swap and
still have all the discretion they have
with regard to any other abatement this
doesn't affect the slayman's power
it just prevents them the from it
prevents the citizen from being told
that you know ohrvs are not a reason for
an abatement go away
it gives them the right to say oh all
right you've got good cause we have to
consider it
that's my understanding of the law and
its impact
representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you
honorable for taking my question
my question pertains to the process by
which a municipality
allows a road such as a classics road to
be used for
such recreational purposes is there a
hearing is there opportunity for our bud
is to come in to provide import and
could you explain that process to me
thank you i'll explain it as best i can
and it's a it's a sore point in the
sense most of the coast county
became open to hrv trails in 2000 and
i was going to say even early in 2013
and it was done
[Music]
in my own town
the bureau of trails called the
selectmen on a monday night
because
and said do you are you okay with our
making your roads into trails and the
selectmen two of them were present that
monday night and they said sure go ahead
there was no public hearing there was no
notice to the property owners
until the signs started going up
that it's now a part of the ride the
wilds trail
the right wiles trail
advertises a thousand miles of ohrv
trails of which to the best i can get
for information at least three or four
hundred of those miles are public ways
they're not
trails in the woods where the noise and
the
dirt and the congestion
and the fun
um will be found
it's public ways
so there there is an effort and has been
an effort in prior years recent years to
get notice and require notice and there
may in fact be the case where selectmen
now must give notice
of a hearing before they
allow
such a use representative guthrie
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony your honourable
former house
uh we miss you i'm quite sure uh
is it your contention that
the assessing cannot take into
consideration the conditions that you're
talking about because there's no
question that there
i don't know how you contend with it and
i'm a selectman in hampstead and we
don't have it and i'm glad we don't have
it because if this bill passed the
unintended consequences is that they're
going to get about 200 requests for an
abatement so again to get back to my
question is it your contention that the
assessors
cannot take this into consideration when
they're determining the value of the
homes
this has been a a situation since 2013
or longer and
while when they assess
property for views they actually make a
point of putting in the assessment that
so much may be related to the view
there's no history of them taking into
consideration the negative consequences
of trails and noise and things of that
nature
i expect
a sincere assessor
would
but he'd have to sit out there on a
saturday and count the 780 ohrbs going
by listen to him to somehow make a
subjective
assessment as to what that
value is
um
i had thought that it would be good for
this
statute to say the abatement would be
250 dollars off credit against your tax
some firm amount but it doesn't say that
it leaves it up to the judgment of the
selectmen to use their judgment along
with their town assessor if necessary to
come up with a value
um so i think the value still
enters in
because
once the petition for good cause is
presented it still becomes quite
quite judgmental or on the part of the
selectmen as to what they want to do we
have my deepest sympathy
and through all those
people and i'm sorry
but they have to contend with this well
thank you for bringing it forward and
we're great that's why we're grateful to
representative renzolo and others who
have carried on the
effort to address the issue thank you mr
chairman thank you
representative manchuri
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
i try to look at each bill as an
individual bill but we can't do that we
have to we can't just do that we have to
look at it in its totality we have two
other bills that we heard today
both consider
uh abatement of nuisances that interfere
with the enjoyment of property
that give cause for unsanitary living
conditions
those are two different bills
that give towns cities health inspectors
the right to look at things as they
affect your personal property
so i look at your bill and wonder
could you see where the board of
selectmen would say i reject your good
cause
and take it a step further i'm not going
to abate your taxes
but instead i'm going to close that road
would i have a problem there if all
three of these bills passed because i'm
making a judgment on what i what we are
considering to be a nuisance
and unsanitary conditions
and have three separate at least three
separate instances where i can make that
judgment and i'm wondering if i'm going
to have a problem my question is am i
going to have a problem if i deny your
abatement on a judgment for what a
nuisance is
does that make any sense
i say all the time i'm not even sure
that my question made sense
i i do i believe i understand
how much
the existing tax code
and maybe recommendations for other
changes to the code
put a burden on selectmen and city
assessors and people have to make those
those calls
one of the differences that i see here
from what i understand your question to
address is that the property owner
who puts in a olympic-sized swimming
pool is personally doing something
that ends up increasing the value of his
property
if you buy a house with a spectacular
view that increases the value of your
property that's something you've chosen
and you've done
if you let your property go to
hell
and and if that's what the nuisance or
bad condition issue is i mean that's
something that's being personally done
by a land owner and it should be dealt
with somewhat
differently than this
this is an abatement as a result of
action that government took
the government made this
from a standard road which has noisy
vehicles that go by already but when it
adds hundreds
of unmuffled
vehicles designed both from a safety
perspective and every other perspective
to not be on town on pavement these
vehicles come with a warning in the
front of their owner's manual it says
don't operate on public ways unless
approved they're dangerous they're not
designed for a public way
but my point is that's government that
made that change that's government
that's made
the reason and the good cause for this
abatement and
i think a side benefit is selectmen will
have to take
the financial impact
of making
their town a recreational
trail into account when they decide to
do that in the future because they know
that they may be affecting the property
values of their citizens
so it may give them something extra to
think about thank you for your question
i'm sorry
uh thank you for taking my question or
thank you for
uh i'd like to follow up on
representative power's question
uh apparently it's very easy
to uh
for the uh
class five and six roads to be adopted
as uh
trails
uh
is it that easy to
reverse the adoption
interestingly
there is no requirement for a public
hearing to make
the decision to allow
class five and six rows to become trails
you do have to have a public hearing to
stop
uh class five or six year old from being
a public
ohrv trail
so in a sense i i would say it's harder
to stop the nuisance once you've created
it than it is to create it to begin with
if that answers your question
uh
yes it does
thank you very much thank you
uh continuing along that same line
would you be looking to us to put in a
requirement for a public hearing prior
to designated one designating uh road
for this type of activity
there have been uh bills introduced and
i think that issue has been addressed um
in other legislation so it is not
something that this would need to
that your committee would need to
address in my humble opinion any other
questions for the representative i mean
for the uh
for the man testifying a former
representative
seeing none
i'm very grateful thank you thank you
very much and welcome back thank
okay now we'll you
hear from um abby
evan cowell
is that right
again
ivanko ivanko got it
floor is yours thank you my name is abby
ivanko
and i live in gorham new hampshire
about a mile from where ride the wild
starts
my friends live in gorham colebrook
pittsburgh henniker stratford berlin
milan dummer hillsborough
and they are all impacted by ohrvs going
past their homes
i absolutely agree with this bill that
recreational off-highway vehicle use is
cause for an abatement
earlier someone asked about how much
i would argue
if it's five months of the year it
should be that percentage of their taxes
removed
because that is how long these people
cannot enjoy their homes they run from
them
many and i also i ask that you amend
this bill to include all public ways
route 2 and route 16 in gorham are open
to ohrvs that was by a vote of the board
of selectmen without a butter
notification
without consideration of our zoning laws
and these people they know what trucks
sound like they know what motorcycles
sound like and now they have hundreds of
atvs going past their homes
after committee meetings writing to
officials on and on seven households in
gorham finally sued the town of gorham
and the bureau of trails to have these
atvs taken out of their neighborhood
and the attorney general is using all
its might to crush these seven
households
um
atvs have been causing problems around
new hampshire for over 20 years now
in 2001 the legislature established the
hb
717 committee
quote to make recommendations on policy
concerning state operated trails and
private lands used by off-highway
recreational vehicles
as it worked the study committee found
quote significant controversy regarding
noise dust and illegal
operation of various kinds
again as as a representative moynihan
said it's well established that these
things are a nuisance
the atv concluded committee concluded
that quote
other trail uses low impact snowmobile
and non-motorized conflict
conflict with atv use
new or expanded trails
should be for atv use only and conflict
issues will not arise
i remind you this is from a 2001
committee
ride the wilds was opened in 200 2013
against this recommendation
certainly residential life is an inc
incompatible
atvs are incompatible with residential
life
i quote further from this committee
report
the policy of course and fine filtering
must remain in place environmental
concerns and the potential degradation
of an area must always be the paramount
consideration
again these are neighborhoods being
degraded by these trails
another recommendation quote the
emphasis should be on development of
self-contained trails not linear trails
and now you've got ride the wilds
throughout coast county
they are not self-contained
these recommendations have been ignored
and art and our towns have been turned
into linear trails
with homeowners subjected to hundreds of
atvs roaring through
as this committee
is charged with municipal and county
government
i want to point out to you that there
are two laws written to protect new
hampshire citizens from recreational
off-highway vehicle use
rsa-236 cohen 56 roman 2d
and rsa-215a10
both of these
exempt costs from the protections that
are written for the entire state if you
live in another county you have more
protections from ohrvs than you do in
coast
so um
as you consider if recreational
off-highway vehicle use is an avatable
cause
know that co-op citizens are denied
equal protections in law by these
exemptions
thank you for your time and
consideration
any questions
yes representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
you said you live in gorham and uh do
you remember before this h
ohrv was
allowed on the public ways yes yes i do
and you uh would you
be yeah it was quieter
i mean you can hear atvs from every part
of town now i'm a gardener
and i was gardening i was working in
various parts of town i could hear the
roar of atvs in every part of town i was
picking blackberries in the town forest
i could hear the roar
of atvs somehow going through
conservation land i don't know how atvs
combined with conservation land
i live i live a mile from the trail
moose brook state park is between my
house and the trail and i can hear them
roaring through
so when my my friends down at the
trailhead their homes are 60 feet from
these trails my heart breaks for them
and to your question
no this appointment won't give them what
they want they want their road they want
their lives back they want their
residential neighborhoods back
you mentioned that
you think this ought to be expanded to
include all public ways let me suggest
talk to that man right over there under
the clock uh
representative renzolo and see if he if
he wants to expand
the uh
the legislation to include that yeah and
the reason for that is because the
gorham selectmen were involved in every
decision to open every atv trail in
gorham on private land on the rail trail
on the state roads on the town roads
thank you any questions yes
representative
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um is it your consideration that
um ohrv use is incompatible with other
uses of the trails such as bicycles
walking horseback riding any of those
things
yes and it was established in the 2001
study committee
and uh
every state does a statewide
comprehensive outdoor recreation plan
and wisconsin they have
a chart that shows that ohrv riding is
highly antagonistic
with
eight out of nine other recreation
recreational uses and they are still
moderately antagonistic even with
snowmobiles
so it's it's established it has nothing
to do with opinion
thank you
any other questions
oh yes
john
thank you for taking my questions
up in your area isn't the
ohiv a fairly big part of the economy
for the community
it is a loud part of the economy
we live
we abut the white mountain national
forest which brings millions of visitors
in
gorham has been a tourist town
for
over a century people coming in for the
quiet of the mountains hiking
if you look at fish and game statistics
uh
far more fishing license fishing
licenses
well over a hundred thousand fishing
licenses are sold every year
and actually before kovid atv
registrations
had started to decline and they were at
i don't know 36 37 38 000 and it's
over a hundred thousand fishing licenses
and i don't know anyone disturbed in
their home by someone fishing
i may have a lakefront property
in a channel
and there may be four or 500 boats that
go past my house
every day with loud motors should i also
get an abatement
i don't know
i just know that this has been a drastic
change in use
in our community and that noise
pollution is a serious health problem
i i think there's no reason for any
motor to be that loud
okay thank
you yes representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
and yet another question
um are you aware of any health
effects negative effects of children in
your communities especially young ones
with you know loud noise
and not being able to
sleep or
a hearing problem because of that
are you aware of any of those things
no not as it pertains to
young children
i do know a friend of mine was walking
on the sidewalk
and
an atv revved right next to her and
caused temporary hearing damage
so but it is established that
loud
decibels of this
size
damage human health
uh i have a question um going back to
what i said originally
it seems to me that
if you can get an abatement or a larger
invade abatement
the homeowners may get a couple hundred
dollars
less in their tax bill
might i suggest that that's not really
what they're looking for
i would completely agree with you sir so
i guess
my thought would be
we're gonna
we're gonna vote on whether we support
this or not but
i might suggest that you gather
the impacted
families together and say what do we
really want out of this do we want
the ohrvs to go away
do we want something else we want a
larger barrier between
where they go and where our houses are
so so that's the thing i think i think
uh
once you get larger abatements
your account your accountant may be
happy because
you're going to see a little bit more
money in
in this tax return
but it doesn't take any of the noise the
dust
the nuisance doesn't take any of that
away
and
i
so i'm not
i'm reflecting on the fact that i'm not
sure this is what you really want
i agree with your assessment it's um
they want their homes back they want
these trails removed from their
neighborhoods where they were put in
without any notification
um they want their zoning
honored these are residential
neighborhoods we gorham has
a noise ordinances
a noise ordinance
you roosters were prohibited when this
bill went through
roosters
and you could have no more than five or
six chickens and they could not be in
nuisance by noise or odor that was the
standing ordinance when the select board
voted to allow off highway recreational
vehicles to travel through this
residential neighborhood
okay we have the we have the legislation
the proposed to us
we will evaluate that and you have my
advice
to think about maybe think about a
little different way of what you really
want
and it's too late now to change that
for this year but maybe next year you
could come back and say this is what we
really want yes representative vann
thank you chairman thank you for taking
another question uh
do you consider that it's likely that
the select board may reconsider their
decisions if they have to start shelling
out abatement after abatement after
abatement
i think other citizens might care
might start to care
if their tax bill goes up
uh right now people
if it's not
the use is very much concentrated in
different areas of town the burden is
not distributed equally so some citizens
are suffering terribly
and other citizens are saying oh it's
not in my neighborhood i'm okay
so if their bill started going up
because this other neighborhood was
negatively impacted they might start to
care
thank you
seeing no final questions i want to
thank you for your testimony thank you
next we're going to hear from nhma mr
grays
thank you mr chairman h grace for the
new hampshire municipal association i'm
just commenting on this bill we do not
have a position
there are a couple questions that
committee members asked earlier that i
do want to address believe
representative power asked about the
current process for opening
and closing roads to ohrvs
that's found under rsa 215 hyphen a
colon 6 roman 9
that also references references rsa 215
hyphen a colon 15.
essentially what that requires is that
there be a public notice
with it with notice to the abutters on
the affected roads
and that notice has to go out uh 14 days
in advance
of that public hearing
and after that conclusion that hearing
the governing body can vote whether to
open or close the road
and additionally the
costs of providing notice both to the
abutters and posting notice generally
is borne by whoever the petitioning
party is so if it's the local ohrv club
they would pay for if it's the
homeowners that want to close the road
they would pay for it
my understanding is the this change
occurred i think two or three years ago
and it didn't affect any current
disposition so
if a road was currently open to ohrvs
and then a group got together and wanted
to close it
you know they'd have this new process
they would have to go through which is
which is what um some of the discrepancy
that was described earlier today might
have might have covered
um
as far as
this bill goes
under
rsa 76 colon 16
the selectmen or assessors for good
cause shown may abate any tax including
prior years taxes assessed by them or
their predecessors including any portion
of interest accrued on such tax
the term good cause shown is not defined
in the statute
what this bill would do is simply add
a
and
partial definition
and then it says that good cause shall
include
allowed recreational use of ohrvs on
and then if it's amended potentially
more than just class six and class six
roads or class five and class six roads
um i would suggest the committee that
the term good cause is purposely vague
here
essentially if you can go to the select
board and make a good argument about why
your property was incorrectly valued
during the assessment process
they could give you an abatement
and that's going to vary
typically it's going to be related to
the property itself
you know perhaps the the select board is
unaware of the fact that you had some
you know
termite investigation or something like
that that totally destroyed the inside
of the property and therefore the value
or the building in there the property is
not
as highly valued but it could have
external causes as well
one of the common ones is if someone is
receiving municipal welfare they
obviously can't pay their taxes because
you know they need assistance from the
town they're not
they don't have the means to pay for a
lot of things so it doesn't make sense
to tax them because the select board
would just be
paying them to pay themselves it would
be it would be a circle
um so to representative guthrie's point
earlier
presumably if properties are valued
correctly at the assessment stage there
would be no need for
for an abatement
but because
we already have this vague term good
cause presumably if you had
loud boats loud motorcycles loud ohrvs
and could convince the select four that
that was caused to devalue your property
you could get an abatement for that
but as i stated the the municipal
association does not have a position
i do want to note um
that currently there's there is a bill
two different bills
working through
the legislature
there's hb
1109 which the sponsor
also sponsored
that would change the process for
opening and closing roads to ohrvs
to be a legislative body vote instead of
a governing body vote
there's also hp 1188 which is go would
create a commission to study ohrv use in
the state
it's a very broad
commission
presumably it would cover
whether
any change needs to be made to the
abatement
process as well but um i think it would
i think it would cover a lot of what
chairman dolan pointed out to the
previous speaker in terms of what we
want to do as a state and state policy
regarding ohrvis
thank you
yes representative
thank you mr chair thank you mr grace uh
could you just tell me where these hb
1109 and 1188 are
i believe both are in the resources
recreation and development committee i'm
not sure if they've been um exact or not
thank you
it's representative guthrie
thank you mr chairman thank you again
for your testimony
as i said before i'm a selectman in
hampstead
and
we've always felt that you can obey for
anything
correct it's in the eye there is a ball
beholder and this bill
is not what would i be correct if i said
this bill is not
necessary for the process to go forward
for a request for an ape an abatement
and they the homeowners can request an
abatement at any time for any reason
and they really don't need this tool if
you will to go forward with the problem
that's my interpretation as well
it sounded like some of the testimonies
today that they were really looking for
a tax credit not an abatement now follow
up if i could mr trump it's been
to i've asked the question a couple of
times i guess but
is it your understanding that the
conditions that we're talking about in
this these situations cannot be
considered when the original abatement
is made
well i would as
my understanding of how the assessment
process works is that
the assessment
should take into account the value of
the property and the value of the
property would be based on
whatever the market would support so
presumably if you're next to a large
factory
your property is going to be less even
if the
exact you know building and the exact
size of the property the same as
something across town because
there are outside factors there
presumably that could take into account
um the use of the roadways as well
i you know
this all gets very complex and is way
above my pay grade um but i am too as i
said presumably if it's correctly valued
in the first place you don't need to
have an abatement because everyone's
paying what they should be paying based
on what the value the property the
various properties are
um
but if they can come in and say hey you
missed this that's really the basis of
the abatement
i suggest to you if i may mr chairman
that the whoever the
assessors are in these communities
are to
take a look at what they're doing and
how they're valuing those homes
i will pass that on
thank you yes representative
uh thank you mr
i'm sorry mr chair and uh thank you for
taking my call um i i think um the the
previous speaker uh
kind of
hit what some of the things that i
wanted to speak to
so my question is
is there potential
by naming this specifically that we're
going to create a slippery slope of
boats
public roads trains going by
recently nashua had a train idle for
nine and a half hours by a residential
area
would all of those kind of things um
fall
because suddenly become named in future
bills
so thank you for the question so what
i've
i think that we've seen in the history
of the development of the law in new
hampshire is we've typically started out
with specific lists and those have
gotten very long and various statutes so
for example
um under rsa 53a
multiple communities can join into
cooperative agreements and it used to be
that it was for a
long and then increasingly long list of
specific things and then at some point
the legislature said hey this doesn't
make sense let's just say
you can enter into those agreements for
anything you could lawfully do
um so in the kind of the same vein
kind of just
letting it be a vague good cause allows
different select boards to make
different decisions um it's
rather than have a very long list
thank you very much um
so i guess my question would be
would you make better recommendation
because i think these people are
suffering um closer to what um chairman
dolan had said of
of trying to
to get these roads to be more approved
or pulled back or something that would
that be a better recommendation for the
towns and cities
um
so
i don't have a specific policy
recommendation um i i did note that you
know there is hp 1109 if that's
something that
um
is that
members of the legislature want to
consider um as an option
um
certainly there's there's also um
1118 hp 11 18 for a commission
um
i've been in a number of these ohrv
hearings over in resources recreation
development i can tell you they packed
the room they're usually
like 100 speakers um it takes the whole
day it's a very controversial issue i i
can't solve it
thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
grace for taking my question you talked
about market value being a basis for
determining the assessed value
from your experience maybe attending
some of those hearings by resources and
from testimony of her today
would a house on an ohrv
trail
if that's being on the market and shown
let's say in april
would you expect it would be the same
market value then maybe three months
later with the traffic that's been
described
or would the market value change because
of the nuisance of the noise and dirt
well thank you for the question now i'm
speculating here
but
i assume that assessments are based on
the selling value sales value and
presumably the person selling the
properties isn't going to want to
disclose anything that might be
considered a defect
whether that's you know the boiler is
about to go or whether there's a huge
amount of traffic during certain times
of year
um and
it's
the the old the old saying is buyer
beware and so the the buyer is going to
have to be savvy enough to sort of suss
that out with you know the assistance of
their real estate agent if any
um that does cause problems because it's
certainly something you might not
necessarily know if you're not from that
community that that might be an issue
whether it's this or something else um
so i don't
i don't know
um i think we're looking towards what
the true value is and that might be very
hard to to determine okay thank you
okay uh
yes representative tripp i mean liseles
i'd like i'd like to follow up on uh
representative rung's uh question of you
one of the the most important websites
that you go to if you're looking to rent
or buy a property
in coast county
is craigslist
okay
if you go to craigslist
would you believe
that if you are right on a
atv trail or a snowmobile trail that is
a very positive thing
in marketing your property would you
believe that
i would believe it i have no experience
in this area
well thank you uh mr graves appreciate
your testimony thank you
and
we have now
that's it
okay so i'm going to close the hearing
on hb 1289
and for all of you who came
long distance for this meeting thank you
very much
uh
thank you
okay we're going to now open the
public hearing
for
hb
1293 which is relative to the design of
sewage or waste disposal systems for a
person's own domicile
floors u.s
thank you mr chairman for the record my
name is mark mcconkey i represent the
good people of carroll county three
i hail from freedom and i've resided in
public works and highways for 16 plus
years
i'm here to introduce house bill 1293
relative the design of sewage and waste
disposal systems for a person's own
domicile
this is a housekeeping legislation for
the department of environmental services
subsurface
so you might ask why mark sits before
you
i have been a permitted new hampshire
permitted septic designer for more than
30 years
i have done hundreds and hundreds of
designs my sons have followed me and
worked with me in the trade
and there are years that we produce over
15 percent to 20 of all the septic
designs generated in carroll county
part of the process to become permitted
by the state
is that you need to
pass two parts of a testing protocol
with them
one is a knowledge of the environmental
rules that pertain to sewage disposal
and the second and most important is
that you have to pass a competency
in evaluating soil the most important
component of our of our industry
is being able to judge where the
seasonal high water adjusts to over a
period of 20 years
when i started in on this practice 30
plus years ago
it was pretty standard we were using
stone and pipe and that all systems
would be built four feet above that
height
the
if you would provide at least two feet
of great soil underneath that system
there were some that claim you could put
a cup of water underneath it and you
could drink that that effluent as it
comes through i have never done that
i've never suggested anyone do that
technology marches forward
like it does in every other industry in
a majority of the systems that many many
of the systems now
have gone from stone and pipe to enviro
to elgins to all these other
innovative systems
that instead of needing to be four feet
above seasonal high water you only need
to be two foot above seasonal high water
the margin of error of a layman figuring
out where that mark was
just became extremely important because
if they missed that mark and they're
less than two feet above that seasonal
height of
water
then we're shedding untreated effluent
into the groundwater
the department had asked me to bring
this forward on their behalf
i understand the issue
i'm happy to answer any questions i know
the department is here to answer further
for you also
questions from the committee
yes representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um
i'm trying to
formulate the question in my mind um
and i'm looking at the language
so i'll just i can't i can't say the
word that i'm looking for but my
question
pertains to
this septic design being approved
so currently a homeowner can in fact
make the app do the design and make the
application is it not true that
regardless
whether it's a licensed septic designer
or a homeowner do both applicants that
must their designs be approved
by another another agency
designs must be are reviewed and
approved by the department
and the department is taking on face
value
uh that the person that has submitted
this is knowledgeable enough to know
to know where the seasonal high water is
follow-up
so in either case
um
or the case of the homeowner that their
design
still must be approved
thank thank you for the question um the
department reviews the design it has to
be designed the difference is
when the department reviews a design
done by myself or my boys or other
licensed people
they know the quality of our work and
we've been tested to know that we know
what's in the soil
when the department gets a homeowners
and
design before them
they the department doesn't have that
same certainty of what they're looking
at
follow-up mr chair
thank you so what the concern is from
your standpoint is the integrity or or
the
integrity of the septic design
due to the fact that the homeowner
may or may not and most likely not be a
licensed septic designer and so
therefore
the evaluation
to approve this design is not you're not
checking every single jot and tittle of
the design is that the concern thank you
thank you for the question i think it
was a good summary
any other questions yes representative
ron
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
is this
is the current rsa applicable to all
septic systems or or septic systems that
may be near
vulnerable locations shorelines wetlands
whatever
are they held to a higher standard or is
this does this apply to all of them
the nature of my question comes is that
i'm wondering if by restricting septic
designs to just the professional
engineers such as yourself rather than
just any person that
we may be able to address
threats to
very
sensitive environmental locations
thank you
for the question i'm pondering
your question so
um
being accurate becomes uh even
more important the closer you become to
a valuable resource
a river and so forth and
wetlands
aquifers and all of that
i
i don't think i don't think if the
question was should the bill be broken
for certain locations
i don't think so
you had characterized designers as
engineers
i just want to make the point that a lot
of us are laymen we're contractors we're
not engineers you're going to have the
pleasure hearing from an engineer after
but we're we are trained in the field
and we have to
we have to know soil we have to know
wetlands we have to draw those
boundaries
and for the purposes of a septic design
we are permitted to go in and put those
boundary lines on our plan
so and once again if if you're if you're
a layman by being a homeowner i don't
know that you have that level and would
know enough to say for instance
to pull yourself 50 feet from what they
call a hydric soil or 75 feet from a
poorly drained so
your question's valuable and
i i hope i answered what you want
thank you
question
who did you say you brought with you
from the environmental services
behind me is uh rob tardif from who's
the subsurface administrator
and i believe
i'm not familiar with the other
gentleman from the department
who is uh phillip throwbridge pe
who is the manager of the land resource
management program water division well
i'm assuming that they're here because
there's a message that needs to be
delivered to the committee from them i
would believe so mr chairman
why don't i invite
invite them up to the
base up here and
ask you a few questions
certainly
welcome
thank you
hello again i was here earlier this
morning uh
thank you again for letting me testify
and and this time house bill 1293 again
my name is rob tardiff
i'm the administrator of the subsurface
systems bureau within the department of
environmental services
just briefly the subsurface systems
bureau regulates all on-site wastewater
in the state of new hampshire
regardless of whether it's residential
or commercial
we also do
subdivision of land
and
relative to 1293 we permit or license
they're kind of synonymous here
all septic system designers and
installers in the state
other than for a person's own domicile
you must be a permanent designer or
installer to design and install systems
right now we have approximately
680 active
designers in the state
and about 1500 active installers
as representative mcconkey pointed out
each one of those
professionals have had to pass a state
exam
and that that exam demonstrates their
knowledge of
soils and their relation the
relationship of soils in the seasonal
high water table
i don't necessarily think i need to
repeat a lot of what representative
mcconkey said i'd be happy to go over it
uh but in an effort to save everybody's
time here you field a few questions
of course
representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so could you explain to to us what
happens when you receive a
a a septic design plan that's very poor
and and just not adequate what is the
process is it just is it denied
or does the department have to assist
and
lead
the the homeowner
into correcting the design mistakes what
does that process look like how much
time does that take in the resources
from your department
thank you for the question uh every
application is reviewed again if there
are any deficiencies noted during that
review we issue what's called a request
for more information letter in that
letter it describes it itemizes all of
the deficiencies that we found with the
application
hopefully
when the applicant or the designer or
the homeowner in this case receives that
letter they can correct the deficiencies
resubmit the application to us or at
least resubmit
the information that we've requested in
our letter
and then we
in time will be able to issue the
approval unfortunately with the
homeowner designs that request for
information process goes back and forth
many many more times than it would for a
permanent designer like representative
mcconkey which takes a significant
amount more a significant more amount of
staff resources
thank you
so you know further questions thank you
oh i'm sorry representative tripp
thank you mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
uh
when i first
reviewed this bill
uh one of the things that struck my eye
was that
the person that developed their own plan
had to
provide that
they
meet the eligibility for this exemption
what kind of process is there for
someone uh
attesting to their eligibility
thank you for that question i'm sorry
that this the speaker is right in
between us here um
that that can be interpreted a number of
different ways one is the eligibility or
the knowledge
that we would like to have from people
submitting applications relative to
soils groundwater
just all our rules our design rules but
it could also be interpreted as just the
eligibility of
that you actually live in the property
you're considering your domicile
so again that could be considered in in
two different ways
if i've answered your question
we would like we would like to be able
to say you have to demonstrate your
eligibility
through knowledge of
i know i'm sorry of
of soils and season in the groundwater
representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
so um my question is
only for
the do it yourself
folks that this is needed are there
other categories of
septic design and source
waste
system
design and uh implementation
uh this bill is and i'm hoping i'm
answering your question but this bill is
specific to homeowner designs for their
domicile let's do it yourself correct
kind of uh so are there other categories
is my question what other categories are
there
homeowners small businesses commercial
large scale
well we have residential systems and
commercial systems but i don't know if i
would consider them necessarily
different categories relative to design
thank you we have we have different
design flows that have to be taken to
account
to create the
appropriate design representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my um subsequent question so to
be very clear with regard to the
the the concept of diy
a licensed contractor or septic
installer
would be the only
parties
permitted to actually install
such a design
that's correct there's a very similar
statutory provision in rsa45836
where
the statutory provision we're talking
about about design is in
rsa45835 but there's a very similar
provision in 36 for homeowner
installation
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
i've replaced a couple septic systems in
my life and
aside from calling up the company and
writing a very large check
i really haven't been involved except i
did notice
i think during both of those installs
that somebody inspected i think with
somebody from the town
is is that inspection a common practice
throughout the state and
how would would that be impacted at all
by this bill
the inspection of the construction of
the system would not be impacted by the
belt but if i could back up a little bit
on your question
the bureau kind of has two
functions relative to septic systems and
that is we review every design before
it's approved
and then we inspect the other part of
our
bureau and specs every system before
it's placed into operation
if i could you take just a minute
my analogy is kind of when you build a
house you get a building permit when you
build a house that's essentially our
approval for construction we approve the
plans
and then on the again the house side you
get a certificate of occupancy right
that the town guy comes in or the town
person comes in inspects the house and
issues you a certificate of occupancy
in our
in our world we inspect every system and
we issue what's called an approval for
operation
so you have an approval for construction
we do an inspection we grant an approval
for operation
thank you mr tardiff
if i could just say if i could just add
one more thing very briefly
to your question about
sensitive areas
i would
like to say that we think that every
area is sensitive because we're really
protecting groundwater
i.e drinking water
so it's not just sensitive areas as far
as surface water goes or wetlands goes
so we feel that this should be a
statewide
thank you mr turtle you've helped
educate representative band
thank you chairman and thank you mr
tardif uh am i
am i correct in assuming that the issue
that we're trying to address here is not
so much the design of the system since
you have to inspect that anyway but you
inspect it as a design on a piece of
paper the issue is is the system going
to be situated appropriately vis-a-vis
the um
high-water mark
is that what we're trying to fix here
that's part of it but i mean that's
that's the vertical extent that we're
talking about as far as the design goes
there's also horizontal setbacks to
wells to right again wetlands surface
waters
but your follow-up please you're
depending on the design to
correctly
identify what the mean high water line
is and where those other
things the the horizontal issues about
the well you're depending on the
designer to have told you the right
thing there that's correct so this is in
an effort to make sure that that person
actually knows what they're doing
that's correct okay thank you
thanks thank you mr tardiff i appreciate
it
thank you much for you very much for
your time
we've learned something today
that's a good thing i hope so thank you
so that ends our our hearing on hb 1293
sorry
another speaker
mr chairman
okay i'm going to unbang my mallet
mr chris albert yes sir
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for taking your time
again for the record my name is
christopher albert i am chairman of the
grant state on-site wastewater
association it's a new name we've
rebranded used to be gsti we're the
septic designers evaluators pumpers
installers
land use professionals
we're in support of this bill we
understand the situation that des has
with homeowner designs i know we live in
new hampshire our home is our castle
but you know deciding a seasonal water
table is a science uh i have a four year
degree from unh a minor in soils i'm a
wetland scientist and evaluator designer
i put a lot of training into
understanding a water table i'm actually
an instructor at the university of new
hampshire teaching continuing education
on soils
the soils are the key under doing a
proper design if that's not done right
again we could have
failures to our groundwater our water
supplies and our wetlands so it again
it's i understand that the situation of
maybe sensitive areas
the problem with that concept is des is
only getting a small snapshot
of a plan they're not getting a giant
locust map that knows what's going on
maybe 500 feet away of a of a lake
perspective so again this should be a
broad-based uh bill the way it's
presented
allowing uh or not allowing any more
home or designs
do you have any more handouts
oh yes i do i'm sorry
oh i split half and half but yep
oh i think representative los alas ate
some of it
again i'll leave leave the letter for
the uh the committee to read at their
leisure but again it's the seasonal
water table is the key component of what
the homeowner's issues are mr republican
uh
mcconkey and mr tardif kind of outlined
those aspects and again we just want to
reiterate uh you know our board of
directors we we actually discussed this
at length and i had you know the support
of all the board members
uh for the passage on this bill very
good thank you for your testimony and we
have one more question thank you mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question are you aware of any um
such septic designs that that have been
installed and have failed and have have
caused damage to the environment or
other um
you know
consequences as a result of a faulty
design
every day unfortunately yeah i mean it's
it's it's you know we're seeing failures
all the time now of even the designers
not understanding a good concept of the
water table so it's it's a learning
process that's why we're always
continuously teaching it
failures on a leech field are pretty
isolated to that general area
but they have been known to break out in
the lakes i mean we have algae blooms
and our our cyanobacteria hits in our
lakes uh we're a non-point source
issue with our septic system so
again there will be future bills or
possibly bills this year about different
types of restrictions on development
along lakes but it is important
we're part of the culprits for our
our water quality that keeps new
hampshire so great
thank you mr abbott albert albert
representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um how
prevalent is the leeching and affecting
the groundwater and drinking water
through because of septic i i don't have
any studies with me but there i was on a
study through this this uh house last
year uh it is prevalent i mean if you
just look at your beach closures
every year they're getting they're
getting worse and worse
and septic systems as a non-point source
contaminant are are
a culprit of that so again
if things aren't done uh we're going to
lose our lakes
okay
now thank you for your testimony
appreciate it
so that
now closes the hearing on hb 1293
and we're going to open the hearing on
hb
1365.
thank you mr chair members of the
committee it's good to be back
my name is uh as most of you know
representative max abramson uh now that
i have lefloterial i'm i'm representing
the towns of hampton hampton falls and
seabrook and i'm introducing a bill that
that
just asks the question or would simply
provide the local option to allow towns
to split from
a one-word rate property tax to a
two-rate property tax system one for
residential and one for residential
essentially
industrial office commercial big box
stores
that kind of thing obviously the
seabrook nuclear power plant
is the largest uh individual property
taxpayer in seabrook and at one time
they were paying almost 90 percent of
the property taxes
as time has gone on
that amount has gone down and the burden
has shifted around now they pay about 40
percent
this bill is intended to to deal with
two problems one is dramatically rising
residential property taxes
which in some towns including very
blue-collar seabrook is is
threatening to force people out of their
homes
we had
when i moved in i believe my
property tax bill property tax bill for
the whole neighborhood was about 300 a
month for everything
uh today it's almost 700 a month
so there's a there's a tendency to want
to talk about what the rate is versus
the assessment
you know the things that can be done
with the
assessed value and so forth um but what
what's killing us is just the fact that
the the total bill is getting too high
and what's happened in in
business-friendly towns like seabrook
originally years ago we thought well as
the power plant pays less and less we'll
attract more business and then business
will take on more of the tax bill and
then our prop our residential property
taxes won't go up
that is actually isn't what's happened
what's happened is
we've done studies in recent years
finding that certain types of business
like retail actually cost you know about
18 or 19 dollars per thousand because of
the higher restaurants and fast food and
certain types of businesses take about
18 to 20 dollars per thousand because of
the higher rate of
uh 911 calls um obviously water and
wastewater garbage pickup you know per
square foot for restaurants for fast
food and drive-through restaurants the
impact on the town
uh towns is is actually a net negative
and what's been happening is more and
more towns are
around new england are cutting off big
box stores or cutting off certain types
of development or instead of having a
very business friendly planning board i
was served on my town's planning board
for three years instead of being
business friendly in order to both
create jobs
and at the same time reduce our
residential property tax bill what we're
being told is that for certain types of
business new business comes in and our
property taxes actually go up
so the response from towns has been more
and more inclination towards stopping
new business development and that's what
i'm worried about
as bad as property taxes can be for
businesses the the zoning power can be
just absolutely devastating and i've
i've seen business owners come in time
and again and once they they start
hitting uh the red tape and regulations
and once they're no longer being helped
and once they're
uh finding they can't get variances and
conditional use permits anymore
when the town turns against them it's
almost impossible to put a a building up
or even renovate or revise or expand a
building
without spending a lot of money on
lawyers
and that's not obviously that's not
guaranteed either so
my hope was to kind of return to a more
business-friendly environment for all
these border towns and towns that have a
large amount of retail shopping
that have lots of the strip malls and
big box stores and whatnot
to put that incentive in place um i'll
i'll give you an idea of the impact
based on the estimates that i did of the
of the breakdown of the property tax
in a place like seabrook residential
property taxes if this passed would go
down by an average of two thousand
dollars a year almost two hundred
dollars a month for residential property
taxes because
more than two thirds of our
uh more than seventy percent of our
property tax
bases business the power plant the dog
track
big box stores and so forth
hampton falls only has a small amount of
commercial development so i'm not sure
that they would adopt this because there
isn't that much to be saved for them but
hampton is split
it's almost even so i think that hampton
voters would
probably inclined to support it since
they would save about a thousand dollars
a year
in property taxes when we talk to
business owners where i thought there
might be some resistance small business
owners have a business
and they have a house
so they own two so they're paying
property taxes twice
on the net on the whole almost all the
business owners i talked to would have
at least in seabrook would save money
and would still vote for the measure
because they would you know they might
see their their business tax property
tax go up by
five or six or seven hundred dollars a
year but then if they're saving two
thousand dollars a year in residential
property taxes is definitely worth it
and and there's the the other issue that
we brought up on municipal and county
that that you do have it's it's only
people who live in town who are voting
on the property tax and that does affect
the business community and the business
community doesn't get to vote on the
warrant articles so they're kind of at
the mercy of it and we kind of
we would we would benefit as a state and
would certainly i think towns would
benefit if
the you know the marginal even though
it's a smaller amount what's left over
if the
if you no longer have this kind of
attitude where some voters are going in
and saying well we'll get the power
plant to pay for it we'll get all these
businesses and we'll get these offices
and industry to to pay for all these
warrant articles some warren articles
are absolutely necessary and even in
seabrook even in tough years those still
pass two to one
um all the school worn articles pass
every year
most of the infrastructure stuff
the absolute have to haves they pass
every year but
even i would admit that there are some
weren't articles that
um
they're iffy or they don't need to be
done this year or maybe they don't need
to be done at all um and and the
selectmen will just put put the question
on about and say do you want to spend
money on this new thing
and
um
normally those would fail but in in
seabrook sometimes they pass just
because there's this attitude of
well you know we'll have we'll have
business pay for it and that isn't
really fair so what i tried to do with
this bill is come up with one that was
mainly business friendly and also
residential property taxpayer family
friendly so what businesses get is their
property tax rate could go up by as much
as a dollar per thousand depending on
how this is written on the town warrant
but then that's locked in for three
years so they get a stable rate what we
consistently hear from business owners
is they really need the stability they
need to know
you know what they need to finance what
they need to do next year and the year
after and the year after that
the residential property owners would of
course have the lower rate and some
years you'd save a thousand a year some
years you'd save 2000 years some years
it would be about the same but overall
residential property taxpayers would
would save the money with uh that
variable rate but it would encourage
um on one hand land use regulations and
rules
that are more business friendly
and because 70 percent of the state's
revenue comes from business taxes
and a disproportionate amount of course
comes from business profits tax
and
meals and rooms tax
are two very large sources of revenue
that from our vantage point if a few
towns did take advantage of this and we
did then get more big box stores and
more of the larger business development
that the it would make the budgeting
process a little bit easier in the
future for the state i don't think that
a lot of towns would implement it
because it's
there are only a few towns in the state
where there's such a disproportionate
amount of business development that's
there already
but i i think that just looking at
seabrook and hampton i think that it's
likely they would
they would probably take the option
and my main concern the reason i put
this bill in of course is
we are seeing a lot of older folks
people on fixed income disability
people who are in a job where they're
paid they don't get promoted every few
years they don't get pay raises every
few years and they're really kind of on
fixed incomes
i do have a lot of blue collar folks in
my district and i have a lot of people
who are on a fixed income so they
they can't afford another
you know two or three or four hundred
dollars a month in property taxes they
just can't afford it that would wipe
them out
yes
representative manager putin
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
simply put
on to shifting the tax burden from one
group of residents to
another group which is residential to
commercial commercial to you know at the
end of the day
the
tax revenue
is what runs the towns and the cities
and
by giving a break
you're shifting it to the other so how
would that benefit
uh attracting more you're shifting it
it's an option for for
for towns with warrant articles so town
form of government
and it's
it's there are two different ways
there are two different ways that we
benefit one is that it encourages the
voters since it's
um
voters must be taxpayers and taxpayers
must be voters residential
homeowners and apartment owners people
who live in town are the only ones who
are voting on the warrant articles so
that's part of it we want to encourage
people to be
more prudent and more careful and get
more involved
at looking at the warn articles the
bigger issue that i'm looking at over
the long run is i'm seeing business
friendly towns like seabrook when i ran
for for planning board
[Music]
i i was continuously hearing this this
concern we originally were a very
business friendly town
top to bottom
in order to get business to pay more of
the property tax bill
so
towns and planting boards and town hall
they can just say we don't want any more
apartments
we don't want any more big box stores
i'm even hearing some people in town
don't want big box stores even in
seabrook and we're right on the border
right on the border with massachusetts
and driving distance of maine so if you
have more and more towns cutting back on
big box stores and large developments it
hurts the state's revenue it hurts
jobs for the state and
it would reduce the state's overall
revenue source so we want to maintain
we want towns to have a strong enough
incentive
uh in some way shape or form to
attract more business and maintain
business friendly zoning laws and land
use regulations
i think mr chair and and thank you for
taking my question um i i will admit
that i do have concern that will push
large businesses out of your town or
your city but my question is um
how does this work with cities i i know
that they have to pass an ordinance or
something but the dra
approves our rate the dra would have to
take the budget
create a
a rate for
each
body so for residential and for
businesses they would have to come up
with their own rate
it's
in the warrant article it it's it's for
towns with warrant articles um
we don't i pardon me my pardon my and we
don't do warrant articles in cities yep
yep so the measure is a local option for
towns with warrant articles it's kind of
town form of government which is run
very differently does budgeting very
differently cities have a lot more
flexibility in how they do budgeting
they're able to do
things like put contracts up for
competitive bid in november and december
and they get to save
money you know they can move funds
around and they have more flexibility
than we have in towns
so this was aimed at
specifically towns if there are members
of the committee who want this amended
to include cities i'm willing to to go
do the legwork and research on that
but what it says is yeah it would allow
the voters to
to push and it'd be the wording would be
in the warren article should the town of
seabrook separate his property tax rate
to raise
the
business rate up by could be 50 cents 75
cents or a dollar per thousand or any
amount up to that
and that would have businesses taking on
more of the tax burden that's true
but for in seabrook a dollar more per
thousand for business results in three
or four dollars less per thousand for
residential
for residential property owners now it
is we have to be realistic it's also the
same residential property owners who are
voting on the zoning laws and land use
regulations and whether or not to enact
impact fees and other development fees
and
and and so forth and and
as a former planning board member myself
i was answerable
directly to residential property owners
and not business owners and business the
businesses overwhelmingly tended to be
out of state and didn't have that much
representation so they kind of have a
tendency to just be at the mercy of
whatever residential property owners do
residential voters do so the the the
hammer that people can bring down
against business right now is basically
to just completely wipe out all new
development and just say no big box
stores and there are towns all over new
england that are saying no more big box
stores none
and they're completely putting a stop to
that that's
one of the things i'm trying to stop
with this bill i'm trying to make sure
that
residential voters understand
a big box store pays a lot of taxes
and can help a lot can help a lot to
reduce the tax burden
mr chairman have a follow-up yes go
ahead i i'm not quite sure that um
that you understood when i read this
line 26
it says in a city or town that has
adopted a charter pursuant to blah blah
blah right the legislative body may
consider an act upon the question in
accordance with this normal procedure
for passage of resolutions the title of
it is allowing towns and cities
to tax residential and non-resident
property at different rates so it
already does
address cities
my question still is
how would the dra have you spoken to
them i guess i should have asked it that
way how would the dra calculate
a different
rate
for residents versus right now we're all
at the same rate
they may go to court and disagree with
the assessment
but regardless they're going to pay the
same rate the residentials do how would
the dra
you
i understand you outlined it with towns
and warrants and so on
um cities don't work that way we do
ordinances and so we could adopt this
through an ordinance but how would it
work
uh
the way dra does it for seabrook um and
i've talked to folks in the finance
department and a few years ago i did
talk to dra about how about this issue
about allowing two different rates
but that's that's long before actually
introducing this bill
if it were done using this mechanism
then the the article itself allows them
to increase the business rate by up to
one dollar per thousand and they can
estimate what the amount of revenue is
for that and then whatever is left over
is paid for by residential the smaller
amount that's that remains is what's
paid for
um by residential
okay and uh thank you for that
clarification mr chairman i thank you um
then my next question is um
in the city of nashville we consider any
apartment building five and up
as commercial
would that fall within your
within this business versus
a residential you could have a five unit
apartment
in a fully residential area would you
tax them at a different rate than you
would tax
the next door neighbor yeah to be fair
um i did consider apartments and i also
have a provision in the bill for mixed
use
[Music]
so apartments would be considered
residential for property tax purposes
even if you had a town or city that that
only allows apartments in
commercial or even industrial or um i
worked with form-based codes so if you
have you know t1 t2 t3 t4 zones
different density zones it would still
work there it's it's the use of
the building itself and if you had a
split use like you had two floors of
residential and one floor of commercial
down on the bottom which is very common
in cities
down at the the down
floor that would be considered business
it would be taxed at the higher rate and
then the upper floors would be taxed at
the lower rate and the surrounding land
would be taxed at the lower residential
rates so the intent is
it gives resident it gives the voters an
incentive to
do a little extra work to keep the
property tax burden down and also keep a
business friendly environment
thank you
representative power
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative my
question pertains to the number three
as a as it relates to lines 17 and 18.
how did you come up with the the time of
three property tax years and what
happens to this separate tax rate
after three years does it simply expire
yes it's only a three-year provision i
assume that if if people are saving
money my assumption is that they're
going to keep renewing it every three
years
the reason for doing three years
sorry
the reason for doing three years is is
to say
trying to think i think it was the
conservative party's definition of
conservatism is being realistic about
human behavior
um and that people do tend to vote
for what they believe is in their best
interests
um people tend to act in their best
my my concern was what if somebody tried
you know or a group of voters tried to
game the system somehow that they would
enact this
and then that same year they would try
to buy a whole bunch of new you know all
sorts of gold-plated
brand new ladder truck and brand new
this that and the other thing and add
all kinds of additions that year
to try to pass this measure and then in
the same year pass a whole bunch of
warrant articles to just
expand the rec center and expand the
library and get that overpass people
wanted but they didn't want to really
pay for it and
and so on and so forth um locking it in
for three years is a way of kind of
protecting the business community from
just a sudden surge resulting from
people saying hey
we'll get the power plant to pay for it
and that that's at that actually is what
happened in seabrook um the power plant
came in it was paying 85 to 90
and people just said well the power
plant will pay for it
brand new fire station even though we
already had one brand new police station
brand
new library all sorts of you know brand
new parks and accessories and things
that are that are definitely not nice to
have but if the question had been
well if you have to pay for it would you
pay for it and now that the now that the
nuclear power plant only pays about 40
percent a lot of people are saying wow
this is this is really expensive our tax
bill has gone
it's more than doubled
um
you know so that's kind of hence the
idea but the reason for the three-year
lock-in rate is is is to provide
business would get at least some benefit
the benefit that they get is the
stability and being protected from
um
you know what they used to call in the
old days the tyranny of the majority
that
it is it is possible to have a majority
of people in town just say hey let's get
some free stuff
um
tax me tax the oh don't tax me don't tax
the tax the man behind the tree
um
you know we don't we want to have all
the nice things but we don't want to pay
for it i wanted to have a provision that
said
okay you can have it but you've got to
pay for it it's not right to keep
shifting the burden to somebody else
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
um
i'm from merrimack and i doubt this is
something we would do our two biggest uh
non-residential property taxpayers are
fidelity investments and inbev we have
an anheuser-busch brewery
um
i don't think they would be really happy
if we passed this
but i in reading through it why
it seems like the only option for a
municipality is to raise
taxes on non-residential property owners
why is there not a provision in case
there might be a circumstance a town
wants to lower
the property tax for non-residential
maybe they want to attract more business
or
or something like that i mean is why is
only one option available
well it is it is a local option so i
i i can kind of
guess which way my three towns would
likely go with this measure but it's
just a guess it's kind of speculation
uh merrimack i don't know in fact there
there are a lot of
towns where
sorry there are a lot of towns where 80
to 90 percent of the tax bill just comes
from residential right now i used to
live in um
deerfield and i think it was 90 was
residential so there'd be no reason even
to contact the town's lawyer and have
them look at this but there are a lot of
towns that are near 50 50.
[Music]
i think that it's
it's fairer
in the long run to business
to
incentivize the towns to create that
more business-friendly environment
and and i kept bringing up zoning and
land-use regulations but there are
actually a lot of different things on
you know permits and licensing fees and
expansions and and whether or not
the selectmen should give an abatement
whether or not planning board should
offer a conditional use permit whether
the zoning board gives gives out
variances and whatnot towns
choose
and they they can go very fast one way
or the other
and i i felt like while i was on the
planning board i felt like seabrook
could very quickly go from
business friendly
to not business friendly at all that it
could that they could pull up the
drawbridge and say no more no more
development the same way in the 1980s
they said no more apartment developments
absolutely none and there and there's
there's a degree of attitude by people
who've lived in seabrook for a long time
no more apartments because they felt
like they were overloaded if they
started saying the same thing about big
box stores and and
industrial developments and large
business developments um there'd be no
more large there'd be no more large
buildings coming into town
and and
and this this state
if more and more towns start moving away
from the business friendly environment
to just pulling up the drawbridge and
using their zoning powers or their or
their town powers or selectmen's
abilities
powers there'd be
a
a real stunt
in
in in large business development so
you have anheuser-busch you have or
portsmouth has a lot of large
business development they have a lot of
large companies if they said hey we
don't want any more large big box stores
or car dealerships or anything coming in
because now the cost is just a little
too high to serve them if they're saying
hey that actually hurts us as property
taxes that taxpayers takes away that
incentive to maintain a business
friendly environment and there are there
are towns and cities that aren't that
business friendly right now
thank you
there may be a distinction between
commercial which i think you're citing
and industrial but uh i'm still looking
for the answer why you think raising
taxes on businesses is business friendly
uh the
every single business owner i knew in
seabrook
every single one i talked to had a home
and a business that they have two
properties
and they told me that when i brought
this suggestion to them every single one
said that they would see
basically a net
savings
i mean obviously the nuclear power plant
would pay more obviously there are a few
big box stores that would pay more
but remember
right now as taxpayers
are our total payout for big box stores
big box retails it was something like 18
or 19 dollars per thousand and our tax
rate is 16 dollars per thousand
so we're
actually being forced to subsidize
certain types of business development
and as people became aware of that there
were full-on department heads there were
planning board members now saying wait a
minute there are certain types of
business development we can't recoup the
cost we can't even come close
so
why can't we charge seventeen dollars
per thousand if we're paying eighteen to
nineteen dollars per thousand
another thing that a lot of voters in my
area and not just in seabrook said is
that they don't like being forced to
subsidize and this is this was left
right middle libertarian everywhere on
the political spectrum everyone hated
having to pay extra taxes
even if it were a small amount but if
they're having to pay extra taxes to
subsidize business development they
hated that once they found out that they
were having to subsidize anything
so really big box retail
should be paying its own way and if it
costs if it costs over 18 dollars per
thousand
to provide myriad public services to
them then it's it's
it's uh
i don't think that it's unfair to charge
them 17
to provide 18 or 19
in and services if anything in that for
that case for for towns like ours this
would just reduce the subsidy to
business
okay uh next we're going to hear from
nick
herman
from derry
oh is that it for me that's it okay
i don't mean to run but i've got another
hearing going
thank you very much for for having me
speak my name is nick norman
and
i am an advocate for
landlords i follow landlord-tenant law
throughout the state
i'm a government i am the government
chair for the apartment association of
new hampshire
and personally i own 48 units and i've
been involved as a landlord for about 35
years here in new hampshire
our legislative update that follows all
new bills goes out to about
maybe 2500 or so landlords across the
state so i'm very connected into
landlord tenant law and the landlord
side advocating for landlords
i don't have a lot to say on this bill
and i don't quite fully understand
everything that max was presenting
particularly
how it's business friendly
to raise property taxes on businesses
our concern is that it seems like this
is a slippery slope
if you begin to have
a different tax rate for residential and
a different tax rate for commercial does
that mean we're leaning towards well now
why don't we have a separate tax rate
for multi-family owners
and other categories we're just
concerned that this is
a real slippery slope of what could
happen in the future it could be the the
opening of a door into a really bad
situation
in the rental housing
industry
and we're very very concerned about
affordable housing and anything that
increases the cost of managing
running
rental property
so that that's really my only point
the bill doesn't say anything about that
right now
it only says we want to be able to raise
property taxes on commercial
but again we
fear for what that will lead to
and it seems to me that
the property tax system is already fair
you pay based on the value of what you
own
so resident i mean commercial properties
are already paying
a higher amount
because
usually commercial properties are valued
higher than residential properties
i'd be happy to take any questions
anybody have any questions
seeing none we have another speaker
catherine heck
good afternoon chairman dolan and
committee members my name is catherine
heck from the new hampshire municipal
association and we are only commenting
on this bill we do not have a position
we did want to point out that the bill
is written does raise some question on
how the division of tax rates might work
on a practical level both from assessing
and from setting the tax rate so talking
about our assessors our tax collectors
and the dra as currently we do not have
provisions in our software or forms to
set to tax rates so that's one
consideration
however what i did want to touch on was
what we know from other states that
allow for a local option which we do
appreciate it's a local option when they
adopt a tax scheme that is intended to
shift the burden from
residential to commercial industrial is
that there is an unintended consequence
over time it does seem like a short-term
policy solution however we've heard from
other states that have similar tax
systems that are adopted locally that
what happens is costs are then passed on
to the tenants
once the tenants have to pay more they
tend to leave so then they move to the
next town and they find another
community who has not adopted this
provision
so in the long run this actually hurts
the community so imagine in 10 years or
15 years that
piece of property that was once a
vibrant business now is
falling apart
it has decreased the value of the entire
neighborhood because it's unkept perhaps
it's gone defunct and is now
you know taken by tax deed so now the
town is getting no dollars from that so
we have seen
from our neighbors just to the south who
have the scheme they
do not recommend that it's a long-term
policy solution so while i appreciate
that there's three years written into
this particular
bill
that it would lapse it appears in three
years there's nothing to say that a
petition warrant article won't come
forward because the
residential taxpayer is paying less
money regardless of what it's doing to
the economy of that town
so we did want you to perhaps consider
the long-term economic impact of this
legislation as you deliberate this bill
additionally
in new hampshire's constitution we would
like to point out article 5 that tax
rates
have to be proportionally assessed so
whether reasonable and proportional
become unconstitutional in this case we
don't have a legal opinion on but that's
something that you might want to
consider as well and i will take any
questions that you have
questions from
eric
so you mentioned in your testimony that
there are some other states that have
laws like this with local options for
different rates could you list some of
those states for us so if we wanted to
look into
how they implement it sure massachusetts
new jersey
to to name two that are um in new
england that's more closer to how we we
operate because they do local property
taxes they're not county run
yes
thank you mr chair uh thank you ms x for
taking my question in other states that
have similar laws
don't they also have prop
income tax and sales tax and other taxes
that is offsetting the revenue
yes those states do have those other
taxes that's
correct for quick follow-up
so that would be not comparing apples to
apple apples to orange isn't it
well we're talking about property tax so
they assess their property tax at a
different rate in those states they have
different tax schemes
so what happens is it drives businesses
out of one town and they move to a town
that has not adopted these provisions
so
i would say on the taxing side of the
property tax bill it probably is the
same because they're paying income tax
and sales tax in that state if they
remain regardless of where they're
physically
located within the geography of that
state
so um i understand but with that uh
you know because we don't have any other
revenues
this may not just
uh you know to move the businesses out
of that
town or
um
but maybe out of the state altogether
in this case
i can't speak to that but it's possible
yes
thank you for taking my question
tax policy has a dramatic effect on
business
i've been told
that with the
proliferation of
malls along our southern border
that they all have a provision
in their leases
that if there is ever a sales tax
enacted in the state of new hampshire
that their leases will be null and void
do you know if that's true
i do not know if that's true
thank you
any other questions for
nhma
seeing none
thank you
thank you very much
and our last speaker is david juvay
welcome the floor is yours
thank you mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is dave
giuve i'm a senior vice president for
public policy
for the business and industry
association
we serve as new hampshire statewide
chamber of commerce we have
approximately 400 plus employers with
over 80 000
employees here in the state
so i represent the people that would be
most impacted by this legislation
and although i tried to do the mental
gymnastics on how raising taxes
on a business is business friendly i was
not able to figure that one out uh but i
encourage all of you to go to the
employers in your communities and ask
them that i think the answer will be
different than uh those received by the
prime sponsor uh mr chair i'll keep my
comments very short but i just want to
put this proposal in the context of
what's going on with employers in the
state right now
right now in new hampshire because of
our
unique tax structure
business taxes are among the highest of
any state in the country our business
enterprise tax is unique to new
hampshire we can't even compare that to
other states because no other state has
it
similarly
property taxes are high here and i
simply i'm i'm a property taxpayer
you're probably all property taxpayers
probably everybody in the room is a
property taxpayer we understand that
property taxes
are high
but there is the benefit here that we
also often talk about about not having
an income tax on new hampshire sourced
income or a general sales tax so there
is a counterbalance
businesses are not only paying those
high business taxes but they're already
paying high property taxes just like
everyone else
this bill which is designed to shift the
property tax burden to employers will
make that even worse
these are employers right now around the
state who are already struggling because
they're having a hard time finding labor
they're already struggling uh because of
the ramifications of the coveted
pandemic either
having a direct impact on their business
and in terms of employee absenteeism or
what's more likely happening a reduction
in business if you're a hotel or a
restaurant
you're seeing the people coming into
your business at about 50 percent of
what it was pre-covered so it's not like
they have a lot of extra revenue to to
give back in a way this proposal
suggests
we're happy to do our part in
communities and pay our property taxes
because we benefit from the fire
departments and the police departments
in the good educational systems those
are all important to our businesses
but please
think long and hard about doing
something that is as unfair is what this
bill suggests thank you mr chair i'd be
happy to answer any questions any
questions
go ahead representative gallagher
so
um with you mentioning businesses having
a hard time finding people
to fill jobs isn't part of the reason
for that due to the
housing shortage
we have so
when making housing more affordable by
having their property taxes be lower
help
those businesses find more people to
work in those jobs
well
bia has long been involved in uh
workforce housing issues i've appeared
before this committee this session on
workforce housing bills
um and certainly we're concerned about
the
availability and affordability of
housing
i believe it's a bit of a stretch
to suggest that an individual who isn't
able to afford a house now would somehow
be able to afford it if this legislation
passed and i would add that there are
also a lot of other factors
that are making it difficult for
employers to find work it's not just
housing
thank you representatives
thank you mr chair thank you mr for
zouay for taking my question
um
something caught my attention in your
statement you said
education
and workforce
and isn't that
don't you think that having good
workforce providing all the
infrastructure
in terms of education roads and fire is
critical for a driving community in that
case you know the
taxes
or the revenue for the
municipalities and it benefits both
businesses as well as the residential
communities
just by cutting taxes we are not going
yeah or shifting burden from one to
other we are not going to enhance the
growth of the community
yeah thank you for the question um i'd
like to make two points one we're not
talking about cutting taxes here we're
talking about shifting the burden to uh
employers in your community
which i'm opposed to i want to emphasize
the importance of education and
especially our public education system
which is where most of our
employees and future employees come from
and the importance
of making sure that those in educational
institutions are funded appropriately
which most businesses around the state
at least the ones i work with are more
than happy to do because they recognize
how critical it is
yes representative
uh thank you mr chair and and thank you
mr duvet for
taking uh my question
um
based on on your knowledge of the
business obviously you've been in for
the bia for a very very long time it
seems like a long time
i first met you in your office and had a
conversation with you about business
taxes but um
the
my question is do you feel that
um smaller business or maybe even larger
businesses
might pick up from a community that puts
us in
and go next door to a community that may
not i know that's a big burden for them
to pick up and move but do you think
that something like that could possibly
happen and potentially shift the burden
back to residents because now it becomes
90 well i want to be honest with you the
likelihood of a company like uh fidelity
was mentioned in anheuser-busch and um
the uh nuclear power plant
uh the likelihood or hospitals the
likelihood of those businesses picking
up and moving is is not likely at all i
do think there's a potential for
mischief with smaller
uh companies you're you're
calling mom and pop shops that may be
unfair but but you all know what i'm
talking about smaller smaller businesses
where it's quite easy to to pick up and
move
to another community
i think there is some potential for that
and i think with even with the larger
companies that aren't likely to move
this may impact other decisions that
they're making in terms of hiring so
i
i think there's i think a proposal like
this
has um we've all heard about unintended
consequences and i think there could be
a lot of mischief that would come from a
bill like this becoming law
thank you
yes representative
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you mentioned
unintended consequences
in the um prime sponsor he focused a lot
on the seabrook nuclear power nuclear
station
do you think that if this were to become
law in some communities who had
non-residential property that was a
power generator
that now would have to be paying more in
property taxes that that might result in
higher energy costs for business which i
know is a big consideration in new
hampshire many businesses
cite high energy costs
um in
you know as a problem for their business
do you so do you think this bill would
even
raise the cost for businesses even
further
i think it has potential for raising
electricity costs for everybody
residential
individuals and other businesses
electricity rates as i'm sure you're
aware established by the puc and when a
rate request is requested or when a rate
request is made
the utility has to provide justification
for for the rate uh increase and i
guarantee you that if their uh taxes are
going up significantly that is something
that they would use as is part of a
justification thank you
yes representative
thank you mr chair and uh thank you mr
gervais taking my question i think
hopefully this is an easy one
does the bia have statistics on how many
uh businesses
are also or how many business owners
actually live in the communities for
which they have their businesses uh and
i don't need the answer now i'm just
curious because the sponsor said that a
lot of those people but you know is that
true i know it's not in northampton that
is not the case in northampton
uh we don't have those statistics and
i'm not
it would it would take an exhaustive
study to come up with them but i think
you raised a good point
that
just because you run a business in the
community
regardless of whether it's a large
business or a small business it doesn't
necessarily mean you live there but even
if you did
he made the point about
um
his the businesses he talked to being
supportive of this because they saw the
potential for their their home property
tax to go down even if their business
property tax went up but we're kind of
talking about two different things the
home property tax is a personal expense
that we all pay the business property
tax is a business expense which is
deductible
um as a part of your your business
return the business is paying for it the
individual isn't
hey uh the
remote
feedback on this particular bill is two
people support it and five people oppose
it
so thank you am i all done thank you mr
chair thank you members of the committee
appreciate it that closes the
hearing on hb 1365
and we're gonna we're gonna take a ten
minute recess
and
representative power could you join me
over here with representative tripp and
asellus
thanks
educational
thank you
is
yes
um
[Music]
is
nice
i'm sure you do a good enough job on
that
there's a wide spectrum of understanding
that's for sure yes there is you know
all right
so julie
i was just gonna say
if i have one it'll be more than that
i was watching
well it depends if you opened it at
night for dinner
i'm just spinning it everywhere
this is
i'll
email you
when you catch people's eye
rosemary's eye you go like this
[Music]
yeah that's a good idea i had that on my
truck
yeah when i if i'm
if someone's coming behind me
and they they come like this like in
front of john
my right butt cheek
vibrates and if they're coming from that
side my left butt cheek vibrates
and the next one that's right
now you're clear how to deal with your
husband during this testimony what's
that you're clear about how to deal with
your husband yeah i'm just doing it the
regular way
i mean
for the sake of time
should i say i'm just saying about where
you're gonna go and what you're gonna
say and all that stuff
i think so yeah that's what we talked
about last night or the day before
all right let's get started
okay we're gonna uh
uh conclude my recess here with uh
starting
to hear the next bill of 1390
which is the relative to the adoption of
school district budget caps
and representatives
you're going to introduce the bill for
us yes
okay
thank you mr chair and fellow committee
members as a prime sponsor i appreciate
the opportunity to introduce to you
today house bill 1393
relative to the adoption of school
district budget caps
for the record i am representative diane
power i represent the towns of brookline
and mason in hillsborough county
district 26.
this bill establishes the requirements
and the procedure for the adoption of
school district budget caps
this bill is a constituent request
year after year new hampshire taxpayers
are faced with ever increasing school
district budgets and spending
despite continued declining student
enrollments
this bill is enabling legislation that
provides a mechanism for taxpayers of a
local school district to address the
unsustainable trend and to bring
spending
to reasonable levels
as enabling legislation the legislative
body
at a school district meeting may adopt
the school district budget cap by a
three-fifth super-majority vote
the warren article to adopt this budget
cap specifies a gross cost per student
as well as an annual inflation
adjustment factor
the inflation inflation adjustment
factor can be
a fixed percentage or an index from the
united states bureau of labor statistics
such as the consumer price index for all
urban consumers
or
for example the
employment cost index annually the
school
district budget cap is determined
by multiplying the gross dollar amount
per student
by the student enrollment which is
defined as a school district average
daily membership as of the previous
october first
this figure is then multiplied by the
annual
inflation adjustment factor to yield the
budget cap for that fiscal year
notably the budget cap will tend to
decrease with lower student enrollments
and increase with higher student
enrollments
at the annual meeting the total proposed
spending of all warrant articles
presented by the governing body or the
budget committee is limited by this
budget cap
and the legislative body can increase or
decrease appropriations in warren
articles using the normal procedures
however when an appropriation will
exceed the budget cap approval to
override the budget cap
will require a three-fifth
super-majority vote
a ballot vote
requiring this supermajority to override
the budget cap ensures that any spending
that exceeds the budget cap is in fact
warranted and is overwhelmingly
supported by the legislative body
additionally this bill stipulates that
in the case of warrant articles
proposing bonds notes or other
multi-year expenditures
only the first year estimated costs
shall be used in calculating
appropriations for the purpose of
overriding the budget cap
this bill also outlines the procedures
for overriding the budget cap in a
school district that has adopted the
official
ballot
the official ballot form of meeting
and lastly this bill also specifies the
procedure for overriding the budget cap
when the sau alternative budget
procedure under rsa 194
c colon 9a has been adopted in
conclusion
this bill specifies a budget cap based
on a gross dollar amount per student an
inflation factor and the average daily
membership
this bill establishes a three-fifth
super majority to override the budget
cap and
this bill provides flexibility in
spending while at the same time
maintaining fiscal responsibility to
taxpayers
by scaling the budget
cap upwards or downward
downwards with the changing student
population thank you mr chair that
concludes my introduction
okay thank you
i was speaking with representative power
last night
we talked about the fact that her
husband was going to be doing some
testifying today
on a bill that she
has
just introduced and
so
mr power if you can i get you to stand
up and uh
you're not mr power
well not yet uh i just want to make sure
that
that it's identified who he is and that
uh
that this is a disclosure of that
and want to make sure that's all uh
understood
anybody on the committee have any
questions about that
[Music]
thank you committee members
i'm the vice president of the school
district governance association and my
name is eric power from brookline
and what i want to talk about today was
about this bill
the school district governance
association or sdga for short is made up
of current and former school board and
budget committee members from across the
state of new hampshire
it's a whole volunteer organization
myself i am a former
school board member in the hollis
brookline cooperative school district
served there for three years
sdga has
been was founded to promote educational
excellence prudence in budgeting and
responsible governance in school
districts
the sdga membership reports that school
budgets are increasing faster than
inflation across the state
despite declining student enrollments
i actually was the chair of a budcom
study committee in the town of brookline
two years ago where we looked at school
districts and towns and i'll talk about
school districts that's the focus here
we looked at 26 peer school districts to
brookline
and we looked at what they were doing in
terms of budgets what was happening and
so we normalized it so we looked at
essentially took out inflation and took
out
the changes in population
and we found that 21 of the 27 school
districts in this sample
had per student costs exceeding
inflation over that four year period
so it's definitely a problem
the other example i think there's a
handout here i wanted to point to
example student enrollment and
appropriations history this is actually
from the hollis brookline cooperative
school district the blue bars are
showing the student enrollment you can
see that it peaked in in fy 10 and was
going down since that time
the red line on there is actually
showing the actual appropriations that
has been done for the the co-op school
district
and we'll talk a little bit in a second
but the green line is if you had adopted
this school budget district this school
budget dis school district budget cap
with the cpiu as your
uh inflation index what the cap would
have done
just so you know is in color we're in
black and white up here
okay
the bottom line that you see is the is
the green line
the top line that's going up almost off
the chart is the red line so that's
that's the actual appropriations you see
a label on it so you can follow it thank
you for letting me know that
so this is hypothetical that if you had
adopted this we went back in time and
said in 2006 what fyo 6 if we had
adopted this is what would have happened
so you can see despite the declining
enrollment the budget was allowed to go
up it just wasn't allowed to go up quite
as fast this is an example how you would
apply the school district budget cap
so
this the graph the other graph there
shows the per student cost the gross
cost per student
and the taller graph is the actual and
the inflation-adjusted one if it had
stayed
and adjusted with inflation is the is
the lower graph
so that that kind of shows you here that
the uh the increase over this time
period was 80 almost 88 percent
for the actual first gross
the gross cost per student
and the cpiu adjusted was only up 43 so
it was up more than double the rate
the budget cap provides a reasonable
approach to budgeting
the budget clap cap as you've heard
includes a dollar figure for gross cost
per student and an inflation factor
which can be a fixed percentage or u.s
government index chosen by the
legislative body
the budget cap is the gross cost per
student times the number of students
times the inflation factor calculated
every year
and it basically adjusts spending based
on the number of students and what's
happening with inflation
small adjustments
are going to be generally made over time
because populations don't change rapidly
and if an urgent need to exceed the
budget cap arises it can be approved
with super majority support
this is just like we do with
multi-million dollar bonds that's a
significant financial commitment
requiring a three-fifth super majority
approval exceeding the budget cap
needs the same level of approval
as enabling legislation voters of each
school district can propose or adopt the
school district budget cap it's not
forced on anyone it's not a mandate
school districts can decide for
themselves if it's if it's appropriate
for them
school appropriation trajectories are
unsustainable from the data i've shown
you
many including
those in the sdga recognize that
taxpayers do not have the unlimited
unlimited ability to pay property taxes
this provides a mechanism that can be
adopted by a supermajority of school
district voters to help shape the
planning and budgeting process
thank you for your support of new
hampshire citizens excellence in
education and please recommend ought to
pass out a committee on this bill thank
you thank you i have a
comment or a question for you
when you're looking at cost per student
i know you're talking about gross cost
per student i want to break that down a
little bit
so when
let's use hollis brookline
when you're looking at the cost per
student you're looking at all the
variable costs are you adding in the
fixed costs for the the mortgage for the
building and and so forth uh where's
where do those costs reside
well the gross cost per student it's on
the slide this slide here with the bar
graph kind of by itself
it's the total appropriations for the
school district so it's fixed variable
everything
divided by
the number of students that you have
thank you that answers it thank you
yes
uh thank you mr chair that was actually
kind of part of my question to
um i understand how you calculated the
cost per student but when you're saying
that enrollment goes down
um the
the cost per student automatically is
going to kind of rise a little bit
because of those fixed costs is is is
that part of this calculation i i don't
doubt any of your numbers this looks
great and i appreciate that but
my question to you is
fixed costs will remain the same
you know building costs fuel costs etc
and if you have less students you spread
that out amongst those less students
that cost per is going to go up
automatically
i i know you're looking at the variable
cost but do you have a way of figuring
that in because cpi does not always
affect um
energy costs and things like that so
that's just my question to you
well depending on whatever index you
pick
employment costs index cpiu they will
they all take into account energy i hear
your point about fixed costs yes fixed
costs will
go up and that's part of what the
legislative body has to take into
account when they set the per cost
student that they want to set for this
adopting this warrant article
i think a wise legislative body would
probably pick something that's a little
higher just to take that into account
and they would you know they would do
that
if there was a dramatic drop in students
there's gonna have to be some tough
choices made and right now the tough
choices in generally aren't being made
the staffing does not go down
proportionally
and that's where you would have to make
some of the choices there so
the whole idea of a budget cap is not
just to rubber stamp what's being asked
for by the administration
or even the school board it's for to
force tough choices to be made in times
when there's to keep budgets from
getting out of control as they have been
represented
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
uh my question
it's my question is also based on
similar
um
how would the fixed costs and school
infrastructures and personnel
can be so agile as you are predicting
you know proposed or
actual
and it's always lagging behind i did
serve on the school board in our uh
city and
and we were building two high schools so
that you know understand that
agility is lagging behind and this
won't this limit
the local governing body
to do the best for
the education of the current population
because the drop
by the time the population school
population drops and you catch up with
the budget
you know the ebb and flow of that
you can't time it just like the stock
market
so how would you account for that
well it's a choice of the legislative
body and with how they choose their
number and if you look at any school
district budget
the lion's share of the budget and i
would say some place in the neighborhood
of 70 to 80 percent
is based on variable cost and there was
probably something in the order of 20
at best
for fixed costs
so yes the fixed costs are going to
still be there but there are there are a
minority of what's in there so i think
choosing the number that you use for per
student co gross per student cost
is a key to getting the super majority
support of the legislative body to take
that into account
it's not the the goal of the bill to
tell people how to make their priorities
among different types of spending but it
gives them a tool in order to
propose this legislation and adopt this
policy locally
thank you mr chair uh follow-up
you know spending spending cap i get it
but education of the future generation
is also an investment unless we invest
today we don't reap the benefit tomorrow
so that investment when you look at the
school funding as investment how would
your approach change or would it change
the school district budget cap is
decided by the legislative body of a
school district they have to decide for
their school where how much they want to
invest in at what level they can sustain
as i mentioned taxpayers don't have the
unlimited ability to pace and there's
some limit to what they can pay i do
agree that the education is the future
that's why i served on the school board
it's important to me but it's also
important to be able to do that in a
fiscally responsible way and i think
that that can be done the spending cap
provides that mechanism to help make
that bakes it into the budgeting process
so that you're making more intelligent
decisions earlier on so that you adhere
to the budget cap and if the case is
that you really need to make those
investments and you can get a super
majority of the voters to buy into that
this this bill lets you do that
and so i think it's flexible in that way
it helps put
it helps put some limits though on
spending that the legislative body
believes is right for that community in
that school district thank you
representative tripp
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question and i'll try and lean
over this way
uh
i'm gonna assume that uh fixed costs are
uh set and
you the school board really doesn't have
a lot of
control over them because it's something
that happened in the past
but
i'm interested in variable costs could
you give me some examples of what
variable costs in the school are
variable costs will be associated with
um you know all the people cost so how
much does how much do you pay your
teachers your administrators your sau
office
um how many students do you have in
special education what are their
services
um
you know
inflation is some of those costs it's
it's a it's it's what's in the most part
of the budget is the people cost the
amount that's spent on buildings
heating and those sorts of things tends
to be lower and the inflation index will
take care of some of those to some
extent
but that's why i mentioned 75 80 percent
of of school district budgets are
variable because they function as a
function of the number of students which
should be a function of the number you
know that should that should affect how
many teachers
administrators
paras support staff
and sau office that you have and that
those decisions have to be made
appropriately you can't keep the same
number of teachers when your your school
population has gone down 15 percent
uh yes i have a philip uh
one of the things that uh
as you said drives the uh
the variable cost is the
the
personnel cost
are the
personnel costs in your estimate
estimation uh going down with the
decrease in
students
the personnel costs are the main reason
why the school budgets have gone up and
up because
the
the class sizes have gone down
and there hasn't been a scaling of the
number of teachers the number of
administrators
appropriately and a lot of school
districts across the new hampshire if
you look at why in that budcom study
when we were looking at what was
happening with school budgets
you know 78 of them had
costs that were exceeding inflation and
these are recent numbers
and so those are all being driven by
personnel costs they're not being driven
by
fixed costs
yes thank you for taking my question
having served on the school board
locally where i live in litchfield
i realize that all students are not the
same
and
a budget can get blown out of the water
with a
multiple handicapped person
and and the cost for one
child moving into the
school district and requiring
buku services can can really hurt
immensely above and beyond what the per
pupil cost is i'm wondering how
this
plan
would accommodate that sort of thing
right so
my background is that i'm an engineer
and i i i'm going to talk a little about
statistics and such but there's the
thing there's a concept called the law
of large numbers
a lot of large numbers says you tend to
reach an average the more that you have
of something
so when you have a large group of
students
you are going to have
you're going to have a an average that's
going to be spread out over a larger
group and larger group you are going to
have the occasional outlier
there with the special education
students
and you will have to deal with that and
that would be a case in which the school
board would have to go to the community
to the school district and ask for a
super majority override to get the funds
to take care of that student if they
were that astronomical
so that that that's that would be the
mechanism there but i i believe if you
have a school district of any
large size there's always going to be a
few students that are present so they're
always going to be there
and that's going to be taken into
account when you set your
gross cost per student when you pass the
warrant article so that's how i would do
it and if you had the special case come
along that would have to be something
that you would have to bring to the
legislative body and show that that's
needed and i'm sure if that was the case
i believe that a super majority would
support that to support the students in
their community
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question my question is about
roman 4 parent a
and why you only consider the first
year's payment of a bond with the
article and the example i will give you
is the town of northampton has a bond
where year two
and thereafter
is double what year one is and therefore
year one of the bond is the only one i'm
asking is is only year one of the bond
counting towards the cap
and does that create a problem for the
school district if the warrant article
is approved
so if this if the school district adopts
this enabling legislation they're going
to need to plan
for that they can't just look at that
year's cost sure they'll get a break on
the interest-only payments on the bond
the first year
and this is a
thing i complain about at every school
district meeting where they say the tax
impact is going to be a nickel
per thousand
but they're telling about the first year
because the next year it might be 15
cents per thousand because it has
interest in principle not just interest
so
you would they have to the school board
and the budget committee if there is one
would have to plan for that
not in the year that it happened
necessarily but would have to know that
they have to have that head room in
their budget when they're putting forth
a
a bond they have to know that they might
get by the first year but they have to
look ahead a year to see what it's going
to do to their budget in the following
years so it puts a little more
makes them think about the budget in
more of a long-term perspective which i
think is too much lacking
today to think about how a bond would
impact them because like it or not the
taxpayers are still going to pay it
it's they get a break the first year but
the second year is when it in in
subsequent years is where it kicks in
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh you made a comment
that um
one of the needs for this bill is that
staffing is not going down
proportionally to a decrease in student
enrollment
but
um is that presuming that
students leave like if let's say a
hundred students are leaving a district
that they're all coming from let's say
four classrooms so you can lay off four
teachers
i mean
you can have in my district
we've seen you know several hundred
students leave but it's random
throughout the district they're not it
wouldn't it might decrease class size by
maybe two but it's certainly not enough
to lay off a teacher so i was wondering
how that proportionality
that logic works in this bill
well the bill
you know you would have to look at
what's happening across each grade and
so i agree when you have a small number
of students per grade disappear that's
not going to be a big effect but when
you start having
you know 12 13 15 of students there is
going to be a point at which you don't
need a teacher you don't need two
teachers
so it's not going to be i call an
engineering quantitization so you you
know you don't quantize to lose a
teacher until you've lost a certain
minimum number of students
so you would have to take that into
account when you're looking at
the the
staffing levels you know in a school of
a significant size so you would once
once the students drop below a certain
level you're going to have to reduce
cost
so
you know in our school district we keep
adding principals and administrators our
sau has doubled
that isn't going in the right direction
with a declining population so it's not
just teachers but it's also
administrators why do we need more
administrators with less students
so that these are all things that are
personnel costs that have to be worked
out
um but at some point when you lose
enough students you're going to have to
reduce staff
no i agree that's why election of school
board members is important because they
will drive the budget but when we
getting getting to those the staffing
isn't a lot of that cost driven by the
labor market
especially um
you know if let's say a budget cap holds
a average salary let's say at 35 000
um
but neighboring districts are paying 40
but the budget cup doesn't allow an
increase in salary to be competitive
i'm just saying i think a lot of the
labor costs aren't they driven by the
labor market and districts need to be
able to participate in that labor market
i'm not sure i understand what the
question is there but you know when the
school district decides to do a budget
cap they they have to know the pluses
and minuses of it and
you know if there's a budget cap and
they're going in to negotiate with a
teacher's union or going in to do a
support support staff
collective bargaining agreement they're
going to go in there with the backing of
this school district budget cap and
they're going to say look we can only
pay this much because of this budget cap
otherwise we're going to have to try to
get a super majority approval to get
your collective bargaining agreement
passed and that's a decision that's
going to be part of the union
negotiations it's going to cause some
challenges and that's you know that's
what's you're going to be looking for
some fiscal responsibility
maybe some teachers will
decide that the raises aren't big enough
in hollis brookline for example and
they're going to go work at souhegan or
they'll go work in nashua where the pay
is better
that's that's definitely a risk but
that's something that the school
district
voters decide on what they're at the
level of which they're willing to
support
and it's like something you decide when
you're going out to buy goods and
services if
if a stake costs
five dollars each you might go buy four
of them but if a stake is ten dollars
each you might not buy
that many you might get less
it's a little bit of an analogy but you
might not be able to afford quite as
many teachers and that's where you'll
have to look at maybe increasing
your your class sizes to make up for it
maybe you can keep up with the labor
market but you just can't have as many
teachers and that might be that's a
that's a decision that the school board
has to make
okay just one more question mr chair
sorry okay thank you um one other note i
want to make is in the years uh the
fiscal year 11 around 11
um
and then we saw a big jump after that
that was caused when the state reneged
on its commitment to contribute to the
state retirement plan and so that burden
fell on local
districts and municipalities to cover
that that difference
how would this
adjust for things like that might might
happen in the future where there is a
downshifting of costs that is of
no we you know it has nothing to do with
local school spending it's just now they
have to pay for things like the
retirement system that was a commitment
of somebody else
well it kind of gets back to the last
answer that you know if there's cost
that you can't control and i agree the
new hampshire retirement system seems to
be an unsustainable trajectory i don't
like it myself
but that's what we're inheriting
hopefully the legislature will work on
fixing it but if if those costs get so
high that you're going to have to be
forced to make some decisions in
reducing staffing you can't afford
your school district budget cap and
frankly the taxpayers don't have the
unlimited ability to pay you're going to
have to start having less teachers
in order to stay competitive and absorb
these so called
out of you know costs you can't control
so i think that that's that's what this
does this forces some tough decisions
potentially if the budgets
um rise unreasonably
thank you
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking another question for me i'm
hoping you can finish this sequence for
me
the the school board proposes a budget
under the cap it's assuming this is
approved and the budget committee
approves the same budget
under the cap all good
deliberative session
in an sb2 town comes in
raises
the
budget
over the cap
by warren article whatever the whatever
the mechanism was it's higher than the
cap
as i read roman 3
the proposed appropriation is opposed is
over the cap
but that appropriation also has to go to
the ballot because
something has to go to the ballot
what happens
so ask i have a i have experience with
both sp2 and traditional because our
brookline school district is traditional
our sp our brooklyn town is sb2 and
their co-op is traditional so what
happens at a deliberative session is
they're setting up the ballot just as
you said representative
so when the ballot is tallied they're
going to go in order just like you would
do at a meeting the ordering of the
ballot makes a difference and so once
you reach that article that pushes you
over the budget cap if there is one
whatever article it will it is
will
require a three-fifth super majority of
those voting
to pass that article
and any other articles afterwards that
would also uh break the cap
in the case of a
if the operating budget is the one doing
that which i anticipate was another one
of your questions
you'll have you will you have a proposed
budget i'm not sure everybody here
understands sp2 you have a proposed
budget and a default budget if the
proposed budget if you get a majority
you're not going to get the proposed
budget you're going to get the budget
that
if it's over 50 but less than 60 percent
you're going to get the budget that's
adjusted to meet the tax
cap if it's
actual yes and if you get below 50
percent
you are going to get the default budget
if that default budget is also over the
cap
that will be truncated to be compliant
with the cap
and that's how that would work
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i just wondered if
you could give me the source of your
numbers about the decline in student
population from 12 13 15 is that a local
number or
is it can you can i find it on google
somewhere
what are you asking for you keep talking
about the decline in student enrollment
as being 13 15 percent and i just want
to cite i want to know where you got
that number well you can look at the
department of education has
statistics on that you can see statewide
we've been seeing that
i gave you some data for the hollis
brookline co-op here you can see the
numbers there and
you know i also had some recent numbers
from the budcom
study committee that was sponsored by
the select board of brookline
that was not for that length of time
though that was a shorter window but the
department of education if you look at
any school district and i believe you
also might have received some testimony
from timberlane that also showed another
example of a declining enrollment it's
the the the what we're experiencing here
in new hampshire is that there's just is
not as many students being born to new
hampshire residents for whatever reason
and that's translating to a lower
um
student population and that's what we're
experiencing now okay thank you
hey uh
i had one question
sometimes schools
just by
by
bad luck i guess
end up
with some really profoundly handicapped
children
and they can't say
we can't afford you they have to
attempt to educate them
and in some some of those cases
their
students are outplaced
to very expensive
institutions
i'm aware of
some that are in excess of 200 000 a
year
and so
when a school
gets
i hit with those types of costs
how would this plan
make an adjustment for that so that
if we're going to spend
500 000 on these three students
does that mean the rest of the students
are going to get
get burned by
by being averaged in and saying we have
to drop your costs down because we're
looking at the collective costs how do
you how do you
deal with something like that
well it depends on the size of your
school district so this is a decision
for the local legislative body if you
have a large school district you can
tend to absorb those costs and spread
them out over the larger population in a
small school district you may or may not
want the school district budget cap it
might not make sense for you in light of
that potential situation
again it's sort of the law of large
numbers you
if you see these things periodically and
i think most large school districts have
a few students in this category they're
going to be
they're going to be kind of baked into
the
number that you're using the gross cost
per student
and
the other case as i mentioned earlier
you can go to the legislative body and
make your case that we have these
extreme costs
do you want this to affect all the other
students or will you do a super majority
override to support this for the four
years six years
whatever the number of years that
student tax cap was agreed to exceeded
for whatever reason
does that have to be
re-energized or re-passed every year or
is it
become like a default budget that you
know you
we we had to raise the cap
four million dollars for whatever
you start the next year four million
dollars higher are you are you back down
to where you were as like a zero-based
budget
it's more along a zero-based budget
but it does have the inflation factor so
if you look at this graph here that
the colored graph that had the two lines
on it you can see
both lines are going up
very rapidly because that's using the
most recent inflation statistic of cpiu
which
under the
last year was seven and a half percent
hate to say it but that's where we're at
so this takes that into account
and so you you use the same gross
student per cost but it gets it it's
adjusted by either the fixed percentage
compounded over time or by the
uh labor statistics metric that you've
chosen
so it makes you so if you had a student
you potentially may need to
uh
do an override for a few years until it
comes in line with the budget
so that yeah that that would be the case
in that um
extreme
unfortunate financial situation
yes thank you again for
i would like to follow up on what the
chairman said
i think there would be a tendency if a
let's say we had a smaller school
district
and
a new student moved into town that was
profoundly
multiply handicapped
everyone in town would know that this
person moved into town
if there was an override
to accommodate this one student
don't you think that
there would be
animosity in the town
possibly toward the student
my
my suggestion
and i'm not against the the concept of
this
but you you need to somehow accommodate
special education
into this because if you don't and i i
know it's it's not
beyond the realm of possibility that one
student could be 250 000
and i know that to be a fact because
they outplace these students
and if it takes a a super majority to
accommodate that
there's going to be a lot of bad
feelings in town toward that situation
and that's my question i
is there any way that you can
accommodate that
situation
i would have to think about that a
little bit more if that would be
something there would make the law more
complicated
and
you know
i was on the school board i had seen
some of these two hundred thousand
dollar plus placements i didn't know who
they were
but i saw you know this with there was
an id number with the student
essentially so that's all i knew that
they existed so i am from i know they do
exist and i'm familiar with that
but the in in a school budget that we
have of
26 million dollars 27 million dollars
that's something that you can adjust if
you have a small school district
maybe this budget cap isn't isn't
something that you want to choose is
enabling legislation it's not one size
fits all it makes sense for some
communities
doesn't make sense for others i would
argue that the smallest communities
probably wouldn't want that because of
this situation i think in a large
you know school district like the hollis
brooklyn co-op i think you would see
that that would not
overly upset the apple cart in terms of
the finances i think it would be
absorbed so
this is just an option for school
districts the school district doesn't
have to adopt it and i would probably
advise them on against it on a small
school district for these reasons
any other questions yes
representative majipudi
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question um you um keep referring uh
to the numbers game right the larger the
number better
of adjusting and agility in terms of per
student spending and
fluctuations
um
nashua is the second largest city in the
state and when i was on the school board
it was thirteen thousand hundred 682
students that we were responsible for
and
what would you consider for what was the
number first
towns that is small or medium or large
what is the numbers game that
you're
talking about in this
you know in terms of number of students
i would say
you know ones that are on the ballpark
of maybe let 500 students in the school
district or less i would say would be on
the small side
you know that the the factor of what's
being represented by representative
cells here
that's where that might come into play
but in a large school district where you
have
you know thousands of students you know
i know nashua is large manchester
um the larger school districts don't
would be able to absorb those outliers
more than
a small school district so i think it's
up to the legislative body
to determine if it's right for their
community giving school districts an
option
is is what
i think is important here
and i didn't mention but if they adopted
this and they saw that it was backfiring
they could rescind it as well similarly
like you can rescind other things you
rescinded by a super majority vote you
adopt by a super majority vote so if it
didn't work for them they're not stuck
in it forever if it really boxes them in
and they just don't see a way out
they could they could unadopt the
budget cap
okay
this is a complex issue we could be here
all night
let me introduce a couple additional
speakers that want to contribute here to
the discussion thank you mr power for
your testimony
barrett christina
from the new hampshire school boards
association
feel free to use the sanitizer
thank you very much chairman dolan thank
you members of the committee my name is
barry christine i'm the executive
director of the new hampshire school
boards association um we're opposed to
1393. i'm not going to spend a lot of
time on the concerns
and questions that the school boards
association had with uh with the bill i
think have been brought up sufficiently
um by members of the committee there are
a couple things that i
would like to just um you know get the
committee to to to recognize
i haven't been in front of this
committee i don't know if i've been in
this front of this committee this
session um i'm up here from time to time
my understanding is many of you have
experience on local government local
school boards or select boards so when
you're putting together your budget what
are you trying to do you've got
competing interests don't you you're
trying to provide from a school context
you're doing trying to provide the best
possible education that you can for what
the taxpayers are are able to tolerate
and able to bear
school board members are not just
handing out money and
and and putting you know
gold you know toilet seats on things and
and the latest greatest football fields
and
the latest greatest facilities we're
trying to manage our obligations to
educate
children
with what the taxpayers can specifically
pay
i would take some issue with some of the
comments
that about fixed costs and and static
costs
for those of you that have been on local
government and you're going through your
line items during budget season
where are your fixed costs if your
employees are under a collective
bargaining agreement you can't change
that
still costs the same to heat the
building gasoline is a lot more
expensive today than we probably
budgeted we meaning school districts
probably budgeted a year and a half ago
when we were putting together our
budgets um also the the on page line uh
page one line nine of the bill it talks
about
um uh a plus an amount for an annual
increase in inflation i think we're all
hoping that inflation may
decrease at some point over the next
couple of years so we're not spending
ten dollars on a steak we can spend
seven dollars on a steak um because i
like steak too and i'm being priced out
of it now and then
um you know the other aspects to um that
i just sort of wanted to bring up
generally um you know
about the
the the the declining in enrollment
representative gilman i believe it was
you that asked about declining
enrollment um
off the top of my head the numbers are
on the department of education website i
believe statewide we're down about 30 to
35 000 students over the last 20 years
enrolled in in public schools in new
hampshire i think we topped out around
the year 2000 we had about 200 000 still
students enrolled and representative i
see sort of nodding along i believe
we're down to about 165 000 students
i will say over the last 20 years the
new hampshire legislature has
downshifted cost after cost after cost
after cost on on local school districts
the retirement costs have been brought
up those go up every year we've had some
questions about um special education
costs the state has underfunded special
education ed education aid to the tune
of about seven million dollars statewide
every year um and just running some of
the the quick numbers let's say we had a
student a school district of a thousand
students and that's k through 12. so 13
grade levels that comes out to 76
students per grade level
if we lost 15 percent of our students
over the course of let's say 10 or 15
years
that's 850 students divided by 13 years
65 students per class per grade level
excuse me
some of these are also local decisions
the minimum standards for public
education department of education rule
306 state that the maximum number of
students you can have in an elementary
school classroom is 25.
some communities through school board
work and through the expectations of
parents and and and mothers and fathers
want that to be lower they want that to
be 18 students um you know in an
elementary school maybe even lower for a
kindergarten class so those are local
values that are adopted by local school
boards and then reflective in the budget
in conclusion i'll say that there are
already three mechanisms in law by which
voters have the opportunity to limit
school district budgets the first is rsa
32 colon 5-c as in cat that's a local
tax cap this bill is a local budget cap
the preceding provision in rsa 32 coin 5
would be a local tax cap i don't know
how many districts have adopted that
we know many of our cities have have tax
caps commune towns and school districts
i don't know how many have adopted that
statewide
the second is um sb2 many communities
have adopted sb2 over the last 25 years
in an attempt to go to the deliberative
session and have a discussion and
hopefully increase turnout you can make
motions from the floor about decreasing
you know your budget or increasing your
budget
and last it's always been in
my
personal opinion not necessarily a
position of nhsba that if the voters
want to increase or decrease a budget
they can come out to their annual
meeting and do that and convince their
neighbors if they make a motion to cut
the budget so we think there are
sufficient provisions already in law
that are are prudent and reasonable
fiscal constraints that school boards
may face
with the voters having complete say over
the adopted budget and then the larger
issue is some of the the costs that we
simply you know can't you know we have
to find a way to absorb because they're
obligations while still trying to
balance providing an education and
trying to provide a balance for what
taxpayers can actually afford so thank
you mr chair with that i'm happy to
answer any questions from the committee
thank you mr chair i didn't know you had
a
eye on your side
political vision
better thank you thank you for taking my
question you
you alluded to a lot of concerns that i
have in terms of this uh bill
how do you account does this take into
account the bubble that we saw
uh you know the population bubble when
there is a big uh influx in kindergarten
and you have to accommodate them to go
through for the next 12 years right
is a big uh challenge with this kind of
uh
it is thank you for the question
representative i didn't mean to
interrupt you um you know i'm looking at
um
page one i believe it's line seven where
it talks about the average daily
membership of the school district
currently our um well yes we've had
numbers of kids um not you know
declining enrollment over the last 20
years
because of covid our current enrollment
numbers
are
are not accurate if i think is the best
way to say it for example for the 2020
21 covet hit march of 12 of 2020
for the 2021 school district we saw a
significant drop in the number of
children enrolled in kindergarten why
because some of the schools were doing
it virtual why am i going to in
quote-unquote enroll my five-year-old in
a kindergarten program it might be a
half day kinder program when they're
going to be staring at a zoom i'll try
and get to my local library or find some
instructional videos on youtube so we
didn't we saw those you know those
numbers artificially declined we also
saw a number of students um
during the pandemic
quote unquote leave the public school
for maybe a private school that was open
but then they're coming back into the
public school now that our school
districts are back open so it was a
temporary
dip in rise in our in our enrollments at
least for the last two years so
um and you make again a good point um i
don't know
the kindergarten numbers but if a
district has a half day
kindergarten program right now and then
they move to a full day kindergarten
program right now i believe i don't
think they're getting state aid for that
so they may not factor into the um the
average daily membership that i had to
go back and check but still is a
fluctuation in our student numbers that
may not accurately reflect the number of
students that we're trying to educate
thank you next we're going to hear from
brian hawkins from the nea
thank you very much
welcome feel free to use the sanitizer
okay
thank you mr chairman uh members of the
committee for the record brian hawkins
uh you're representing nea new hampshire
we represent over 17 000 educators
across the state of new hampshire
um here here in uh opposition to to the
bill
um
i'll be very brief because i think the
between the questions that were raised
in the committee as well as mr
christina's testimony i think a lot of
our
we share
a lot of the same concerns um
what i would uh just emphasize and add
is that um
during some of the testimo
the first testimony we heard a lot about
you know what how do we deal with the uh
the things that come up and that and
that the answer to that was
we need you know you need to take that
into account when you're setting these
initial numbers that you're going to be
going by for potentially
in perpetuity
and
we heard a lot of the questions that i
think committee members asked about the
various things
that
can come up
and
how do you balance those competing
priorities it's through your annual
budget process that we have
and so we think that that is
a
an adequate
uh method by which we should continue to
operate by
uh another piece i just wanted to raise
is
the the initial number that um gets
approved uh when we're when we're
putting the question
to uh voters
if that initial dollar amount
is not adequate
um
if this is if this comes in because as i
read this it can come in by petition
and it is set at a number that is too
low
and it is approved
um
it is it is going to be very difficult
for the
for the school district
uh
to adapt for the students that it that
it has and so
um i i just wanted to add those
um pieces and and
um i'll conclude my testimony there and
happy to take any questions
any questions
yes representative
you mr chair i'll be very quick and um
in tr how
agile can school district be in terms of
their staff
and that's a huge cost of the school
budget and
can they be fired and hired
on a
uh how would that impact us education of
the students well i i think the the the
biggest impact
uh concern we would have is is is for
the students so if you have a couple of
students who end up the
the enrollment goes down you still have
to have the teacher you still have to
have the para educator you still have to
have
all of those
of things and so
um
i think the biggest concern
would be you know what what happens to
class sizes and the quality of education
that the students would have and um
that
can be
best determined by a majority of the
voters at their annual town meeting and
they're elected uh and their elected
officials who establish the budget
well thank you for your testimony i
appreciate you making yourself available
for this
hearing
and for everybody that's in the audience
that
came for
hb 1667 and this is kind of a dry topic
and it takes you all your concentration
to uh
to stay with it and have it make sense
to you so appreciate those of you who
did that and were able to uh
to listen and uh and absorb it we have
one more hearing
let me close the hearing
mr chair for this one online uh 44
support 108
opposed 44 support 108 pose
thank you
okay
our next hearing
and last hearing
is hb 1667
representative powell would you like to
introduce the bill
thank you mr chair and thank you fellow
committee members as the prime sponsor
i appreciate the opportunity to
introduce to you today house bill
relative to the standard and optional
veterans tax credits and the all
veterans tax credit
for the record i am representative diane
power i represent the towns of brookline
in mason in hillsborough county district
26.
this bill clarifies that veterans of the
united states armed forces who served in
any active duty status and those who
continue to serve
qualify for the veterans property tax
credits
this bill comes from a constituent who
brought to my attention an inconsistency
regarding veterans in current new
hampshire statute
the term veteran is clearly defined in
rsa 21 colon 50.
under current new hampshire law veteran
means any person who
served in the armed forces for more than
four years and continues to serve
or
a person who has been honorably
discharged or received an
uncharacterized discharge based on a
service connected injury illness or
disability
the issue that this bill addresses is
that the veterans tax credit statutes in
section 72
do not align with the definition of a
veteran under rsa 21 colon 50.
thus
armed force forces members who are in
fact veterans under new hampshire law
are not considered to be veterans which
is both
which is a significant discrepancy
as a result of this inconsistency
currently serving veterans do not
qualify for any of the veterans tax
credits
including the all veterans tax credit
which is incongruent with the section
title
the remedy that this bill provides is
simple and straightforward
this bill amends the language in the
standard and optional veterans tax
credit and the all veterans tax credit
to include those veterans still serving
consist consistent with the statutory
definition of veteran
additionally the current language in
these sections only counts title 10
training for active duty
title 10 is a
federally funded and federally
controlled status
however
since national guardsmen perform a
majority of their duties
in title 32 status
which is a state-controlled but
federally funded status
this bill removes title 10 from both
sections so that both title 10 and title
32 service qualifies for the 90-day
requirement
lastly
under the all veterans tax credit state
active duty is also included as
qualifying service in this bill
towards the 90 days since the status is
commonly used when guardsmen respond to
natural disasters emergencies and other
contingencies
which is one of the missions and
functions of the national guard
in conclusion
this bill clarifies that title 32 and
state active duty by national guardsmen
counts towards the 90-day requirement to
qualify for the veterans tax credits
and this bill also addresses the
inconsistencies between the term veteran
as defined in rsa 21 colon 50 which
includes currently serving members as
veterans in rsa 72
the veterans tax credit sections
which currently specifies that members
have to be separated in order to be
eligible for the tax credits
mr chair that concludes my bill
introduction i'm happy to answer any
questions if you allow any questions for
the representative yes representative
please
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um there's no fiscal note on this as has
been with all the others so
i'm not going to ask for that but
would you know
the amount of impact this will have on
each of the municipalities i i'm not
disagreeing that we should have
clarifying language
um consistency consistently but
my curiosity is especially once we put
in state active
duty and so on this could have a very
large impact on on the shift it's not
going to cost municipalities but the
shift of a burden of tax do you have
any idea as to what percentage this
could be because i assume all our
national guards may not be homeowners
but they
they could
um they could be okay thank you for the
question representative i do not have
any data or statistics to to answer your
question however we do know that less
than one percent
of the people in our country
serve in the armed forces therefore
i would say that
in total it would be you know less than
one percent in general
yes just a quick one um
is it isn't it true that i think new
hampshire
um
per population has a much higher
percentage of veterans we're we're very
fed veteran friendly um state which is
which is a good thing
um i'm not with the question was
do i know or do i agree or no would i
believe
no no neither would i i just wanted to
know if um
i guess yes
are you aware are you aware that was my
question i'm not we are i'm not
specifically aware but what i would say
is um you know it depends on the town
so therefore
i mean that would be that would take a
lot of
research to do and i would also add that
this
these veterans tax credits are enabling
so the municipality would have to
you know
adopt it locally and additionally
it's not automatic the service member
must apply
and they must
you know have the proper application and
all the proper documentation so it's not
an automatic given there's many steps
that that you know one would need to to
go through it's just not not automatic
to say well we have x percent
of
uniformed service members therefore it's
going to have this impact we do not know
until
um they apply
just a quick follow-up sir one more yes
um
it'll just be quick um
you said that it's enabling which which
i agree with but if it's already in
existence we would be adding more to the
existing group is that correct
that is that is correct that this bill
amends
legislation that's already on the books
thank you for taking my question um
when a person is is
in the service
when they re-enlist or they change
status
in many cases they get what's called a
dd-214
which
in a lot of cases
in
municipalities all you have to do is
present a dd 214 and you're considered a
veteran
even though i
my my
my theory is
that the impact of this law
is going to be minimized because a lot
of towns are not processing it correctly
by the law they're they're giving people
that are in the guard or the reserves
the benefit of the doubt and considering
them veterans
even though they aren't by law
would you agree with
that could you repeat the question
touche
um
i i just i just think that the impact of
this change
i agree with the change i don't have a
problem with that
but the the impact is going to be
lessened
because
a lot of towns aren't following the law
now
they're being more liberal
than the law
allows okay well thank you for the
question representative
towns should be following the law so
that's disappointing that they're being
um i guess loosey-goosey with it that's
that's improper
and um i would also ask that you perhaps
defer
and ask the question of um
someone who's going to provide testimony
who is
a retired
air force officer and also a squadron
commit had been a squadron commander and
is more versed in um
the the details and the ins and outs of
those forms that you refer to i know
that there are a number of forms it's
just not one so that individual can
speak better to
the question that you're posing okay i
was not in the military
yes
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
again can't look at everything in a silo
1375 that we have which changes
honorably
discharged to discharged with honor
always have to assume you can never
assume that that something is going to
happen let's say 1375 does not pass
we understood with 1375 that discharged
with honor and honorably discharged are
different things
i didn't know that i wasn't in the
military does your bill need to be
amended to say discharge with honor or
separated with honor
in order to capture
all of those people who might
benefit
from it does it make any sense because
we learned in 1375 there are people who
are not benefiting right now
could you thank you for the question
representative so you're you're
asking with regard to an amendment to
this bill
which line would you be would you be
referencing
mr chair yes thank you so again i'm
referring back and i apologize that
maybe i should have prefaced it 1375 was
introduced to us a while back to say
honorably discharged and discharged with
honor are two very different things
and therefore i wonder here where in
parent a you say or what with the
statute says was honorably discharged
and where it's honorably separated it
goes on to say that i think a few times
does that phrase also need to be changed
so that we capture
the full group of people that could
benefit from this
bill so i might refer you thank you for
the question representative so i might
refer you to
section 21 colon 50 that does define
veteran and it also goes on to
define an honorable discharge or the
uncharacterized discharge
based on a service connected injury
illness or disability that may be
encompassing
that
group of people that you're
referencing to put an amendment
to
yes
thank you and that's actually the
question because 1375
looks to amend 21.50
am i missing that
so house bill 1375 looks to amend 21 50
to change honorably discharged to
discharge without by the way i i think
this is a good idea i just want to make
sure that
we we're capturing all the right things
and it may just be an administrative
thing we may just have to
you know do that i just want to make
sure that we're not missing something
thank you representative for the
question um
my focus
i i i appreciate that the question and
my focus is on this bill that i'm prime
sponsoring and you know i
to be honest i have not reflected on the
previous bill
and to to for the purposes of this
hearing
to
um
to consider
how that bill if it were to be passed
how this bill here in front of us might
need to be amended so i can't
unfortunately can't answer that sitting
here right now i would need to take some
time to carefully analyze that and
reflect and consider
how that might be addressed
thank you
seeing no further
questions thank you representative power
representative
wheeler
wyler sorry
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee representative ken weiler
the veterans tax credit originated in
the civil war
that's why the standard deduction is
only 50
in the late 1860s that was a substantial
amount of money
substantial changes have been made to
this deduction especially the definition
of veteran
this bill tries to clear up some of the
confusion between sections and be more
inclusive
previous laws would only give deductions
to those who actually were in the
service in war times
all who volunteer for service are at
risk of being deployed at any time and
anywhere
reservists and national guards are at
people are at the same risk and should
be treated similarly
i'm a retired colonel with 30 years
combined service and active in reserves
yes officers are you note from the
language treated a little differently
when we leave a service we are
considered subject to recall
rather than being discharged
and please pass this bill to clear up
some inconsistencies i think it's a good
change and i think it's well needed uh
as far as the discharges
in my reading of that section
i think everything's covered but as you
point out
discharged with honor and just an
honorable discharger not quite the same
thing and i have a few friends that i've
in several different veterans
organizations and some would be like
they're in basic training vietnam comes
to an end
you're discharged
for honorable reasons or administrative
reasons i've even seen those so this
i couldn't believe the number of
different reasons for discharges that i
would hear from people but
when they
mailed in to try to get a veterans plate
sometimes that would be a confusion
through the years we've tried to
straighten this out by rewriting it but
if if you think it needs to be for
honorable reasons or something like that
then this would be a good time to put it
in but
i thought we had everything covered when
i first read this bill but
any that's that's why we come to a
committee so our collective ideas can
can come together and make sure we have
have it as good as we hoped it would be
and i i appreciate what representative
power has done because this has been
confused through the year it's like i
remember i was here when we first tried
to include
uh people from afghanistan and iraq wars
they weren't in here
there would be a bunch of people that
had been veterans and they'd go to get a
they'd be discharged from service and
they'd go to get things you're not
included
you know it's you got to wait till your
war has been over for a few years then
we stick it in the bill
if somebody gets around to it
but that's why you see so many different
uh wars that are listed in some of the
what what qualifies as a veteran so this
okay you walk up you're on active duty
you show
an active duty
id card that should be sufficient
so
um you know
hopefully we'll get this thing all
straightened out because
there are some confusions in the town as
was and one of the things listed in this
2150 was a national guard uh id
head down here ngb form 22 from the
national guard
under uh
2150 so i guess there is a there is an
intent to uh
include national guardsmen
and when they're the treatment for
veterans so
representative
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question uh
earlier uh
representative power was asked why there
isn't a fiscal note attached to this
since you're a finance guy
i imagine that you would know
whether it required a fiscal note or not
since it's a town only expense well
actually it's not a town only expense
it's just a town only uh
shift an expense
would it need a fiscal note
we have several different
uh notes on it fn is a fiscal note which
normally means it increases the state
budget then there's an a which means
that it requires an appropriation then
there's an l
which
if you increase the budget locally this
does not increase a budget
it shifts some money
but it doesn't have the same criteria as
f n or l f n l or a
well thank you that's my epiphany for
the day thank you
very good
appreciate it at least i know the answer
all right thank you thank you colonel
all right the next uh
input we're going to get from is eric
running out here
also a colonel
come on up
thank you honorable members of the
committee i'm up here now as
air force colonel eric power retired
i served in the air national guard and
the air force reserve for over 30 years
and
i was never active duty thank you
uh
just for those aren't aware
every year i honor graduates at our
hollis brookline high school that are
joining the military
so every year i do the statistic of how
many
americans are actually serving in the
military including national guard and
reserve
and that number has been going down and
down and down and right now we're at
about half a percent of americans are
actively serving
so that kind of gives you a little bit
of a metric of how much this would
impact to include the
currently serving members it's not going
to be more than half a percent
of new hampshire residents so that just
to say so there's when you see a young
person signing up today they are doing
an honorable thing because it's there's
not many of us serving anymore
the representative here talked about a
dd214 everybody thinks a dd214 is what
you get when you retire but you can get
it for a lot of reasons guardsmen and
reservists can get it after they do a
deployment so some towns may mistakenly
be using that and they shouldn't be
because the law is clear right now
without this bill
that you have to be separated in order
to get the
veterans tax credits
which i think is wrong i'm here to
support the bill
as i mentioned i was in the air i was in
the air national guard for my first 28
years in the air force
and
almost i think all of my time was done
in title 32 status
so
when i went to get the veterans tax
credit none of that time counted
because it's title 32 and the law says
title 10.
i only got it because of my last two
years in the air force reserve which is
a title 10 status i'd be glad to answer
any questions about titles if people
have questions about that
the other thing about
people think that veterans are retired
people that are on fixed incomes and
have don't have a lot of financial means
and certainly there are veterans in that
category
but an active duty member who's serving
if you've ever looked at military pay
compared to civilian pay
is a lot lower than what you get in the
civilian sector military pay is less so
to exclude currently serving veterans
is probably the wrong thing because
they're going to make more money when
they get out of the military they're
making a sacrifice when they're serving
in more than one way including
financially
so today
the
you know we have the so-called all
veterans tax credit i would rather it
should it's really more the some
veterans tax credit because we're
leaving out a lot of veterans especially
when you look at the conflict between
how we define it in 2150
and how we do it in rsa section 72.
the ngb form 22 should be counted and it
does count it recognizes it but when you
do guards duty unless you're doing
overseas war duty all that duties is
title 32
which i think is a good
uh piece another another bit
that i would bring forward is that in my
last job in the air force reserve i
serve with all services including the
coast guard
and uh the coast guard
actually serves in another title title
14. so you're actually taking care of
our coast guardsmen by deleting title 10
so you're letting title 32 title 14 and
title 10 all count to qualify as it
should
so i think that's an important fix in
the law
and you know
as you mentioned
officers that get out i can still be
recalled i'm in the retired reserve so
i had to wait until i was done my 30
years until i could actually apply for
the veterans tax credit and finally get
it just a couple of years ago finally
so i think we need to do the right thing
and take care of our
servicemen and women who are currently
serving have been in more than four
years and and passed this bill to take
care of all veterans in new hampshire
thank you very much
well thank you
you mentioned something that kind of
reminded me of something when i was
in service
back in 78
79 time frame
i had troops that were
on food stamps that's how that's how
poorly we were paying them
and
it was a real real crime to see that
going on
so thank you for your testimony okay uh
jim misho
we don't have jim misho here
all right so that's going to conclude
mr chairman was that 1978
yes
funny guy
lucky i didn't say it yeah
okay so uh
i want to
close the hearing
and i want to congratulate my committee
members who have now finished work on
all your spills
that's done
so uh we're going to be going into
executive session next week
and we're going to we're going to work
it hard
we're going to be looking at up to a
dozen 15 bills a day
but this should go pretty fast
okay anybody else have any questions
before we adjourn
okay we are adjourned
thank you
you